[музика]
Ну що ж Добрий день Добрий день шановні
учасники ми готові розпочинати раді
вітати нас на сьогоднішньому заході
Попереду у нас великі спринт великим
марафон Отож дуже дякуємо за те що
долучились її нас сьогодні чекає
сповнений інформацією відкриттів
інсайтів день ото шановні гості та
учасники інформаційного дня Horizon
Europe lunchday in Ukraine Я радий
вітати вас сьогодні оскільки ти що ми
зібралися разом на цьому заході означає
що Україна досягла успіхів у своєму
прагненні долучитись до ранкової
програми Європейського Союзу і з
досліджень та інновацій горизонт Європа
та програми із досліджень та навчання
євфратом на цій площадці Ми зібрали
провідних учених дослідників і Новаторів
представників центральних органів
виконавчої влади малого та середнього
бізнесу та широко громадськість для
обговорення досягнутих результатів та
формування майбутніх пріоритетів
розвитку України у сфері науки та
інновацій у розрізі нашої участі у
ранкових програмах із досліджень та
інновацій Дякуємо усім також можемо за
участь у сьогоднішньому заході і друзі Я
пропоную для того аби продемонструвати
те що готові те що прагнемо працювати
оплесками один одного привітати тут і
зараз сьогодні
Ну що ж друзі структура нашої
сьогоднішньої конференції нашого заходу
передбачає наступні 4 тематичні панелі у
першій частині із 12 години до 12:40
представники Міністерства освіти і науки
України що й організатором
сьогоднішнього дня та Європейської
комісії розкажуть про здійснення кроки
на шляху асоціації до програми горизонт
Європа та європам та інтеграції України
до Європейського дослідницького простору
далі перед нами відкриється Нові
горизонти та будуть розглянуті
можливості та перспективи для України У
рамках цієї частини програми ми зможемо
провести панельну дискусію між
представниками влади та наукової
спільноти щодо підтримки та залученості
держави у реалізацію програми із 14 до
14:30 всіх запрошених очікує кавабрик а
одразу після кавабрику розпочнеться блок
щодо європейських та національних
інструментів підтримки досліджень та
інновацій колеги із європейською
комісією скажуть про нові можливості які
відкриваються перед нашими учасниками у
зв'язку із приєднанням до горизонту
Європа після 16 години українські
спікери долучаться до обговорення та
розкажуть у свою чергу про національні
інструменти які відкриті для провідних
науковців та інноваторів після короткої
паузи розпочнеться заключний блок
присвячений кращим українським проектам
попередньої рамковий програми горизонт
Як ви можете бачити у нас сьогодні
достатньо напружене достатньо щільний
графік тому Закликаємо усіх спікерів
дотримуватися регламенту дотримуватись
таймінгу Ну і власне для того аби
Сьогодні у нас все було логічно чітко та
враховуючи графік протягом нашого заходу
буде забезпечений синхронний переклад
тому якщо є потреба у перекладі до
присутніх у цьому залі то будь ласка
якраз час взяти пристрої Для прикладу
для того аби максимально комфортно для
себе провести У цей час
також прохання до спікерів протягом
ваших виступів будь ласка робіть логічні
паузи тим петримати для того аби можна
було забезпечити усі переваги
синхронного прикладу та зробити його
чіткі Ну що ж ми готові розпочинати Ще
раз вітаємо усіх також на вітаємо усіх
присутніх у цій залі вітаємо усіх
учасників які долучилися до нашої
трансляції дуже багато зараз дивляться
нас у живому ефірі усім такожному вдячні
за те що долучились тут і зараз за те що
прямуєте до інноваційних горизонтів за
те що прагнете творити мріяти досягати і
демонструвати високі результати
здобутків натхнення плідної роботи
сьогодні І ми готові розпочати Ну що ж
розпочинаємо наш сьогоднішній захід і з
перегляду відео про нові горизонти
України тож увага на екран
2015 рік Україна долучилася до
найбільшої програми ЄС з досліджень та
інновацій у горизонт 2020 наша держава
стала асоційованим членом програми а
відтак Українські науковці можуть брати
участь у конкурсах на рівні з
європейськими колегами
[музика]
7 років України в горизонті це
можливість реалізувати свої ідеї для
сотень українських вчених винахідників
Та інноваторів це фінансування майже 230
високу якісних наукових проєктів для
державних установ та бізнесу це майже 46
мільйонів євро від ЄС в тому числі на
проєкти який координувала саме Україна а
також колаборації з провідними
європейськими країнами
горизонті 2020 Українські науковці та
підприємці працюють над передовими
проєктами з доступом до унікальних даних
Мене звати чигерева Анастасія Я беру
участь у проекті під назвою polaresa це
проект в рамках горизонту 2020 як
науковиця Антарктичного центру Анастасія
досліджує полярні хмари в арктиці та
Антарктиці щоб оцінити зміни клімату в
цих регіонах завдяки горизонту 2020 Ми
маємо унікальну можливість співпраці з
інститутами європейськими нас сприймають
на рівних ми будемо використовувати
унікальні дані маємо вперше за достатньо
довгий час можливість реальної оцінки
ситуації
в популярних регіонах Київський
політехнічний інститут тут науковці
Дмитро Королюк Сергій Сіренко Юрій
Якименко та Юрій Гордієнко в межах
горизонту 2020 розробляють автоматичного
радника лікаря на основі штучного
інтелекту який зможе визначити
оптимальну терапію онкозахворювань це
велика консолідація європейських сил
завдяки проєкту вони об'єдналися з
кращими світовими вченими і мають доступ
до унікальних медичних даних без яких
застосування радника було б неможливим
фантастична програма яка дозволяє нам
інтегруватися з зі світовою наукою
науковці з інституту сорбції і проблем
ендоекології нан україни досліджують і
розробляють енергоакомулючі пристрої А
ще працюють в науково-дослідні
лабораторії компанії Юнеско що продає
дослідні зразки таких пристроїв у
горизонті ми приймаємо участь у
виконанні трьох проектів які спрямовані
на вирішення проблем енергозбереження
команда створює інноваційні акумулятори
та досліджує як можна покращити існуючі
енергоносії досвід участі проект та
горизонт 2020 він просто колосальний в
одному з проектів є смак Ми отримали
доступ до
дослідницького обладнання яке Ми навіть
і не мріяли інший проект та стробат
дозволив нам поповнити нашу матеріальну
базу він нам дозволить закупити
обладнання яке Ми не можемо купити в
Україні
[музика]
Україна і надалі продовжить співпрацю з
ЄС угоду про участь в новій програмі
горизонт Європа та євроатом підписали 12
жовтня 2021 року це визначний крок для
України Українські вчені і Новатори та
підприємці зможуть не тільки брати
участь а й залучати грантові кошти для
реалізації спільних міжнародних проектів
по програмі горизонт Європа та Європи а
також мати доступ до всіх інструментів
підтримки вищезгаданих програм
нова дослідницька програма Євросоюзу
горизонт Європа - це три основні напрями
для наукових та інноваційних проєктів із
бюджетом понад 95 з половиною мільярдів
євро це додаткові інструменти фінансової
підтримки та партнерства програми це
можливість створювати колаборації та
консорціуми з провідними країнами світу
а також можливість долучитися до
вирішення глобальних викликів людства
наступного десятиліття як того зміни
клімату четверта промислова революція
інфекційні хвороби та їхні наслідки тощо
тож запрошую всіх учасників долучитися
до програми горизонт Європа та Європи
які відкривають нові можливості для
потужного розвитку науки та інновацій
нашої держави втілюйте сміливі ідеї в
горизонт Європа
Ну що ж дякуємо дякуємо бачимо те що
здобутки насправді величезні як бачимо
із цього відео реалізація програми
горизонт 2020 Та є наступниці горизонт
Європа сприяє не тільки тісні міжнародні
кооперації але й розбудові нашого
наукового та інноваційного сектору Ну що
ж так тримати і рухаємось уперед до
подальшого втілення програми для
офіційно відкриття сьогоднішнього заходу
запрошую до слова заступника міністра із
питань європейської інтеграції
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Олексія шкуратова будь ласка пане
Олексію вам слово
привітаємо оплескими будь ласка
дякую
Доброго дня шановні колеги Шановні
учасники шановні європейські колеги та
всі хто долучився до нашого
сьогоднішнього заходу
Rising europplanesday in Ukraine Для
мене велика честь та радість сьогодні
відкрити даний захід Адже для України це
знаменуй момент коли українські вчені
інноватори винахідники
для них відкривається нові можливості У
рамках однієї з найбільших програм
Європейського союзу з досліджень та
інновацій
для України долучення до програми
горизонт Європа Та євратом є важливим
кроком у напрямку у інтеграції України і
вітчизняного наукового простору до
Європейського дослідницького простору
реалізація програм створить передумови
необхідні для прискорення становлення
України як впливовою європейською
державою
зокрема шляхом розширення міжнародного
науково-технічного співробітництва
створення сприятливих умов для
здійснення науково-дослідницької
діяльності комуналізації розробок
розбудови національної інноваційної
сфери розвитку співробітництва з
європейськими країнами
І як було зазначено на відео 12 жовтня
2021 року на 23-му самі Україна і
Європейський союз було підписано
офіційно угоду між Україною і ЄС та
Європейським товариством затомної
енергії про участь України у двох
програмах горизонт Європа та
комплементарні програмі до неї з
досліджень та навчань і врата
Я хотів би особисто та від імені
Міністерства подякувати всім
європейським колегам які були долучені
до довготривалого але як бачимо
результативного проекту
Зокрема я дякую голові делегації
заступнику генерального директора
директорату науки та інновація
Європейської комісії пані сейнерцо
вона сьогодні погодилась відкрити наш
захід зі сторони європейських партнерів
і Протягом цього тривалого часу команда
з обох боків пліч-о-пліч працювали для
забезпечення можливості долучення
України і набуття нами статусу
асоційованої країни
звісно перед нами ще стоїть завдання
Виконання всіх внутрішньодержавних
процедур з метою ратифікації цієї угоди
Але завдячуючись тому що для України
діють вже перехідні умови і ми вже
спочатку 21-го року мали право Приймати
участь у відкритих конкурсах
приєднання до наступної програми з
досліджень та інновацій горизонт Європа
та програми євратом сприятиме широкому
залученню української наукової спільноти
до участі в міжнародних проектах
формуватиме новий рівень якості
освітнього процесу в Україні та
забезпечують ефективну міжнародну
співпрацю
і те що ми сьогодні зібрались тут у
такому ж широкому колі представників і
центральних органів влади і Наукової
спільноти підприємців інноваторів
представників громадського сектору не
тільки з України а й зі сторони
Європейського Союзу свідчить про
актуальність і необхідність реалізації
вищезгаданих програм
тому Дозвольте ще раз поздоровити нас з
цією прекрасною подією побажати всім
учасникам та гостям отримати максимальну
кількість корисної інформації протягом
заходу і Бажаю всім е-е цікавих дискусій
і гарних результатів я вам всім вдячний
Ну що ж дуже дякуємо Олексій шкуратов
заступник Міністра з питань європейської
інтеграції Міністерства освіти і науки
України Дуже дякуємо Дуже дякуємо
Міністерство освіти та науки України за
усі кроки які роблять це для того аби і
новаційному простору в Україні справді
буде аби і Новатори втілювали в життя
свої проекти адже за інноваціями
майбутнє і у кожен із нас повинен
відчувати те що справді є потужні
інструменти завдяки які можна бути
попереду світу попереду планети усі є
творити втілювати досягати Ну і власне
реалізовувати круті та неймовірні
проекти Отож колеги Отож долучаємось до
усіх ініціатив Ну і власне саме завдяки
отакій колаборації саме завдяки
підтримці наших європейських колег ми
можемо досягнути успіху ми можемо
досягнути неймовірних результатів на
шляху до втілення і новацій Ну що ж і
справді Без наших європейських колег ми
не змогли би досягнути усіх тих
горизонтів які досягли на цьому шляху Ну
і власне отримати статус асоційованої
країни до слова запрошується заступниця
генерального директора директора та
науки інновації Європейської комісії
пані сігне радсо будь ласка
міністра
шановні
представники наукової спільноти І
Новатори горизонт Європа в Україні я
дійсно
погоджуюся з темою нашої події
і
вже час приєднатися до горизонту Європа
і ви мабуть знаєте що я головний
Перемовник
для програми
його горизонт Європа і євратом і ми вели
перемовини щоб Україна взяла участь у
обох програмах і я бачила
а
сама на власні очі як
відбулися ці перемови і результат ми
маємо вже зараз тепер ми запускаємо в
Україні
програми
дослідження Я знаю що в цей час пандемії
карантинних обмежень
це
непростий час
багато чого відбувається і Якщо говорити
про інновації то ми зараз
в ситуації де дослідження новації є
частину невід'ємною частиною нашого
життя і є
ряд інструментів які дозволяє
малому бізнесу стартапам науковцям
долучитися до чудових можливостей
Україна
- Це новий учасник Таких програм
ви вже обрали участь в горизонт 2020
попередніми програмами євроатома і ця
програма два горизонт 2020 закінчується
але в нас є багато учасників які
отримали
вже
великосомо
і Україна зараз одна з
країн які асоціюються з
програмою горизонт 22:20
і бере участь у програмі євроатом
Україна
збільшує розширює свою участь у
дослідженні Якщо говорити про майбутнє
то ви зараз приєднуєтесь приєднуйтеся до
найбільша амбітної програми звинувації
які яка була створена
за майже
та мільярдним бюджетом на наступний рік
і цей бюджет буде збільшений на 40%
Тепер я хочу
згадати про цілі горизонт Європа
це головний строк для того щоб розширити
нашу наукову дослідницького базу
поширити цифрові трансформації і
заходи з ліквідації наслідків зміни
клімату
і 40% бюджету буде при
спрямовано на покращення клімату
і цифрові трансформації
А ще цілі - це
перехідні
перехідний період для енергосектору
безпекового сектору
радіаційної промисловості
авіакосмічної індустрії і в мене є
багато очікування від України і я
хочу сказати вам науковці і компанії
Новатори національні контактні точки
інституції мають
використати цей досвід і скористатися
можливістю
як кинуда і є наша європейська програма
І мені приємно бачити що наш порядок
денний
дозволяє до несуть інформацію до світлих
умів України
розказуючи їм про різні
деталі про наші програми Я сподіваюся що
ви будете натхнення
і я хочу заохотити вас ставити запитання
особливо моїм колегам які будуть
розказувати про різні аспекти про
програм Я хочу зазначити тільки основні
компоненти Як ви знаєте
горизонт розбитий на три стовпи перший
стовп горизонт Європа буде
просувати
дослідження
і також
тут будуть брати участь
ініціатива дії Марії колодовської Кюрі
У вас є 1 Гранд і Росії і я думаю що
вони будуть презентувати свою роботу
сьогодні ось другий
другий стовп - це цифрові амбіції зміни
клімату там є різні кластери пріоритети
сюди входять різні інструменти
і ми представимо ці інструменти пізніше
сьогодні якраз
мені ця галузь дуже цікава я хочу щоб
Україна долучилася дійсно до цього і
третій стовп пов'язаний з інноваціями
для того щоб забезпечити щоб всі ці
наукові ідеї вийшли на ринок
тут якраз європейські союзи новації грає
дуже велику роль Він допомагає стартапам
Я знаю що Україна запустила свої свій
план для стартапів тобто будемо бачити
багато цікавих
співпраці і Звичайно є братом
і давайте не будемо забувати що нова
програма буде
мати справу з медичними і іншими
застосуваннями цих ініціатив
і нарешті
Слід зазначити
різні
науково-дослідницькі центри
о є різні плани для передачі
технології які забезпечує grc ви
сьогодні дізнаєтесь набагато більше про
це пані та панове це нова фаза участь в
програмі
і ви досягнете нових висот
і
горизонт Європа євротом
вже запущені в Україні я бажаю вам
успіхів дякую
Ну що ж дуже дякуємо дуже дякуємо за
програму Дякуємо за тісну співпрацю між
Україною та Європейським Союзом та
країнами-партнерами і Дякуємо за те що
основний Пріоритет у нас все наука та
інновація дуже дякуємо за цю співпрацю
за підтримку і за програму ну що ж
колеги ваші Оплески ваші Оплески бачите
що посмішки у залі бачити що є уже дав
руки які долоньки які готові долучитись
до того аби подякувати за то все І
дійсно є Чому радіти є чимось дякувати
Адже у нас потужна програма Адже у нас
потужні можливості для того аби і
новації науковий сектор для того аби
взаємодія колаборація дійсно втілювалась
у життя для того аби втілити інноваційні
проекти насправді потрібно дуже багато
компонент дуже багато компонент завдяки
яким можна досягнути успіху Одна справа
коли просто є ідея але проблема в тому
що ідея сама по собі нічого не варта
потрібно йти про комунікувати перевірити
наскільки справді ця ідея потрібна
нашому клієнту наскільки у нас широкій
проблем Space на скільки справді Кожне з
нас готовий втілювати і новації стартапи
для того аби вирішити істотну насущну
проблему А ще потрібно про ідею про
комунікувати про піччати розказати
представити отримати підтримку адже Одна
справа цей ідея сама по собі інша справа
- це ідея яка втілена у проект в MW
Прототип і яка готова далі
комерціалізуватись патентуватись Ну і
власне про яку можна розказати широкому
загалом руки потрібно зробити чимало це
є пропрацювання ідеї за технологія
бізнес-крем Василинки це є натхненна
робота команди пошук своїх людей тих хто
готовий працювати зранку до ночі аби
втілювати потужні наукові та інноваційні
думки це і перевірка валідації
відповідних ідей це спринти із дизайн
thinking is a jiel завдяки пандемії
завдяки корона кризі Кожний з нас відчув
те що
іншійл тренер стала пандеміями стала
такі діджіл ми втілимо потужні великі
кроки незважаючи на те Які обмеження у
нас може діяти Ну і при цьому Звісно
якщо є підтримка Звісно якщо є як гроші
так І так звані Smart Money У такому
випадку за підтримки інвесторів
партнерів мендерів ми з вами можемо
досягнути на порядок більше власне цьому
і буде присвячена наша наступна
тематична панелька наш наступний виступ
Отож для того аби висвітити здійснення
кроків із метою нашої успішної
інтеграції до Європейського
дослідницького простору Ми запрошуємо до
слова виконуючого обов'язки генерального
директора директора та науки та
інновації Міністерства освіти і науки
України Григорія озилевича будь ласка
Запрошуємо та вітаємо на сцені нашому
блисками
Доброго дня шановні колеги вибачаюсь
корабля на бал Як то кажуть
як працює цей інструмент значить я хотів
би вам сказати що
Міністерство освіти і науки України
здійснює всі необхідні кроки з метою
інтеграції нашої з вами країни до
Європейського дослідницького простору
сьогодні я доповім вам про те що ми
зробили цього року про те які у нас є
плани на найближче майбутнє
які у нас є успіхи і з якими питаннями
ми працюємо наразі в уряді і з нашими
європейськими колегами
на початку скажу про деякі
речі
ну по-перше наука технології інновації
беззаперечно є ключовим інструментом для
інтеграції європейській дослідницький
простір і про це розуміє
Міністерство про це розуміє уряд про це
розуміє президент
і ми не можемо сказати що в нас немає
проблем у нас насправді є деякі проблеми
Але ми з ними працюємо по-перше проблема
- це дослідницька інфраструктура з якою
працюють наші українські вчені
по-друге це недосконалі бюджетні
інструменти
підтримки
проектів на національному рівні І
можливо частково на міжнародному рівні
по-третє - це
низький поки що рівень співпраці
українських науковців з промисловістю та
бізнесу
однак
ми цього року затвердили концепцію
державної програми розвитку
науково-дослідницьких інфраструктур на
2021-26 рок і вже розробили проект самої
державної програми
наразі йдуть останні узгодження з
міністерством фінансів України і
сподіваюсь найближчим часом розгляд цієї
важливої державної програми буде
винесений на уряд
по-друге
цього року був прийнятий закон який
сприяє розвитку наукових парків цей
закон нам надасть можливість
зменшити бюрократичні навантаження
закладах вищої освіти в наукових
установах для створення таких парків і
сприятиме їх ефективному розвитку
по-третє цього року був
поданий на розгляд Верховної Ради
законопроект щодо стимулювання
діяльності у сфері технології буквально
Минулого тижня Комітет Верховної Ради з
питань науки освіти та інновацій
розглядав цей проект закону деякі були
висунуті зауваження думаю що найближчим
часом директорат науки та інновацій
доопрацює ці зауваження і закон буде
розглянутий вже Верховною Радою України
далі хотів би зазначити що Україна
приєдналась цього року до глобальної
пілотної програми Організації Об'єднаних
Націй
спрямованою на підтримку країн щодо
розробки дорожніх карт
які пов'язані були б вибачаюсь з
реалізацією і досягненням цілей сталого
розвитку
Організації Об'єднаних Націй
по-третє хотів би зазначити що зараз
велика Наша команда працює над
створенням національного плану з
відкритої науки грав цього документу вже
розроблений він доопрацьовується і думаю
на початку
2022 року цей документ потрапить вже на
громадське обговорення
також
Міністерство розробило
такий фундаментальні зміни до Закону Про
наукову науково-технічну діяльність які
пов'язані також з питаннями відкритої
науки пов'язані з
діяльністю молодих вчених і також
пов'язані з розвитком дослідницької
інфраструктури
Також хотів би зазначити що
велика робота була пророблена для того
щоб в Європейському Союзі був створений
проект який би допоміг нам зробити
якісний аудит дослідницького
інфраструктури наявної в Україні
і який би допоміг нам
визначити
якісні пріоритети розвитку цієї
інфраструктури оскільки Європейські
країни вже давно зрозуміли що окрема
країна не може будувати все А кожен
обирає свій пріоритет і з цим
пріоритетом заходить в Європейський
дослідницький простір і свою
інфраструктуру надає всім вченим в тому
числі не тільки українським умовно так
само як і країни Європейського Союзу
маючи унікальні дослідницькі
інфраструктури потім надають доступ в
тому числі нашим чином
і цей проект буде стартувати вже на
початку 22-го року в нас підтверджена
інформація про фінансування з
Європейської сторони вже обрані експерти
і якщо не помиляюсь 17 чи 19 січня він
вже буде презентований
можна ще зазначити про те що
Протягом цього року
є значне просування щодо створення
національної електронної
науково-інформаційної системи уріс яка б
допомогла зменшити
значне бюрократичне навантаження на
наших українських вчених з точки зору
пошуку підготовки різного роду
документів пошуку інформації про себе
про участі таке інше ми хочемо зробити
таку глобальну вже розробляємо таку
глобальну базу знань де Центральна
фігура буде український вчений і про
нього можна буде підтягнути всю наявну
інформацію яка існує і програнти і про
наукові праці і про участь заходах і
таке інше для того щоб кожен вчений не
мав особливої необхідності подаючи свої
роботи на черговий грант або на черговий
конкурс збирати десь в себе по папочкам
окремого роду документу і таким чином
щоб всі її бази цю інформацію можна було
швидко підтягувати із іншого боку
експертам потім перевіряти справжність
тієї чи іншої інформації
тепер те що стосується по суті головного
12 жовтня Я думаю що можливо ви про це
вже почули сьогодні Україна підписала
угоду про долучення до наступної
рамкової програми горизонт Європа
наразі законопроект Про ратифікацію цієї
угоди вже знаходиться в офісі президента
України і думаю що вже в грудні цього
року потрапить на розгляд Верховної Ради
України Ми з моїми колегами
і в тому числі по іншим міністерством із
Кабінетом міністрів України пройшли оцей
важкий шлях Україна стала першою країною
східного партнерства яка підписала таку
угоду
попереду нас не з членів Європейського
Союзу були тільки Норвегія і Ісландія
які мали зовсім інші
питання в рамках співпраці з горизонтом
тому я вважаю що перероблена була
фундаментальна робота яка має
конкретні наслідки і яка сподівається
українських вчених призведе до того що
вони якомога раніше потраплять в
спільний Пул
спільні колаборації з європейськими
вченими і ми не будемо мати таку картину
яку мали на початку приєднання до
попередньої рамкової програми Коли ще
ніхто не знав куди бігти Що робити що
збирати куди подавати деколи шукати і
таке інше От у нас вже є інформація про
те що перші два проекти на суму 800
тисяч євро
були обрані до для фінансування в рамках
цієї програми Я думаю що найближчим
часом кількість таких проектів буде
збільшуватись
і
Україна буде мати
експоненційне таке зростання
в наступній рамковій програмі що ми
хочемо зробити для того щоб участь
українських вчених стала якіснішою більш
масштабною
Ну по-перше ви знаєте що у нас існувала
мережа національних контактних пунктів
яка працювала з
попередньою рамковою програмою і
намагалась
бути
головним
інформаційним джерелом для всіх вчених і
не тільки вчених і підприємців
організацій тощо
в рамковій програмі горизонт-220 цю
мережу ми вже поступово удосконалюємо ми
будемо розробляти новий
нормативно-правовий акт який буде
пов'язаний з розвитком цієї мережі у нас
є мрія створити офіс програми горизонт
Європа в Україні
і є вже підтримка декількох міністерств
в цьому сенсі
у нас буде проведено
значна робота і вже вона відбувається
щодо запуску національного порталу
горизонт Європа технічна технічним
завданням вже працюють виконавці Я
сподіваюсь що безпосередньо над
створенням цього порталу
Ми почнемо працювати з перших днів 20
другого року
це головні меседжі які я вам хотів би
сказати сьогодні Я вас прошу
приєднуватись до розповсюдження
інформації про програму горизонт Європа
про її можливості
серед своїх колег
всі коли програми відкрити для
українських учасників українських
організацій практично з травня квітня
2021 року
і в усіх відкритих колах ви можете брати
участь сміливо знаючи інформацію про те
що український уряд в 22-му році
сплатить відповідні внески після
ратифікації закону І
проекти будуть для української сторони в
тому числі про фінансу Дякую за увагу
якщо будуть питання Я готова відповідати
Ну що ж то вже дякуємо
Григорій мозолевич виконуючий обов'язки
генерального директора директора авто
науки та інновацій Міністерства освіти і
науки України Дуже дякуємо і пропозиція
усі питання які будуть залишити на
кавабри якщо ви не проти для того аби У
кулі нетворкінгу поспілкуватися обійняти
з думками і плідно попрацювати заради
того аби наступні кроки проговорити та
втілити Ну що ж Дякуємо дуже
Міністерство освіти і науки України за
усі ці кроки які роблять у напрямку того
аби інтегруватись до Європейського
наукового та дослідницького простору Ну
і власне на собі відчуємо і відчуваємо
ті результати ті здобутки які уже стають
нашим світом і новацій втілелень та
звершень Ну що ж колеги рухаємось далі
рухаємося до наступної тематичної панелі
і У рамках наступної тематичної панелі
ми з вами поговоримо про основні розділи
програми горизонт Європа та Європи Ну і
власне цьому присвячена наша наступна
сесія
міської ради запросити до слова
представника програмного комітету
програми євротам яка направлена на
здійснення перспективних досліджень та й
інноваційних проектів у сфері ядерної
енергетики термоядерного синтезу та
ядерного поділу Отож Ігор Гаркуша
Запрошуємо до слова і про Гаркуша є
представником програмного комітету
євротам ф'южен термоядерний синтез
представляє національний науковий центр
Харківський фізико-технічний інститут
Отож Запрошуємо увага на екран
дякую доброго дня шановні колеги вітання
з Харкова з національного контактного
пункту євратом Україна своєму виступі я
Буду намагатися коротко висвітлити
сучасний стан та такі перспективи які
відкриваються в програмі
єврата в рамках наступної програми
горизонт Європа мушу зауважити що
Україна уклала єдину угоду про асоціацію
як горизонт Європа Та євратам а що
стосується європам то я загалом то буду
зупинюсь на двох таких напрямах програми
діяльності і дослідження втратам це
термоядерні дослідження як основа
Зелена енергетики майбутнього це
фактично стратегічне джерело енергії яке
немає CO2 викидів Як ви знаєте а також я
зупинюсь на дослідженнях напрямі
ядерного ділення що сфокусовані на
питаннях екології та безпеки утилізації
редактивних відходів тощо обидва ці
напрями є вкрай важли для нашої держави
для України е-е що стосується
термоядерної програми євратом то вона
виконується в рамках єдиного створеного
загальноєвропейського консорціуму під
назвою єврофюжин який включає в себе 30
бенефіціарів з різних країн наразі
Велика Британія та Швейцарія ще на
стадії укладання угоди для нової
програми і також Юра фюжен включає
більше ніж 150
афілійованих національними бенефіціарами
установ як наукових так і університетів
так і приватних компаній тощо і Україна
була залучена і залученою в діяльністю
е-е єврофюжен починаючи з 2017 року і
вже на протязі цих років виконання
програми горизонт 2020 дуже великий дуже
хороші результати були отримані і наразі
вже дуже успішний старт вже наступної
рамкової програми відбувся так
які ви бачите тут на слайді він вже
підготував пропозицію для в рамках
програми горизонт Європа і Ця пропозиція
рісоч пропов а-а була уже нещодавна е-е
затверджена європейською комісією наразі
відбувається підписання
консорціум гранти Грімм на 20-21 років
та 20-25 і ця вже підписання вже на
фінальній стадії Фактично це є Перша
ластівка української участі в проектах
евратама уже в рамках нової горизонт
Європа і Уже в цьому консорці в
єврофюжин на
20-21-2025 уже фактично створений
український дослідницький юніт який
включає в себе
три інститути Національної академії наук
це Харківський інститут Харківський
фізико-технічний інститут інститут
ядерних досліджень
інститут теоретичної фізики імені
Боголюбова а також три наших
провідних університетів - Це
каразинський університет - Це Тарас
Шевченко національний університет і
Національний університет Львівська
політехніка там лабораторія магнітних
сенсорів що очолює професор Большакова
кпті представляє український рисучий
Юність в єврофюжені як менеджер програми
від Happy ви бачите тут уже підписана
угода бути таким менеджером на наступну
програму і
ми маємо
права голоса на єврофюжин-женерала
семблі але найбільш важлива для наших
дослідників те що українські дослідники
будуть мати і вже мають і будуть
продовжувати мати доступ до європейських
експериментальних установах таких як
така маті Джет
аздекс Must tcv а також теларатор
венденштейн севенкс у свою чергу
наприклад кафеті має теж потужні
дослідницькі установки такі як плазмові
прискорювачі та стеларатори ураган які
теж завдяки цьому мають бути нагоду бути
залученими в в
калабаритів
мушу сказати що
ми вітаємо будь-які інші партнери з
України з боку це може бути і
університет це може бути і приватна
компанія і це може бути
науково-дослідний інститут який
проводить роботи пов'язане з
термоядерними дослідженнями разом із тим
мушу сказати тут Що переважна більшість
проектів Європи Вона реалізується за
принципом копанки фінансування причому
Європейська комісія вона сплачує вже за
підсумками року здійснює відшкодування
так званої римбардсмен вже витрачених за
даний рік-ресурсів Зазвичай це
55%. тому для успішної участі в
програмах евратам критично важливим для
нас є наявність відповідних національних
проектів як українська і складової цього
кофан фактично Саме цей чинник а не
рівень наукових розробок є основним
зараз обмеженням для подальшого
зростання нашої участі в програмах е-е
євратам і це стосується в першу чергу і
наших установ наукових і також є
освітніх особливо університети бо вони
зазвичай не мають довгострувалих
науково-дослідницьких проектах у цієї
галузі і тому дуже важливий нещодавний
запуск міністерством освіти і науки
конкурсу в проектів на підтримку участі
нашої горизонт Європа а також інші
національний конкурси на кшталт
національного фонду досліджень е-е та
базове фінансування установ все це має
більш
має бути більш чіткіше спокусованим на
європейській пріоритети нашої участі і
це безумовно буде допомагати нам
поширювати свою участь я не хочу сказати
що вона е зараз якось обмежена вона дуже
потужна особливо в Європі і особливо
приємно зазначити що вона поєднує і
науку і освіту Ось на цьому слайді ми
бачимо освітню діяльність в рамках
єврофюжен зараз є три головних там
Фактора це є фузинет Європі unfusion
Education Network і приємно що
каразинський університет уже приймає
участь в цьому і ця фузинет е-е
асоціація вона сприяє подорожам участі
студентів і аспірантів в європейських
мітингах зустрічах є окремий рок-нпекич
Education eurora Fusion наразі ми маємо
близько 60 тисяч євро підтримку від
на цей напрям і тому кожний бенефіціар
кожний установа може отримати
відшкодування в засвіту Я також цільовий
коледж інженерних і дослідницьких
гарантів І я також спільні join TV
наприклад був в Європі античнівент по
термоядерним дослідженням він відбувся
нещодавно в
22-23 числа І це дає змогу нашим
аспірантам спілкуватися більш плід нас
європейськими колегами що стосується
ядерної частини тут наразі йде 15
проектів активних які були переходять із
горизонту 2020 горизонт Європа вони 19 і
25-й рік що стосується горизонтів Європа
то тут є
вже
16 кольорів для пропози вони вже були
відбулися до дедлайн був е-е Що сьомого
жовтня і я очікую шановні проекти з
української участю тут з'являться також
є два відкритих кола - це інноваційний
приз для термоядерних і для ядерних
досліджень тощо наступний раунд
очікується в
[музика]
навесні 23-го року як приклад такого
проекту є ось проєкт який залучено два
бенефіціари як е-е українських і два
інституту як партнери це національний
науковий центр а також інститут геохімії
навколишнього середовища і закінчує тим
що розпочав свою виступ в Україні працює
національний контактний пункт євратом в
Україні які її з якого я зараз її
доповідаю і завдання цього пункту якраз
е-е
комунікувати з українськими науковцями
надавати консультативні послуги
допомагати їм підготовки нових проектів
ви бачите тут сайт який є контактного
пункту євратом Україна то будь-хто може
будь ласка звертайтеся будемо раді
допомогти в наступній програмі Дякую вам
за увагу
Ну що ж Дякуємо вам Дякуємо дуже ігри
Гаркуша представник програмного комітету
євратам ф'южен термоядерний синтез
національний науковий центр Харківський
фізико-технічний інститут дякуємо
дякуємо за інформацію Ну і власне бачимо
те що справді неймовірних результатів
досягли наші вчені у галузі ядерної
фізики та радіаційного захисту Отож Так
тримати Ну що ж ми тим часом рухаємось
далі як уже озвучував таймінг У нас
сьогодні дуже щільний програма сповнена
різноманітними дискусіями виступами і
дуже багато цінної інформації сьогодні
буде презентовано Отож українські
учасники активно беруть участь за всіма
напрямками програми це безумовно але
Слід відмітити що все ж У деяких
напрямках наша долученість все-таки
трошечки вища ніж в інших і якраз зараз
розкажемо про напрям дії мрії
Склодовської вікюрі який спрямований на
підтримку навчання мобільності та
розвитку кар'єри науковців як з країн
Європейського Союзу так із асоційованих
країн про цей напрям та більше про весь
розділ програми провідна наука більш
детально розкаже пані Карина шахбазян
яка не один рік успішно працює
національним контактним пунктом Отож
пані Карино будь ласка вам слово
Каріна шагбазян дім мрія Склодовської
корів головний науковий співробітник
центру досліджень інтелектуальної
власності та транспротехнологій
національної академії наук України Ще
раз підгортаємо оплескими будь ласка
і все на ваше вам слово Дякую дуже
[музика]
сьогоднішнього заходу І побажати успіхів
і плідної співпраці сьогодні і надалі в
програмі горизонт Європа ну моє завдання
розповісти про перший напрямок програми
горизонт Європа а саме передавав наука
як ми бачимо він складається з трьох
напрямків з трьох складових великих
програм це
європейська дослідницька рада це
програма дій Марії скадовської Кюрі і
дослідницькі інфраструктури разом на
перший цей напрямок виділяється чверть
бюджету програми горизонт це приблизно
25 млрд євро і всі вони повинні піти на
основну мету на укріплення і розширення
наукової бази Європейського Союзу і на
підтримку передової науки те що в
документах юрбатській комісії має назву
Frontier reset дійсно тут робиться
наголос дійсно на передових дослідженнях
але і на відміну від інших напрямків
програми горизонт 2020 і горизонт Європа
тут ще робиться ще один наголос на
безпосереднє рушійну силу всіх інновацій
всіх новаторств науки і такого іншого це
дослідник це науковець і велика увага
приділяється розвитку кар'єри науковця
створенню
достойних можливостей і умов де його
праці для його життя для життя його
сімей це це все основні такі завдання
цієї цього напрямку
і також на відміну від інших напрямків
програми
рамкових рамкових програми онукових
досліджень і новацій в цьому напрямку
можлива участь індивідуальних учасників
індивідуальних науковців чого неможливо
робити в інших напрямках це мають бути
лише колективи
науковців колективи учасників а тут
можлива роботи індивідуального
дослідника і також ще одна
відміна риса - це те що має назву знову
ж таки в документах ботом а п proвич
тобто коли науковець має сам може сам
самостійно представити тематику свого
наукового проекту в усіх інших напрямках
як ми як ми знаємо оголошуються вже
конкурси за певною визначеної тематикою
тут науковець має свободу в тому щоб
вирішувати як йому працювати І на яку
над якою тематикою тож переходимо до
першого напрямку це гранти європейської
дослідницької ради
європейського дослідницька рада це
орган який займається організацією
грантово фінансування передових наукових
досліджень і які мають втілювати в життя
найкращі науковці найвищого рівня з
Європи з третіх країн тут обмежені за
громадянством немає але це наукові
дослідження мають відбуватись в Європі
також це ця рада вона була заснована в
2007 році як компонент ще сьомий
ранкової програми і в принципі з того
часу її функції лишаються незмінними як
приклад незмінності
політики Європейського Союзу у цій сфері
у сфері підтримки проривних досліджень
єдине що раніше вважалась
а гранти європейських дослідницької ради
то це підтримка фундаментальної науки
майже виключно але в принципі з часом
вже ці риси змінюються і ми розуміємо що
підтримується не лише фундаментальна
наука але і прикладна наука і інновації
тобто все весь цей комплекс Він має бути
присутнім і щоб були проривні результати
якісь відкриття не лише у
фундаментальній науці але й у подальшому
застосування їх в реальному житті так би
мовити да яким чином відбувається
оцінювання оцінюється подані проекти
лише за одним критерієм це критерії
досконалості і за цим критеріям
оцінюється як сам проект так і
оцінюється
того науковці який подається цей проект
потім коли Він отримує фінансування цей
дослідник принципу висаджує керівник
цього проекту він вже на свій розсуд
може набирати команду науковців
дослідників з якими він буде втілювати в
життя цей проект типи проектів є
стартовий Гранд є консолідований грант і
грант дванс Гранд простонутого рівня
тобто для грант для найбільш досвідчених
найбільш визнаних науковців які мають
видатні досягнення протягом останніх
десяти років і ще єсть енергетичний
грант Тобто це для груп двох від двох до
чотирьох дослідників які об'єднуються
для втілення
документу якоїсь дуже з амбіційного дуже
проекту і відповідним чином це і більш
тривалий проект і дійсно Він отримує
високе фінансування другий тип друга
програма це програма Маріє Склодовської
Кірі Де я є контактним національним
контактним пунктом До речі їх чотири по
Україні ну було так принаймні до
оголошеної тут
вдосконалення системи контактних пунктів
може їх буде більше але що таке програма
дій марічковський Квіт це грантова
підтримка надається
і окремим дослідникам це ми говоримо про
такий тип проєктів як пост докторські
стипендії тобто якщо минулій програмі Це
були індивідуалу щоб тобто індивідуальні
дослідники
чи мають вони науковий ступінь чи не
мають вони могли Приймати участь в цій
програмі вже тільки дослідники які мають
науковий ступінь можуть Приймати участь
і отримувати ці індивідуальні стипендії
для проведення наукових досліджень в
приймаючи установі в країні ЄС або в
третіх країнах це буде Global або іропія
також є тип проектів
докторським докторанській мережі це те
що було попередній програмі іноді
Network в цій програмі Це вже виключно
сконцентрувались на розробці програм
освітніх результатом якої стане набуття
ступеню
доктора філософії аспірантами і при
цьому це має Ну майже там Must have
залучення представників промисловості
для розробки спільних програм освітніх і
для подальшої супервізії над
плином цього проекту
ще один тип проєктів Марії Кюрі які є
найбільш успішним для українських
науковців це програма з обміну
персоналом обмін
кадрами які має назву став Ікс Changes в
цій програмі Це програма втілення
проектів дослідницьких засобом
короткострокових відряджень тобто
короткостроковому мобільність тут має
відбуватися цих проектах і таким чином
впроваджується цей науковий проект за
колективом з трьох різних країн
Європейського Союзу асоційованих країн і
третіх країн також новелою в програмі
горизонт Європа є те що раніше була
міжнародна і міжсекторальна мобільність
то в цьому в цій програмі дозволено ще і
міждисциплінарна мобільність Якщо йде
проект всередині якогось сектору що є
дуже важливими і це дійсно полегшує і
підбір концертів мої пошук партнерів
відповідним чином
і ще два типи проектів це кофант - це
спільне фінансування коли на
національному рівні міжнародному або
регіональному рівні існують програми вже
з надання грантів чи стипендії
аспірантам з умовою мобільності і
Європейська комісія якщо виграється ран
кофант то вона додає ще фінансування для
збільшення кількості аспірантів яких
можна профінансувати і для збільшення
обсягу цього гранту істотного обсягу і
ще одна остання такий тип дій - це діє
це він має назву в цій програмі дії
Марії Склодовської Кюрі і
громадяни Тобто це те що мала назву ніч
науковця попередньої програмі горизонт
2020 то це Таким чином має назву але
суть його не змінилась це коли
наукові організації науковці Вони мають
можливість представити свою наукове
технічні результати представити широкій
громадськості провести якісь
майстер-класи фестивалі науки зацікавити
молодь і дітей зацікавити в тому щоб
вони в подальшому обирали професії
пов'язані з наукою і наступний
третій третя програма напрямку Передова
наука це дослідницький інфраструктури це
об'єкти які забезпечують ресурси і
послуги для дослідницьких спільнот і
сприяють розвитку і в принципі метою
конкурсів дослідницькі інфраструктури в
програмі горизонт Європи і горизонт 2020
це було забезпечення саме розвитку таких
земель інтегрованих дослідницьких
інфраструктур створенню великих наукових
структур світового рівня світового
масштабу і також зазначено що крім
наукової безпосередньої діяльності цієї
дослідницькі інфраструктури вони можуть
забезпечувати ще і
освітні громадські заходи
прикладами таких інфраструктур це можуть
бути і велика масштабні науково-технічні
обладнання і колекція архіви наукових
даних і
це можуть бути і інші об'єкти
дослідницької інноваційної
інфраструктури але їх відмінною рисою
має бути по-перше їх унікальність в
чомусь і по-друге вони мають бути
відкритими для доступу громадян своєї
країни і громадян інших країн Це така їх
має бути така такий характер доступу до
них в рамках програми горизонт Європа
планується фінансування створення нових
потужних дослідницьких інфраструктур
світового масштабу на базі європейських
наукових установ і також інтеграція
діючих дослідницьких інфраструктур у
міжнародній мережі їх об'єднання і також
розвиток віртуальних дослідницьких
інфраструктур
тож Таким чином хочу привітати і ще раз
наших науковців з офіційним початком
програми горизонт Європа і закликати їх
приймати дуже активну участь не лише у
програмах Марії Кюрі я сам глобіну
персоналам але і усіх інших напрямках
щоб в цій програмі вже отримати і більше
грантів європейських дослідницької ради
і індивідуальні стипендії і долучатися
активно до
роботи дослідницьких інфраструктур
європейського рівня Дякую за увагу
Дякуємо дуже
Карина шербазян мкп дії Марія
склодовський Кирил головний науковець
співробітник центру досліджень
інтелектуальної власності та
транспротехнологій національної академії
наук України Ну що ж буквально кілька
хвилин а скільки цінної інформації да от
буквально одну годину ми з вами працюємо
А скільки уже думок виникло і скільки
різноманітних напрямків які можна
втілити заради того аби отримати для
себе справжню європейську наукову та
дослідницьку перспективу Отож рухаємось
далі не зупиняємось наш нон-стоп триває
загалом Якщо говорити про програму
горизонт Європа то вона розрахована на 7
років і чесно кажучи за оці 7 років
можна тільки уявити скільки викликів
постане Перед кожним із нас і перед
людством у цілому Це звісно і зміна
клімату це і впровадження здобутків
штучного інтелекту і зелена енергетика
Отож Все це потрібно обов'язково
враховувати це глобальні тренди і саме
про такі глобальні тренди виклики ми і
поговоримо Протягом нашої наступної
сесії і з радістю до слова запрошує пана
Сергія шукаєва представника
національного контактного пункту на базі
Київського політехнічного інституту
імені Ігоря Сікорського Отож вітайте
будь ласка Сергій шукає в мкп
інформаційні та комунікаційні технології
національне технічний університет
України Київський політехнічний інститут
імені Ігоря Сікорського будь ласка вам
слово
шановні пані і панове Добрий день всіх
Поздоровляю з тим що Україна підписала
угода про асоціацію і тримаємо кулаки за
те щоб наша Верховна Рада швидше її
ратифікувала
працюючи керівником відділу координації
міжнародної діяльності Київського
політехнічного інституту імені Ігоря
Сікорського будучи національним
кантокним пунктом в програмі горизонт
2020 я можу стверджувати що
європейські рамкові програми це
взагалі-то унікальне явище які не мають
аналогів ні за своїми
масштабом фінансування ні за охватом
тематики ні за рівнем міжнародної
співпраці тому для українських науковців
які будуть брати участь в програмі
горизонт Європа це не тільки можливість
знайти фінансові ресурси для того щоб
профінансувати свої наукові іноваційні
розробки це можливість отримати нові
знання отримати новий досвід отримати
нових друзів і партнерів і безумовно
продемонструвати свої
якщо ми подивимось на
структуру програми горизонт Європа то я
би її порівняв з птахом який має два
крила це Передова наука і інноваційна
Європа але крім того Він має дуже
потужний міцний тулуб Так це силова
конструкція на якій все кріпиться і ось
саме ця цей тулуб - це другий напрям
який називається глобальні виклики та
європейська індустріальна конкурентна
здатність
головною метою програми цього другого
напряму це
досягнення цілей Європейського Союзу
політики Європейського Союзу і
реалізація цілей сталого розвитку
проголошених організацій Об'єднаних
Націй
Ця програма цей ключовий напрям
планується профінансувати на рівні
55,5 млрд євро що складає 56%
загальної програми горизонт Європа крім
того Ця програма Вона поділяється на
кластери вона буде підтримувати
діяльність об'єднаного дослідницького
центру і в цій частині будуть
реалізовані нові фінансові інструмент
місії
крім того ще раз Хочу сказати про те що
для Європейського Союзу характерна
підтримка високого рівня міжнародної
співпраці і кожний з цих проектів він
передбачає створення консорціуму
якнайменше з трьох
юридичних організацій з трьох різних
країн Європейського Союзу або
асоційованих країн
якщо подивитись на структуру цієї
скажемо напряму да то вона
багатоступенева вся структура вона
поділяється на тематичні напрями це їх
називають кластерами так кожний кластер
в свою чергу поділяється ще на окремі
напрями так а в рамках уже цих напрямах
формуються пакети конкурсів і кожний ну
які складаються з окремих конкурсів
щодо
щодо 6 кластерів так цієї другого
ключового напряму то це здоров'я це
культура креативне інклюзивне
суспільство це безпека суспільства це
цифровізація промисловість і космос
клімат енергетика і транспорт
харчування білий економіка природні
ресурси сільське господарство і оточуючи
середовище
якщо що стосується першого класу то
здоров'я так сказать На для це кластер
із бюджетом
8,25
млрд євро Так І він передбачає
першу чергу спрямований на підтримку на
покращення і захист здоров'я і
благополуччя людей різного віку цим
конкурсом передбачена підтримка ну
скажемо є шість от цільових груп
які
охоплюють різні аспекти цього напряму
так
Зокрема я хочу сказати що Ну наприклад
Тут є багато
підрозділів На жаль ця презентація трохи
мене збиває так тому
Давайте таким чином що
зокрема от можна навести приклад
проєкти які характерні для саме цього
напряму кластеру і якраз демонструють
миттєву реакцію Європейського Союзу на
ці виклики які з'являються ну зокрема
конкурс який буде оголошений в січні
наступного року і був буде присвячений
готовності до боротьби з пандеміями
другий кластер він присвячений культурі
креативності та
інклюзивному суспільству з бюджетом 2,28
млрд євро так і він буде розділений на
три напрями перший напрям він
спрямований на підтримку європейської
демократії і права людини другий напрям
він буде підтримувати збереження
збереження
культурних цінностей європейських так і
третя напрям він буде спрямований на
дослідження з
соціальні і економічний трансформації
суспільства
прикладом такого конкурсу буде
конкурс наприклад який також буде
оголошений в січні наступного року це
захист європейських мов які перебувають
під загрозою зникнення
ось один з таких прикладів такого
конкурсу
третій клас - це цивільна безпека та
суспільство з бюджетом 1,6 млрд євро і
цей кластер має
дати відповідь на певну реакцію на ці
виклики безпеки які весь час виникають
тобто цей борьба з тероризмом і боротьба
з кібербезпекою Ну за кібербезпеку
прикладам такої такого
конкурсу може бути конкурс який буде
оголошений в червні наступного року так
і так сказати матику ефективна боротьба
з корупцією
четвертий клас це кластер який
називається цифрові технології
промисловість та космос з бюджетом 5,35
млрд євро цей
кластер він покликаний дати відповідь на
такі потреби Європейського Союзу як мати
конкурентна здатність надійні технології
так для розвитку промисловості Ну і
якраз в цьому напрямі ви бачите що якраз
сконцентровані всі ключові цифри
технології це і цифрові і розвиток
промисловості і космос
прикладом конкурсу який вже буде
оголошений в цьому місяці Так це
конкурс який направлений на міжнародну
співпрацю в галузі напівпровідників
тобто ось одна із ключових галузей яка
потребує розвитку і Європейський союз
дуже уважно До цього ставиться
п'ятий клас - це клімат енергетика та
транспорт
основною ідеєю цього кластера це якраз
боротьба за проти змін клімату Так це
значить покращення
управління
навколишнім середовищем Якщо так можна
це зробити і безумовно Це так сказати
трансформація в галузі енергетики в
галузі транспорту для того щоб вони були
екологічно чисті і безпечні ну приклад
дам конкурсу за п'ятим кластером може
бути конкурс який вже оголошена в жовтні
цього року і натілене на рішення для
накопичення теплової енергії ну Зверніть
увагу що це innovation Action тобто воно
вже припускає що треба мати певні
технології для того щоб брати участь в
такому конкурсі
шостий кластер з бюджетом 8,95 млрд так
він присвячений харчуванню біоекономіки
природним ресурсом в сільському
господарству та довкіллю
безумовно ці питання вони надзвичайно
хвилюють не тільки європейські Союз Ну і
всю світову спільноту зокрема і Україну
тому
розумне управління
природними ресурсами це одна з головних
цілей цього класу і прикладом
такого конкурсу за цим кластером може
бути конкурс який буде оголошена в
лютому наступного року і за тематикою
екологія інфекційних захворювань у
тварин
крім
кластерів так цей ключовий напрям він
так сказать Ну планує підтримку
діяльності спільного дослідницького
центру так в рамках спільного
цього центру
науковці які там працюють мають
продукувати нові знання розробляти нові
інноваційні інструменти виявляти
актуальні проблеми для Європейського
Союзу поширювати науково-технічні знання
навички сприяти досягненню
цілий горизонт Європи і проведення
досліджень в межах програми євроатом
в програмі горизонт Європи з'явився
новий інструмент Так це фінансовий
інструмент Це
дослідницькі інноваційній місії
який охоплює такий міжгалузеві тематику
зокрема
передбачається що 5 буде таких тематик
це адаптація до кліматичних змін включно
соціального трансформаціями боротьба з
раком здоров’я грунтів та харчування
кліматична нейтральні та розумні міста
здоров'я океани моря та внутрішні води
що треба сказати що в червні в вересні
цього року вже пройшли конкурси з
підготовчої фази для за напрямом місії
Ну будемо очікувати нових конкурсів бо
це інструмент Наскільки я розумію тільки
розробляється але сьогодні в нас буде
спеціальна якраз доповідь саме по місіям
тому ми задоволенням спробуємо
розібратися А як вони мають працювати Ну
і на
наприкінці свого виступу Я хотів би
сказати що на мій погляд безумовно дуже
важливо поширення інформації про
програму і особливо важливо це робити
для молодих вчених і
аспірантів тому як представник заходу
вищої освіти
Ми будемо монсувати це в своєму
університеті треба безумовно для тієї
групи аспірантів проводити спеціальні
навчальні курси під умовною назвою
горизонтознавство чому Бо аспіранти
мають розуміти
от власні дослідження чи співпадають їх
рівень з тими й дослідженнями які є
актуальними зараз в світі от саме така
постановка вона дозволить їм більш
критично підходити до своїх робіт ми не
все дякую за увагу Дякуємо дуже
Дякуємо Сергій шукає інформаційні та
комунікаційні технології
національно-технічний університет
України Київський політехнічний інститут
імені Ігоря Сікорського Ну що ж бачимо
те що і справді перед нами постає дуже
багато проблем дуже багато викликів які
необхідно вирішувати за допомогою нових
методів та підходів у тому числі і з
використанням інноваційних методів
фреймбурків та врізноманітних
інструментів саме про інновації та
інструменти підтримки інноваційних
проектів і не тільки ми будемо говорити
з нашим наступним спікером Отож про це
розкаже Пан Іван Кульчицький директор
агенції європейських інновацій Отож будь
ласка вітаємо
Дякую за можливість висловитися хочу
сказати що Україна має вже більше 20
років досвіду участі європейських
програмах починаючи ще з п'ятої ранку і
програми ми як організації маємо досить
шостий рапою програми в проектах але що
важливо який етап важливий зараз як на
мене цей важливий етапом є те що вже з
кінця горизонт 22 Це особливо активному
ідеалузі які зараз відбувається при
асоціації до горизонту в Європі ця
участь зранкових програмах починає мати
значний вплив на українську національну
інноваційну політику І власне Коли я
буду розказувати про таку структуру як
європейська інноваційна рада то вона має
її модель діяльності
взаємодія науки інновацій це хороша
модель для України і я сподіваюся що
наступному раунді де у нас буде дискусія
то я трошки підкину дров до цієї
дискусії оскільки один з елементів де
треба брати наприклад це власне
відповідальність європейської
інноваційної ради чому вона взагалі
появилася в горизонт 2020 в усьому рамку
в програмі її не було Тому що ще на
кінці сьомої рамкою програми європейські
Союз задумався слухайте Та не скільки
фінансуємо наукові дослідження такі
хороші результати А вони не йдуть в
економіку вони не йдуть для суспільства
вони не йдуть для людей і коли Ми
розказуємо про рамкові програми ми
завжди питаємо науковців Чому ви робите
дослідження для публікації для
дисертації для кар'єри Але якщо ми
хочемо мати публічні гроші чи державні
чи бюджетні чи державну підтримку чи
підтримку громадян Ми повинні показати
як ці дослідження впливають на зміну
життя а це через нові інноваційні
політики і звичайно що європейські Союз
хотів також мати конкурентну позицію з
глобальному світі з США з кореєю з
Китаєм з іншими активними ключовими
світовими структурами
І зараз якщо ми бачимо бюджет
третього вступає інноваційної Європи
досить велика більше 13 млрд євро з них
на європейську інноваційну Раду припадає
більше 10 мільярдів євро і більше 3 млрд
попадає цей бюджет європейського
інституту інновації технологій і півмілі
об майже півмільйона попадає на І
припадає на європейську на формування
інноваційної екосистеми на взаємозв'язки
між різними акторами взагалі хто
цікавився європейським інститутом і
новацій та технологій то його Цікава
історія створення був конкурс
претендувало два європейські міста
розклад і Будапешт це зараз є в
вперше цей інститут але він має багато
офісів різних країнах і коли ми дивимося
основна функція інноваційної Європи то
це з одної сторони Да треба підтримувати
стартапи нові рішення але воно має іти
через взаємодію з національними
соціальними політиками то був перший
челендж буде для України а як наша
національна інноваційна політика
відповідає європейській поліції другий
момент Як же це реалізується добре мати
хороші цілі А яким чином це реалізувати
відповідно європейські інноваційна рада
вона самого початку була націлена на
підтримку малого середнього бізнесу і ми
пам'ятаємо великий успіхи
семіструментів у нас 16 проектів
горизонт 2020 зайшли по лініями
інструменту фаза один фаза два і це
підтримка
спрощена бюрократія там була мала 10
сторінок заявки і інші форми для того
щоби молись середній бізнесмен зменшити
бар'єр входження і знайти ці інновації
які міняють ринки так звані правління
інновації коли ми говоримо про
європейські інститут інновацій та
технології - це поєднання різних акторів
поєднання освіти на навчання інших речей
десь певній мірі цим займаються
ряд провідних технологій технічних
університетів таких як Київський
Політехнічний Львівська політехніка
Сумський університет Харківський та інші
університети які є в Україні інноваційна
екосистема будування На жаль в Україні
дехто інноваційно екосистему плутає з
екологією і над недостатньо уваги
приділяється якщо ми говоримо про сам
механізм фінансування європейської
інноваційної ради то тут треба звернути
увагу на суттєву зміну в горизонт Європи
коли вони подивилися Окей ми шукаємо
стартапи на базі чого вони будуються
тому вирішили звернути увагу на весь
ланцюжок інноваційний від ідеї до ринку
появилися такі механізм портфендер де
взагалі можна претендувати на
фінансування
індивідуально або невеликому консортіумі
починаючи просто з ідею єсть транзистом
нова модель і тут є взаємодія з
європейською дослідницькою радою тому що
на transition на продов на просування
Так звана інноваційна яма яка є в
Україні коли в нас після досліджень
немає механізмів підтримки для того щоб
була комерціалізація то тут можуть
подавати Як ви результати попередніх
проектів горизонті Європа а також
проекти які виконувалися європейською
дослідницькою радою і коли ми дискутуємо
національним фондом дослідження за
національної академією коли науковості
кажуть Ми зробили дослідження а дальше
так Хтось думає як з цим робити то тут є
механізм як з цим робити тобто є певний
результат є аналіз якщо ви бачите що ці
результати можуть бути застосовані на
ринку то ви можете отримати певне
фінансування щоб довести уже від науково
обґрунтованого результату від якогось
експерименту до прототипу до того що вже
можна показати бізнес у ближче і її
закселератор це дуже близьке до
колишнього семиструменту де вже можна
отримати фінансування для виводу нових
речей на ринок є конкурс який були вже
закриті тут я специфіка приємно з
спіллером 20 стопом другим де є програма
на два роки 21-22 рік європейська
інноваційна рада стартувала першою
програма дій була прийнята в березні від
21-го року але вона була прийнята на
один рік і було рядку ко- конкурсів де
тематика була певній міри визначена там
медичні пристрої по енергетиці по цифри
але також були відкриті теми де можна
було подавати любу тему основне що вона
була інноваційна і була така яка може
охопити певну нову нішу на ринку зараз
обговорюється питання що буде
22-му році Поки що немає офіційно
опублікованої програми але тут дискусії
певні драсти вже появляються але підхід
який був 21-му році обіцяється що він
буде збережений 22-м Тобто будуть
тематики які відкриті і також будуть
тематики які вже більш-менш визначені
певній сфері це не дуже детальні
тематики але певні сфери і очікується що
перший конкурс це будуть спить в березні
22-го року тому зараз для нас для
України задача - це ну провести певний
аналіз того що подавалися 21-му році які
фірми що можна робити Які результати І
тут має бути виведений корисний і
активний діалог в середні країни причому
не тільки на рівні Міністерства освіти
науки Андрій і інші Міністерство питання
як би дуже цікавий механізм подачі заяви
з певній мірі він відрізняється від того
як подають заявки на інші конкурси коли
готуються заявка партнерстві е-е
подається заявка тоді вона оцінюється
оцінки і так дальше тут для того щоб
бізнес не витрачав даремно час ви можете
подати з короткої простої ідеї пару
слайдів піч відео записали так званий
піч і вас оцінюють еволютори а дальше ви
вже коли ви прийшли певний початковий
відбір коли кажуть Ой щось цікаве ідея
не зовсім стара ви готуєте повну заявку
і є цілий певний етап і подачі цієї
заявки збільшили кількість оцінок
евуляторів для того щоб була більша
Об'єктивна оцінка що є дуже нам не
цікавим взаємодія елементом я так звана
платформа штучного інтелекту яка в
діалозі з вами допомагає будувати цю
заявку це значно спрощує роботу бізнесу
скільки є певний виклик для бізнесу ми
маємо братику співпраці з бізнесом Вони
зайняті поточної діяльності вони нам
мають часу на підготовку заявки Вони
дуже часто кажуть хай нам Хтось напише
заявку ми скажімо її подамо але тут
якраз єврокомісія вимагає щоби
бізнес який подає заявку сам міг про неї
розказати Таким чином має бути
відповідна команда і має бути
відповідний рівень бізнесу коли ми
дивимся на карту хто може бути приємно
що ми тут бачимо Україну Да ми її бачимо
акціону країну Але вже ці слова про
асоційований статус України уже
відображається в карті штучного
інтелекту цієї платформи як ми бачимо
Крим там Так Він в складі України Так що
тут все окей є платформа спільноти де ви
можете зареєструватися і отримати масу
бізнес-сервісів це тоже виклик для
України порівняти які тут надаються
сервіси для бізнесу які в нас є сервісу
в нас є офіс застосування експорту в нас
є дія бізнес має багато речей які є
певному наближені ми не скажемо
релевантні але дуже подібні Я думаю що
ці налогодження комунікації між такими
структурами Могло б бути цікаво тому
Запрошуємо звернути увагу на цю
ком'юніті платформу треба розуміти
базові підходи
ви можете подати заявку будь-коли але в
певний період часу я так званий
відсікання коли йде оцінки є багато
підтримки сервісу це є мова штучного
інтелекту якість оцінки другий раз ви не
можете це змінили що колись горизонті 22
Це можна було подати коли-небудь зараз
можна подати ще раз Якщо оцінка пройшла
певне рівень прозорість набагато більш
детальніше фідбек Тобто ви отримуєте
підтримку не просто коротенько не
зрозуміло що це була певна проблема
горизонт 2020 зараз ви ось оці детальне
пояснення еволюцію від оцінки цілого
екстракт буде видаватися по-іншому тобто
для тих дійсно
хороших заявок інноваційна екосистема
Значить тут є важливо будувати як є і
вже запустили європейський інноваційні
форум нам треба побудувати в Україні
такий інноваційний форум який би
висновки якого якийсь пропозиції могли
подаватися на європейській формі це така
постійна площадка співпраці нам треба
думати як розбудовувати таку екосистему
з себе Є певні підходи де треба
комунікувати розвивати підтримувати
бізнес є уже перший конкурс якщо ми
подивимося Я ще одну хвилину буквально є
перший конкурс де уже говориться про те
що треба підтримати підприємництво
підтримати інвестиції під певні сектори
ті ж самі соціальні інновації інших ці
конкурси вони не є дослідницькі проекти
Та так звані дії підтримки і вакцинації
але важливо що тут багато аналітики
багато корисних матеріалів буде для того
щоб ми в себе могли діяти європейські
інститут і на вас і технології багато
спільнот є нові конкурс на креативні
індустріальну
ряд активності від стратегії навчання
стартапів ми маємо приклад на даному
Львівській політехніки приходив захист
за підтримки яєць Фуд і я вже приклад
співпраці знає що буде спеціальний
захист з цим інститутом в січні мон
планує з представниками Європейської
комісії ми надіємося що в нас буде
представництво цього інституту оскільки
це інститут Він має зв'язки з різними
системами тобто з різними діями і Марією
бо тут є можливість мобільності навчання
з іншими проектами для того щоби все це
з інтегрувати разом і помогти провести
на ринок він так само працює на
інноваційному регіональному рівні І ми
знаємо що Україна має стратегію 17
спеціалізації є Хабі інноваційні значить
треба будувати
зв'язки і спільнотами європейським тут
інновацій і технології є корисні лінки І
ми готові дальше продовжувати в нас є
мережа розсилки в нас є приклади кращих
проектів які ми поширюємо і ми
сподіваємося що українці будуть успішні
у цій сфері інновації в цьому конкурсі а
також співпраця з європейською
інноваційною радою стоятиме суттєвому
прогресу інноваційній політиці України
Дякую за увагу
що ж Дякуємо і вам
Дякуємо Іванку
інформаційні та комунікаційні технології
директор громадської організації агенція
європейських інновацій як ми дуже за
виступ за поради і рухаємось далі Отож
Як ви мабуть вже помітили наша сина
трошечки трансформувалась А це означає
те що прийшов час для панельної дискусії
дискусії між представниками органів
влади та науковою спільнотою Отож і з
радістю передаю слово генеральному
директору директорати науки та інновації
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Григорію мазалевичу і нашим шановним
учасником панельної дискусії Отож
успішний панельною дискусії і вам слово
ваші Оплески будь ласка
тож колеги
хотів би вам представити наших учасників
панельної дискусії
перед цим сказати що я думаю ви добре
розумієте що успішна участь України в
програмі горизонт Європа це робота не
тільки Міністерства освіти і науки
України
і в перспективі це робота практично всіх
міністерств
тож з нами сьогодні
Ростислав та мінчук
генеральний директор директорату
координації міжнародної технічної
допомоги Кабінету Міністрів України
прошу вітати
з нами сьогодні Максим шкільов
керівник Департаменту координації
проектів цифрової трансформації
Міністерство цифрової трансформації
до нас повинна приєднатись Руслана
коренчук заступник начальника управління
начальник відділу розвитку цифрових
навичок управління розвитку цифрових
навичок та цифровізації освіти також
Міністерства цифрової трансформації із
нами зараз в онлайні Олексій колижук
голова наукового комітету Національної
Ради України з питань розвитку науки і
технології він також долучиться до
Олексій вітаю
які питання Я хотів би задати нашим
гостям ну по-перше на вашу думку які
кроки необхідно було б здійснити для
підтримки реалізації програм горизонт
Європа та евратом на державному рівні
які на вашу думку існують підходи та
методологія розробки та реалізації
проектів цифрової трансформації
створення сприятного поля державної
підтримки наукових науково-технічних та
інноваційних проектів та їх підготовки
до участі у міжнародних проектів на вашу
думку Чи це є міфом Чи це є реальністю
процес спробуємо поговорити
на початку хотів би дати слово пану
ростиславу перед цим
хочу сказати що він наш добрий друг і
вже мабуть декілька років ми плідно
співпрацюємо
в різному Полі і
пан Ростислав нам на всіх етапах
допомагав з
процесом підготовки угоди
тому пане ростиславу ваші думки
Дякую велике радий бути тут сьогодні
радий бачити колег і в залі і в онлайні
тільки Не закривайте ці питання щоб
можна було не відходити далеко
думкою від змісту які ви хотіли
обговорити ну для мене горизонт це
завжди був
окремий світ не тільки просто горизонт
окремий світ великий з великою кількістю
можливостей і
я завжди був таким якби дуже оптимістом
з приводу того що треба ставити планку
високо і в цьому світі в нас є багато
можливостей
наш директорат займається
супроводом я так можу сказати І скажемо
підтримкою
більшої участі України у різних
програмах Європейського союзу в тому
числі
оскільки ну тобто Україна бере участь в
програмі вона платить членські внесок
але потім отримує кошти з програми і ці
кошти які отримує Україна проект
програми вони вже є міжнародною
технічною допомогою реєструється в нас
Таким чином ті хто виграють проекти ті
хто їх реалізовують Вони мають
можливість
вони на них не накладають там
оподаткування і по суті Вони знаходяться
в такі от в системі реєстрації всіх
проектів де ми можемо розуміти що
відбувається як ці речі синхронізуються
і для нас Важливо щоб ці проекти були в
полі зору для того оскільки є інші
підрозділи які займаються моніторингом
політики плануванням плану дій уряду
реалізації його і щоб ми розуміли що є
питання планування є питання там
наповнення різними компонентами цих
планів для того щоб можна було власне
синхронізувати ці речі але я вже далеко
за глибоко зайшов я все-таки вернуся
кроків які необхідно здійснити для
підтримки реалізації програм горизонт
Європа на державному рівні
для мене я спробую відповісти на цих
двох ключових питань для мене є важлива
сильна спроможність і я розумію Я дуже
радий бачити всі національні контактні
пункти І от гарна інфографіку ви недавно
виступ випустили в соціальних медіа з
приводу кількості з приводу там переліку
цих університетів які беруть участь і я
дуже так тепла відношуся до того що ці
університети є що є спроможні є сильні
Хто хоче Хто розуміє наскільки це
важливо і тому для мене
по суті ми аналізували яким чином
забезпечити кращу участь тому що одним з
показників для нас це є більша участь
заявників наступним індикатором для ну
для нас там для мене особисто є
є уже більші контакти наших заявників з
потенційними заявниками учасниками
Європейському Союзі
а третій індикатор в принципі це є вже
збільшення кількості виграних проектів
так Ну і звичайно четвертий індикатор
для мене це як то кажуть
нескладно було написати складно потім
реалізовувати та і кожен стикається на
якомусь рівні з тим що що ж робити тут
коли ти не виграв проект ти ще
переживаєш як його виграти коли ти
виграв проект Ти розумієш що тільки тут
все починається
Ну тому тобто для нас завжди було
важливе питання на першому етапі як
забезпечити так щоб кількість сильних
спроможних учасників
збільшувалась Тобто ми розуміємо що ми
тут стикаємося з тим яким чином
сформувати Так ці рамки сформувати Ці
правила щоби допомогти
народжуватись цим новим ініціативам
новим середовищем бажаючим університетом
чи науковцям чи середовищем науковців
брати участь в програмі
І власне тут ну і раніше ще піднімали
питання важливості і самого менеджменту
і можливості оцих коридорів і вікон для
для тих хто готовий і хто бажає брати
участь у цих процесах
оскільки ну Той досвід з яким ми
стикаємося ми ми так координуємо ще ряд
інших програм транскордонних не горизонт
але ми розуміємо наскільки важливо
підтримати ті ініціативи які є в
університетах і тут питання скажем не
стільки державної політики скільки
питання
Скільки питання вірив ці речі скільки
питання того чи люди які знаходяться на
тих чи інших посадах або там роблять тут
чи іншу функцію вони вірять свої сили і
готові підтримувати там нові
нестандартні ініціативи
допомагаючи тим власне оцим от зернам
які хочуть розвиватися Ну тому що часто
буває що ну не хочуть розвиватися ми
живемо як живемо добрий як є
університеті в нас багато науковці в нас
багато Десь чули про якісь проекти Ну
гаразд є але може вони не для нас Та ну
тобто для нас важливо для нас Важливо
щоб аналізувати оці от вузькі місця чим
ми чим можна на державному рівні
допомогти
розширювати оці от вузькі місця
збільшуючи можливо кількість
потенційних оцих середовищ які готові
включатися
змагатися подавати все брати участь в
проектах
це по це по Першому індикатору по
другому індикатора ми розуміємо що я
надзвичайно важливо забезпечувати оцю от
синергію між українськими учасниками і
учасниками з інших країн і ми в своїй
роботі Спілкуючись з різними країнами
Європейському Союзі ми завжди піднімаємо
Питання в тому що
що важливістю для нас є не сприймати нас
як третю країну що часто фігурує в
текстах директора в текстах директив там
чи регуляції ну юридично ми розуміємо що
там члени ЄС а там інших Хто не члени
єсть вони треті країни але тут важливо
розуміти що
для нас важливо розбудовувати співпрацю
з різними країнами на рівні показувати
нашу спроможність в різних галузях Чи це
бізнес Чи це міста чи це молодь Чи це
науковці
Чи це там державні службовці так і тому
це другий компонент для нас важливий щоб
підтверджувати цю можливість
і підтримувати
налагодження цих контактів те що ми
стикаємося ми бачимо що в Європейському
Союзі вже є випрацьовані моделі
університети знають один одного вони
знають один одного вже роками Та вони
знають хто чим займається Ага там
сільським господарством займається цей
університет Швеції там космічне питання
ми займається той університет Швейцарії
Ну так і так дальше по темах по темах і
в них працюють оці от нетворкінги Для
нас це є виклик тому що нам потрібно
включатися в ці нетворкінги тому що ми
раніше там не були і
ну і і для них теж є важливо зрозуміти
що це що українські представники вони є
сильні вони спроможні вони можуть писати
якісні заявки можуть реалізовувати
якісні проекти і в першу чергу в них є
потенціал до цих інноваційних наукових
рішень
це я вже думаю що потрібно завершувати
так тому для нас ще третій компонент
який я хотів озвучити для нас важливо
підтримувати оцю синергію між між
різними темами щоб науковці щоб оця оцей
світ горизонту світ програми він не
знаходився в закритій
[музика]
в закритому шарі так щоб
ми забезпечували цього горизонтальну
комунікацію між різними міністерствами
між різними учасниками оскільки є оцей
принцип який я зараз вже закінчу є ще
кілька компонентів важливих це ланцюги
доданої вартості і це комунікація для
того щоб ми не видумували велосипед а
підсилювали один одного тобто формування
горизонтальних різних ланцюжків в тій
галузі в якій ви працюєте тобто умовно
якщо ми говоримо про те що є якісь
проекти які займаються дослідженнями в
хімії для в якійсь галузі нам Важливо
щоб ті хто Працюють як бізнес в цій
галузі Вони знали про цих науковців
використовували їхню там результат або
по крайній мірі спілкувалися і чули один
одного щоб ці світи не були відірвані
чим швидше ми зможемо вибудувати оці
ланцюги між різними міністерствами між
різними стихолдерами тим більше буде
додана вартість і тим більше буде ефект
власне Ну і ми тоді реалізуємо
ті завдання які ставили перед собою
підписуючи угоду про участь в горизонті
Європа Дякую тож Дякую Ростиславе
далі пропоную перейти мабуть мабуть до
найбільш
інноваційної сфери в останні мабуть
десятки років вже до сфери
діджиталізації
пані Руслана за наявною інформацією ви
спеціалізуєтесь на проектах пов'язаних з
діджиталізацією в сфері освіти щоб не
хотіли
додати про можливості які відкриває
горизонт і можливо декілька слів про
свої проекти Ну давайте почнемо з наших
проектів які є в першу чергу хочу
запросити всіх присутніх
переглянути портал дія цифрова освіта
той проект яким я займаюся
на що він спрямований Як ви знаєте
амінцефара є має чотири стратегічні цілі
одна з них це якраз навчити 6 мільйонів
українців за три роки цифрові грамодості
чому це важливо тому що власне Ми не
можемо навчити ефективно користуватися
інструментами поки ми не навчилися поки
ми не набули оцей от юзер Experience по
користуванню тими чи іншими процедурами
тими чи іншими програмами І вміннями
власне Через це всі ті програми і
проекти які ми робимо в мінсофрі для
цифрової трансформації в плані освіти
вони спрямовані на легку швидку і дійсно
ефективне навчання А тим чи іншим
навичкам Ми зрозуміли що в 2019 році
коли це все запускало що людям дуже
легко знаєте от є таке слово заходить
навчання за допомогою серіалів тому що
ніхто не любить насправді навчатися Ну
типу будемо чесні і відверті тому що все
ще складно сприймається складно воно
вимагає зусиль ми спробували відійти від
цих зусиль і запустити такий собі проект
в якому є можливість власне за короткий
період там буквально за 5-7 хвилин за
одну серію зрозуміти якусь якийсь із
пунктиків якусь галочку поставити по
тому чи іншому навику як зробити
цифровий підпис як загенувати сертифікат
як в принципі навчитися сплачувати
комуналку онлайн і так далі таких нас
небагато але це формат освітнього
серіалу Коли є залучення експерта які
дійсно в темі проекту який абсолютно
орієнтується по тому яким чином
організувати той чи інший процес в
цифровому світі і є
назвемо так зірка
кіно музики не важливо і яка своєю
енергетикою
вміє запалити людей і вміє пройти цей
самий шлях навчання разом з користувачем
відповідно таких освітніх серіалів У нас
уже понад 70 на освітній платформі А
плюс до того Зараз ми зробили оновлення
Іра дизайн в якому з'явилися уже і
текстовий формат тобто з'явилася гайди
яким чином там обробити в фотошопі свою
фотку Ну будь-що і закінчуючи також
подкастами де в форматі знову ж таки там
поїздки в транспорті ви можете слухати
прослуховувати ту чи іншу корисну
інформацію відповідно запрошую на цю на
цю платформу діє цифрова освіта плюс
шматком проекту дієсферної освіти є і
вашоу Всеукраїнська школа онлайн це
можливості навчання власне і підтримки
для вчителів та школярів в часи
особливої пандемії тому
запрошую долучитися до цих проектів плюс
є велика можливість в офлайн частині це
є мережа із Понад 6000 хабібів де
будь-яка людина в якої немає особистого
гаджета ми розуміємо що цей цифровий
розрив у нас ще й досі є може прийти і
відповідно отримати цей Перший досвід
дотику до будь-якого або гаджета або
того як там чи іншим гаджетом
користуватися відповідно
якраз в цих напрямках і Запрошуємо до
співпраці Чому Тому що тем як ви
розумієте ще дуже багато які треба
покрити І власне донести до користувачів
з приводу перших результатів от ми
говоримо що нам потрібно 6 млн українців
вночі тому і звичайно орієнтуємось і на
більшу кількість
перші У нас уже є Понад мільйон
реєстрацій Надії цифрова освіта і повна
250 тисяч на всеукраїнській школі онлайн
тобто
з хорошою Чим ще можна похвалитися що
дійсно
ні курси Ані жоден інший жодна інша
міжнародна чи української
онлайн-платформа не може похвалитися
результатами там в понад 70% проходження
курсів від А до Я тобто
70% почали навчатися і закінчили його
тому
долучайтеся і власне ці можливості по
розвитку і включення в даний проект
величезні починаючи від офлайн хабіб
мережею яких можна збільшувати і
поширювати ну просто максимально
дотягуючись до кожного міста села
населеного пункту і закінчуючи тим що ще
дуже багато тем залишається не закритих
а теми ми формулюємо в напрямку 30
цифрових компетентностей з ними теж
можна ознайомитися з нашими
дослідженнями на сайті тому Welcome до
нас дякую
прошу привітати
пане Максиме щоб ви хотіли додати зі
свого боку Я коли аналізував цю програму
Я зрозумів яким чином ми можемо бути
дотичними один до одного Я маю на увазі
мін цифру та інші міністерства та
людей які будуть подаватися на програми
є цілі які вже одна з яких була озвучена
а я інша ціль - це 100% послуг онлайн
яким чином це
робиться є
ціла система
cdtio це люди заступники міністрів з
цифрової трансформації заступники голів
совів з цифрової трансформації є цифрові
команди
оце тільки частина цих людей
які центрально органи виконавчої влади є
ще CDTI на рівні областей та міст і є
цифрові проекти щоб ви розуміли що це
таке це дві частини тобто надати
можливість людям отримати якусь державну
послугу а інша частина - це інформація
яка міститься в реєстрах та
інформаційних системах
і більшість цих систем немає тобто
більшість інформації знаходяться в
паперовому або Екселі І що робиться є
технологія за якою робляться всі проекти
цифрової трансформації в державі це 4
кроки які є на екрані це ініціація це
проектування реалізація та втілення і на
перших двох кроках в нас є запит до вас
тобто наразі є більш ніж 300 проектів
цифрової трансформації в всіх
міністерствах тацовах
і ці проекти потребують в більшості
розробки тобто аналізу
пошуку аналогічних працюючих рішень в
Європі в інших країнах і розробка
технічних завдань для цих проектів і це
може бути спільними проектами в рамках
горизонт і інших міністерств Я не кажу
про мінсору бо ці проекти це проекти во
всіх міністерствах тацовах це
загалом це
75 державних органів від міністерств до
совів до комісії і таке інше є люди яких
я показував це
заступники
голів або
заступників міністрів які
будуть отримувати і надавати підтримку в
ваших проектах Ми запрошуємо до праці
дякую
Я хотів би додати що в рамках програми
горизонт Європа вже створений
спеціальний інструмент для співпраці
міністерств країн європейського
дослідницького простору між собою якраз
подібного роду умовно кажучи ТЗ Вони
стають актуальними і вони є актуальними
одночасно і для України і для умовної
там Польщі Словаччині або навіть
Німеччини тому
я думаю що тут є точно перспективи для
співпраці як центральних органів
виконавчої влади так і вчених які б
могли такі розробки пропонувати далі я
хотів би запросити до слова пане Олексія
калажука пане Олексію
ви з нами
у питання до дискусії ви чули Я думаю що
вам ви могли прочитати окрему лекцію на
тему горизонту Європи але давайте десь
до семи хвилин я не великий спеціаліст
по горизонту Європа але ну зараз я
скоріше буду говорити як
з позиції науковця що могла б в чому
могла б виражатися державна підтримка
яка стосується і значить програм
міжнародних всіх і зокрема і горизонт
Європа Значить ми тут Я б розділив на
три таких значить фальти
одна це по лінії збільшувати так би
мовити залученість наших науковців до
європейських взагалі справ
Ну справа в тому що ну це Відомо що в
принципі подача міжнародних заявок є
певний такий бар'єр для науковців і ну
легше знаєте залишатися в звичній
системі координат в зоні комфорту тобто
подавати якісь заявки на національному
рівні ніж виходити якось на такий
міжнародний і часто це причина цього є і
низька залученість низька інтегрованість
міжнародної і так далі тобто Люди
більш-менш там випадково можуть
знаходити якихось партнерів значить ну
відповідно у нас беруть участь в
основному ті у кого вже Є напрацьоване
відповідне міжнародне співробітництво
тобто що по цій лінії зробити Ну хоча б
саме перше це збільшувати рівень
мобільності наукових
науково-педагогічних працівників бо якщо
студентів ми зараз більш-менш успішно
так би мовити випихуємо по лінії
еразмуса по мобільності то з науковцями
і
професорою це досить складно особливо
складно коли йдеться про більш довгий
терміни цієї мобільності а саме такі ну
там річні речі такого порядку вони
приводять до утворення тих контактів які
потім виростають в спільні проекти
ну це звичайно по цій же лінії Я б
сказав що це заходи підтримки Які
забезпечували взагалі участь
повноцінно представників України
відповідних там європейських структурах
в тих комітетах з Європейського
дослідницького простору це давня
проблема що Україна повноцінна там не
працює і відповідно це зменшує наші
можливості і по впливу і по загальній
інформованості так би мовити і по
відповідно в часній передачі тої
інформації тих трендів які там виникають
до наших досіжемейкерів і до наших
науковців
це могла би бути і
така інформаційно тренінгова підтримка Я
розумію що є система національних
контактний
але я зараз говорю про трошки інше це не
тільки там скажімо допомога в пошуку
партнера чи консультація по якихось
таких значить загальних питань я говорю
зараз про те що у нас є вже певна
кількість людей які мають особистий
досвід написання заявок успішних так
успішного керування проектами і так далі
І якщо би організувати такий значить
передачу досвіду тобто дуже просто
Наприклад людині яка або подавала заявки
або експортувала заявки подивитися на
чужу і заявку і сказати Чого там не
вистачає я можу одразу подивитися на
вашу заявку на там Марію Кюрі і сказати
що вона прийде чи вона не прийде
і порадити що треба зробити для того щоб
і ось такий такий консультації могли би
бути Дуже корисними і значить знижувати
ось цей бар'єр складності який дійсно
існує
друга шпальта - це
менеджмент дивіться я знаю двох
не просто людей які вигравали заявки
горизонта що 2020 які були
координаторами з українського боку і от
обидва цих науковців Сказали мені ніколи
більше тобто не в сенсі ніколи більше не
буду подаватися на горизонт але не буду
подаватися як координатор бо отримавши
досвід адміністравання гранту коли ти
відповідаєш за весь консорціум Ну це
дійсно значить виходить такий невеличкий
кошмар і
несумісність якихось речей якихось вимог
які ставляться європейцями з нашим
бюджетним законодавством незважаючи
навіть на те що це спецфон там і так
далі вона приводить до купи проблем і
ось тут треба було подумати з боку
держави на організацію якихось окремих
форм для цього щоб це йшло щоб були
якісь грантові офіси які менеджери би ті
проекти на окремих якихось субрахунках
щоб до них не щоб там була більше
Свобода застосовувати зокрема наприклад
є якісь вимоги от як були вимога наразі
Коли остання 10% фінансування Ти
отримуєш тільки після успішного
завершення проекту і здачі всіх звітів
де взяти українському координатору це
10% фінансування значить повинен бути
відповідний механізм який це дозволить
інакше це умова яка потім виникає вона
виявляється Не ну непідйомною
це створення таких структур які скажімо
Можна було б працювати на іншому проекті
які зараз є korzofacellence Які спільно
з німецькою стороною будуть
організовуватися то на цьому пілотному
проекті Можна було б відпрацювати
практику створення подібних структур які
знімали би ось цей бар'єр складності
менеджменту і бар'єру того чи варто
взагалі зв'язуватися так би мовити з
такими складними в адміністрування
речами
Ну і третя шпальта - це взагалі
заохочення того що ми кажемо те що ми
називаємо інноваційними проектами да
Коли ми говоримо несуто там
фундаментальну науку А про щось ближче
до інновацій то Ну тут цілий Пласт
проблем які пов'язаний з тим що треба
чимось зацікавити і приватні структури
для того щоб вони захотіли мати справу
взагалі з державними щоб взагалі по
лінії державна приватного партнерства
тобто нас з цим навіть уже проблема поки
ті проекти дорестуть ще до горизонта Та
треба проблема з тим Щоб стимулювати це
навіть на цьому рівні щоб ці речі
взагалі утворювалися і з іншого боку
треба зацікавити державні структури ті ж
там університети чи наукові установи в
тому щоб вони були зацікавлені в
створенні таких
партнерство з бізнесом який потім
значить могли би виростати в щось і
значить претендувати уже на якісь
міжнародні гроші ну тут ясно що тут
великий Пласт не вирішених проблем
починаючи від податкового стимулювання
якщо йдеться про зацікавленість
приватних знову таки можна було би
переймати міжнародні практики про те що
хай-тех стартапи звільняються від
оподаткування на якийсь час про те щоб
ці речі з боку зацікавленості державних
структур якось входили в критерії
оцінювання і виливалися теж відповідно
далі в якийсь державний фінансування
такої активності взагалі да тобто щоб в
принципі тебе стимулювали за саму подачу
заявок чи за утворення таких речей в
Незалежності від того чи виграв де потім
грант горизонт чи ні це великий Пласт
проблем про який дійсно можна говорити
дуже довго напевно на цьому зупинюся
Дякую за увагу Дякую пане Олексію
[оплески]
Дякую нашим гостям
Ну що ж будемо дякувати і вам будь ласка
ваші Оплески дякуємо за цю справді
плідно дискусію Ми багато чого дізнались
багато чого почули і бачимо те що
спільно ми дійсно можемо напрацювати
дуже багато для того аби рухатись у
напрямку Європи досліджень інтеграції Ну
і власне для того аби спільно творити
інноваційне та наукове майбутнє України
Ще раз Дякуємо за цю панель і Дякуємо
нашим гостям плістам
Ну що ж колеги Запрошуємо усіх до
спільної світлини якщо можна просто
зараз Запрошуємо усіх піднятися з ваших
місць зробити спільно світлину прямо на
сцені нашого заходу Отож колеги перша
частинка на цьому добігає свого
завершення усіх Запрошуємо тут і зараз
долучитись до спільної світлини Попереду
у нас 30 хвилиночок кава при віку
Запрошуємо усіх посмакувати Друзі
долучайтесь долучайтесь будь ласка усіх
чекаємо на півобертом стаємо для того
аби Усі помістились на наше спільну
світлину
[музика]
Ну що Шановні колеги повертаємось
повертаємось до живого ефіру час нашої
перерви Вибіг нетворкін під час перерви
був плідним але ж повертаємось до нашої
пленарної роботи і саме тут на головній
сині нашої сьогоднішнього заходу буде
відбуватись найцікавіше Отож Дякуємо
усім то кожного хто разом із нами зараз
отут наші аудиторії нашого прекрасному
залі хто долучився до нас онлайн раді
бачити усіх так кожного ну і звісно
колеги сьогодні говоримо про перспективу
сьогодні говоримо про майбутнє сьогодні
говоримо про європейські горизонти ті
перспективи яка відкриває програма
попереду багато цікавого попереду багато
насиченого ну і справді наш сьогоднішній
спринт буде нон-стоу буде невпинним і
принесе дуже багато інсайтів спілкування
нетворкінгу для усіх також знав Отож
Шановні колеги Запрошуємо ще даємо
кілька секундочок для того аби усі наші
учасники такі долучилися приєдналися
якщо Ваші друзі колеги ще не тут не з
нами то У такому випадку мерщій
долучайтесь напишіть повідомте що ми уже
уживому ефірі і ми готові продовжувати
Ну А попереду інформації буде дуже
багато це є інформація від наших
європейських колег і виступи українських
представників бізнесу стартапів
інновації науки Отож тут і зараз
найкраще і будемо говорити про багато
над цікавих речей і Головне усе те про
що ми будемо говорити можна втілити
можна випробувати на собі і відчути
потужне можливості та неймовірно
перспектива Ну що Шановні колеги
продовжимо Отож я прошу усіх займати
місця швидше швидше швидше долучаємося і
зараз ми розпочинаємо наступний наш блок
який присвячений європейським та
національним інструментом підтримки
досліджень та інновацій до усіх спікерів
у мене прохання Оскільки ми в дуже
щільному спринті в дуже щільному
таймінгу то будь ласка Слідкуйте за
таймінгом ретельно його дотримитись для
того аби ми справді працювали по графіку
і аби наш захід дав максимум для усіх
також на з точки зору балансу усіх
виступів Ну що ж розпочинаємо нашу
частину із перегляду відео яке було
розроблено та створено нашими
європейськими колегами тож увага на
екран
[музика]
Ну що ж дуже дякуємо бачимо те що
потужні можливості відкриваються те що
європейська перспектива ті горизонти яка
Вона відкриває справді вартує того аби
долучитись послухати подивитися Ну і
власне спробувати на собі взяти активну
участь у відповідних програмах Хто як не
наші європейські партнери можуть краще
розказати про перспективи про можливості
та про здобутки Отож і з радістю
запрошено до слова першу спікерку нашої
тематичної панелі Отож вітайте будь
ласка пані Марію лік яка розкаже нам про
новий вид взаємодії у програмі горизонт
Європа партнерства дімаря The flories
please Welcome Welcome to Us
вітаємо вас передаємо вам слово
Добрий день Дякую за увагу я Мене звати
Марія лик
Ні я працюю DJ
Я вже мала Минулого року нагоду
представити нашу роботу і сьогодні я
буду говорити про
те які можливості надає хорайзон Юра ми
є презентації є чотири блоки Спочатку я
розкажу що відбувалося за останній рік
Також я буду говорити про те що
очікувати в наступній робочій програмі
буду говорити про можливості участі І
нарешті я розкажу про те
що таке чому полягає процес стратегічної
координації для партнерства Ну я думаю
що деякі знають цей слайд Я просто хочу
нагадати тим
хто з нами Минулого року не був
у нас в горизонт Європа є
різний підхід до партнерства
порівняють що це за 2020-м роком тут
більше стратегії більше фокусу на
результат вони більш відкриті прозорі і
вони мають започаткувати синергії з
різними
програмами ЄС у нас є три основні форми
партнерства перше - це
копрограмування співпрограмування на
основі меморандумав про порозуміння
співфінансування
і інституціоналізація
там свої
угоди і основні етапи розвитку
це
червень 2021 року коли
було запущено 11
європейських партнерств з
співпрограмування
14 липня ми запустили
єврейські
ми
запускаємо стратегічний Координаційний
процес процес для партнерства
і
робить зробляємо
спеціальну систему з звітування для
європейської партнерства
таких партнерство
і трошки детальніше про це ми
вже прийняли
єдиний основний акт
і це
він вже зовсім інший ніж такий як ми
використовували раніше там своє
законодавча база тут більше узгодження
і є
там основи які забезпечують більш
синергії більше узгодження
партнерство відбувається набагато
простіше Також у нас Ми розіслали листи
різним урядовим структурам і
[музика]
це включала в себе відповідні українські
інституції Якщо говорити про
копрограмування
співпрограмування ми запустили 11 таких
партнерств
у червні
є програма і вони зараз
працюють на додатковими заходами
всередині
з партнерства Якщо говорити про
співфінансування У нас є багато таких
партнерство 16
В основному в першому і 6 кластері я
покажу структуру їхню
і 9 ще буде
будуть
запущені цього року і наступного року і
ще
їм буде запущено в протягом наступної
програми
ви бачите структуру наших партнерство
в першому класстарі три два в п'ятому
три в шостому і також
інноваційні
малі і середні підприємства в третьому
напрямку
ми будемо
запускати
партнерство які стосуються
сталої економіки
і так далі
наша програма включає в себе плани на
2022-23 план
У нас є вісім партнерств які включені в
фальшиві шостий клас чому 8 ми ще не
вірили чи вони будуть частиною програмою
спів програмування або співфінансування
через пандемію
також є вже
терміни наступного року на початку ми
будемо відправляти
листи
запрошенням до участі і
ми будемо знати які країни
зацікавлені в цих партнерствах і на
результатами
відповідаємо ми будемо розуміти які
виділити бюджет для цих партнерства тут
ви бачите діаграму де видно всіх
партнерства кандидати
те що виділено червоним
кольором
[музика]
це те що включено в програму
23-24 ну і бачите
інституційні партнерства оранжевим
виділено
синім це партнерство з співграмування і
співфінансовані проекти партнерства
виділені
Зеленим кольором
синьо-зеленим кольором
І я також хочу сказати які можливості
надають ці партнерства тут
ви бачите партнерства які вимагають
участь країн
всередині цих країн Це в основному
першому класі два партнерства в 5 і
деякі спів спільні ініціативи
глобальне партнерство
в напрямку здоров'я і так далі
важливо зазначити що країна взяла участь
щоб зацікавлені сторони могли отримати
результат потрібно відправити результат
листа участі
і
заявити про своє участь
фінансування надається тільки юридичним
особам
як я вже сказала що деякі партнерства
будуть скоро запущені вони зараз на
етапі підготування
готуються угоди про надавання грантів
але важливо знати що багато вже
проведено зусиль щодо підготовки Якщо ви
хочете зв'язатися з координатором таких
партнерств
вони можуть
вам надати якісь можливості
можливо підписати
угоду про надання гранту можливо
відкласти його на якісь час ці
партнерства які виділені червоним
кольором вони
заплановані на
23-24 рік Ви можете взяти участь і
самого початку ви можете
долучитися
У нас є контактні особи
координатори
Вони є на сайті є ви можете вже
відправляти листи участь Якщо говорити
про
комп'ютерні технології
ми
У нас є
вже є денний
акт і ви можете також свої всі листи
участі відправити
ще партнерства які укладаються не в
країнах а а з
компаніями представниками промисловості
в основному ви не укладається за
асоціаціями промисловими
і як вони можуть долучитися вони можуть
ці підприємства об'єднатися
ну сюди входять чиста авіація єдина
європейське небо і європейська залізниця
там немає асоціації Але це буде
заклик відкритий заклик
є такі
також є можливість для участі
партнерства для громадськості
але якщо ви будете партнером то ви
отримуєте додаткові можливості Я бачу що
Час проходить мій але на цій таблиці ви
побачите
які є вимоги
долучення до європейських
партнерських проектів
зверніть увагу до
якщо
на інформацію щодо співфінансованих
проектів і метрологічних проектів є
стаття 225
яка обмежує
яка містить певні обмеження
і нарешті є
нова
структура керування
називається стратегічний координа ночі
процес це діалог між комісією і країнами
партнерами про те як вибираються
партнерства як відбувається
нагляд над портфоліо цих партнерських
проєктів і такі спеціальні
центр знань
І зараз є країни як Норвегія
що говорити про початкові умови то
країни всі країни які хочуть долучитися
можуть висловитись висловити своє
бажання
можна
подивитися вимогах
є також так званий дворічний
моніторинговий звіт перший звіт
буде наступного року в першому кварталі
готовий і де ми покажемо
наші партнерства
ситуація на той момент як я амбіції
базовий рівень і також
У нас вже будуть
пропозиції і ці партнерства допоможуть
нам ці звіти поможуть нам
зрозуміти і як
виглядає ситуація
все тепер мій час вийшов Дякую за увагу
і я буду рада відповісти на ваші
запитання
Ну і власне рухаємось далі наш нон-стоп
триває Дякуємо дуже і рухаємось до
наступного спікера Отож Ми продовжуємо і
продовжимо тепер говоримо про можливості
співпраці У рамках об'єднаного
дослідницького центру Європейської
комісії до слова Запрошуємо пані Олену
відович і пана Рамона римеріса просимо
дякую добрий день
мене звати Ірина федович це
службовець з політик Я рада що в мене є
можливість
розказувати про роботу нашу Це нашого
центру і можливості які ми надаємо ну
якщо говорити про спільний дослідницький
центр це такий центр
і його місія
підтримувати
[музика]
зусилля і співпрацю
з науковцями
і цей центр створив такі координовані
центри знань Вони мають зібрати до купи
експертів
з європейськими комісії для того щоб
зібрати інформацію необхідно для
створення політик ви бачите
кількість центрів таких знань наприклад
як ви бачите на слайді
нещодавно було відкрито 3 з таких
спостереженням за землі з боротьбою з
раками і різноманітності також цим
центри зраджуються на інформаційних
інструментах які можуть стосуватися
будь-якої теми наприклад та
макроекономічна
оцінка центр компетенції щодо передачі
технологій і нарешті ті наша центр мають
50-6 унікальних дослідницьких об'єктів
країнах і тут ви можете
перепрошуємо за такі незручності Можливо
я повторюю останні слова щодо нашого до
сільського центру у нас є 56 унікальних
об'єктів
п'ятих країнах членах і ми тут бачимо
приклад деяких з них наприклад
лабораторія дослідження викидів
автомобілів
лабораторія ядерної криміналістики та
інше для того щоб побудувати потенціал а
ми відкриваємо ці
можливості цих лабораторій так що ж і
для зовнішніх користувачів серед
представників
смб і
промисловості також країни асоційовані
члени як Україна може брати в цьому
участь
ми зараз оголосили
запрошення подавати заявки і ми можемо
побачити посилання внизу слайда
що ви почули За ці пару хвилин про
спільний центр дослідження ціль нашої
співпраці і також з Україною основна
ціль така допомогти посилити системи
інновації і наукових досліджень для того
щоб допомогти передачі технології
посилити підтримати прийняття рішень
згідна європейського законодавства
як це відбувається через
спеціалізацію передачу технології
переходи до зеленої економіки і згідно
порядку денного від липня 2021 року
як є п'ять довготривалих
цілей і в цілі після 22-го року це все
впровадження спеціалізації стратегії
спеціалізації і розробка планів передачі
технології щодо розумної спеціалізації
Україна є одним з найбільш важливих
партнерів
нашого центру наша колеги працюють паціє
темі безпосередньо і це буде Результати
будуть презентовані після моєї
презентації що стосується передачі
технології ми не ви знаєте наскільки
складно виводити результати дослідження
на ринок Отже ми є компетентним сектором
для передачі технології з
проводимо діагностику і
оригінальний аналіз
стану передачу технології в країнах
східного партнерства включаючи Україну і
ми описуємо основні характеристики
ландшафту включаючи
відповідних стиль холдерів гравців
кінцевої ціллю є надавати інформацію і
фактаж для прийняття необхідних
політичних решений рішень і
каналізації результатів що звіт цього
кримінального аналізу поки що стадії
розробки знаходиться але я низька звітів
з інших країн які вже були підготовлені
та опубліковані
звіту по Україні ми можемо знайти якщо
піти за посиланням яке ми бачимо на
слайді для того щоб куртка поставити
рекомендацію для України то ми
пропонуємо законодавчої реформи
спрощення законодавства створення
спеціального Суду
також
нарощування потенціалу і
фонди для підтвердження концепції
і засоби фінансових засоби такі як
звільнення від податків або інновацій
для ваучерів
щодо
дорожньої карти передачу технології у
нас тут йдеться про фінансову підтримку
співпрацю між науковими колами та
промисловістю і розбудову спроможності
звичайно ми готові підтримувати Ці
зв'язки розвиток
Україною і декілька слів Ще що до
захисту довкілля
інноваційний процес севіля процес
Севілья це інноваційний процес
для
спрямований на запобігання
забруднення і назва походить від міста
Севілья в Іспанії
надає можливість обмінюватися між тих
холдами інформацію
агросектори в інших секторах і побачити
вплив викидів на довкілля
цей обмін інформацією
здійснюється на основі фантажу
представленого
дослідженнями недержавними організаціями
Міро комісії основні результати ми цього
обміну інформацією задокументовані в так
званому референтному документі коли
прийме буде прийнято то це стане
обов'язковим стандартом для
промисловості
центр надає найкращі посилання
щодо технології
в різних секторах як ми бачимо на екрані
Цей підхід визнаний на міжнародному
рівні як успішний для того щоб
встановлювати
спільні стандарти захисту довкілля
Цей підхід стає дедалі більше важливим в
Україні то Україна також наближує своє
законодавство включаючи і
стосовно довкілля стосовно впровадження
найкращих технологій Україна також бере
участь в обміні знаннями і найкращими
технологіями за програмою захисту
довкілля на останньому слайді ми можемо
побачити певні інтернет посилання за
темою я передам слово
колезі хто який буде презентувати
інформацію щодо розумної спеціалізації
Так Дуже дякую Олена
Так ми бачимо презентацію на екрані
І я хотів би перш за все подякувати
Україну
що ви маєте таку успішно організовану
реформ і я радий прийняти в ньому взяти
в ньому участь
виступати
Я вже працюю з Україною 5 років Я бачу
великі потенціал цей країні Я спробував
бути дуже дуже коротко відповісти тому
що у нас обмаль час я думаю що
оця тема
відома аудиторії сьогоднішнього форуму
розумного спеціалізація починається з
палітики інновацій і який результат це
має на суспільство на сталість це
актуальна і для країн-членів Європи і
зараз
застосовується по всьому світу для країн
сусідів також в Україні
нас є співпраця яка триває вже
триває понад 4 роки ми підтримуємо
розвиток регіональних стратегій розумної
спеціалізацією ми вже провели
низку заходів з покращення бізнесу на
національному регіональному рівнях ми
проводимо дослідження
картографування економічних економічних
потенціалу і також ми провели три
практичних семінари
у нас були представники для того щоб
дати
навички
того щоб пізніше розробити такі
стратегії і також ми злочин до прямої
експертної підтримки
щодо розробки розумної спеціалізації
стратегії спеціалізації і також
намагаємося залишити і поєднати різні
регіони починаючи з цього року ми також
започаткували роботу на національному
рівні щодо смарт спеціалізації для
виконання сіли сталого розвитку і в мене
є слайд присвячений цьому також ми раді
бачити що є поступ поступи інтереси і
серед регіонів які співпрацюють з нами
зараз з питання розумної спеціалізації
наразі 12 областей зареєструвалися на
нашій платформі ми бачимо тут посилання
і більше регіонів більше областей
звертаються до нас безпосередньо або
через центральний уряд для того щоб
зареєструватись на нашій платформі і
ознайомитися як розпочати процеси
розробки стратегії експертна підтримка
дуже важливий елемент в нас целя
спрямована підтримка для того щоб
підтримати в регіоні в розробці їхні
стратегії в нас вже є досить велика
кількість областей які співпрацюють з
нами я зараз не буду їх вліщувати я лише
зупинюсь на планах на наступний рік
Ми плануємо залучити щонайменше 7
регіонів ця інформація ще не підтримує
підтверджена ми зараз введемо діалог з
як з міністерством такої регіонами які
будуть раді отримувати надалі тепер
експертного підтримку Це ті що з нами
працювали і раніше і будуть деякі нові
знову ж таки це всі регіони з якими ми
працювали і будемо працювати
певні дослідження щодо картографування
аби краще впроваджувати політики щодо
досліджень та інновацій
національний рівень - це нові рівень
співпраці який ми започаткували в 21-му
році
досягненням цей співпраці є
дорожня карта як досягти цілей сталого
розвитку і як залучати потенціал і на
вас і технології до цього Україна була
визначена як пілотна країна це єдина
країна яка
для
міжвидовою команди
і
ми залучення до
написання певних планів одна останніх
речей як я хотів би зазначити це один із
наших основних звітів які ми скоро
Сподіваюся
публікуємо на початку Наступного року ми
провели вивчати дослідження
в країні східного партнерства за яких
Україна входить є потенціал співпраці
щодо знань це дослідження досліджує
можливості зміну знаннями і також з
ціною потенціал щодо інновації країни
В мене є пара слайдів які демонструють
які будуть результати звичайно
методології повне дослідження і
результати коментарі будуть представлені
а також багато інших раз аспектів нашого
дослідження
ми про певний потенціал дослідження
технології
контексті економічних класів кластерів
економічних сфер основних галузей і
сподіваємося що це допоможе не тільки
для розвитку
стратегії
спеціалізація але також для розкриття
інноваційного і дослідницького
потенціалу країни На цьому я хотів би
завершити мою коротку презентацію для
того щоб захищати певний час для Питання
якщо аудиторії будуть такі питання дуже
дякую за увагу
Дякуємо нашим спікерам за презентацію з
принту нас дуже щільний ми усі наші
питання спробуємо зібрати передати нашим
спікерам залишити на кава паузу на час
спілкування для тих спікерів хто
знаходиться в аудиторії для спікерів які
знаходяться онлайн усі питання
обов'язково зберемо передамо тож будь
ласка Якщо є питання обов'язково пишіть
вони обов'язково спікербуть
переадресовані Ну що ж колеги рухаємось
поспринту нагадуємо нашим спікерам про
таймінг оскільки програма попереду дуже
Щільна дуже потужна У нас дуже багато ще
однарних дискусій презентацією є певне
не те що ми з вами отримаємо для себе
дуже і дуже багато корисної інформації
та перспектив говорячи про перспективу і
новаційному уже трошки торкнулися цієї
теми під час нашої попередньої панелі і
зараз пропоную продовжити тему інновації
тему технологій Ну а саме У рамках
програми горизонт Європа на повна
потужність запустила свою роботу
європейська інноваційна рада про яку нам
розкаже наш наступний спікер Отож пане
Ерік олів'є павлус запрошуємо вас до
слова
Добрий день Вітаю всіх
для таких
перевних технологій інновацій і вона є
унікально в світі
через те що поєднує
дослідження таких технологій які
з'являються і стартапи і
маштабування
найбільшим в Україні в цей в сфері все
більш там понадто три мільярди ми
говоримо про себе як
інноваційноцентричними у нас дуже
активні такі підхід
гнучке фінансування для стартапів для
мсп Ми намагаємося
робити дійсно європейську інноваційну
екосистему причина чому ми утворили
таку європейську і не інноваційного Раду
Да є три такі причини
А що в нас велика
база розробок
фінансування і у нас також Якщо
порівняти з
США у нас не такі проривні технології
але ми можемо
створювати ринки по всьому світу
У нас є такі
пробіли такі
долини смерті як ми їх називаємо
перехід
від лабораторії до
корпорації до ринку і
нас є обмеження можливості масштабування
для
інноваційних стартапів з високим ризиком
також Можливо ви знаєте У нас є проблеми
з глобальною екосистемою інновації вона
дуже фрагментована і нам потрібно
включити туди всі регіони таланти
особливо жінок
у нас
порівняли цифри
для інвестиції в мене чорний капітал
бачите що вони
в США вище 4 чи 5 разів ніж в ЄС це для
наших стартапів
таке слабке місце в результаті в Європі
менше
єдинорогів ніж в Північній Америці в
Азії включаючи
Китаю це такі компанії з капіталом більш
ніж мільярд капіталів
також Якщо говорити про
технологічність ми відійшли від позиції
спів лідерства з США
в цьому столітті зараз в лідерах Америка
Азія
за ЄС і питання хто буде лідером
наступні роки хто буде лідером цих
технологіях
на два роки в нас два роки у нас вже діє
пілотна фаза
в рамках горизонту 2020 бюджет складає
3,5 мільярди і ми
проводили таку новацію ми
злили разом свої фінанси в 2019 році
і ми тих компаній які підтримуємо ми
забезпечуємо їхні потреби я потім
розкажу детальніше про це у нас дуже
в великий попит
щороку має
отримуємо багато заявок також надається
спеціальна підтримка інновацій які
пов'язані з ковідом з зеленими угодами і
Ми продовжуємо це робити Також ми
підтримуємо жінок і Новаторів Також ми
набираємо
програмних керівників
дуже активно
вже є результати їх можна відчути вже є
конкретні цифри
і ми залучаємо інвесторів
вкладати
своєю фінанси і також ми шукаємо
продовження інвестування цих компаній
які ми підтримуємо і ми вже
залучили майже 10 мільярдів
подальших інвестицій в нас є три
єдинорога
20.91 Кентавр це компанії
чи капітал нараховує більш ніж 100
мільйонів євро
і основні теми з якими ми працюємо це
Зелена угода Digital і охорона здоров'я
з дослідженням
є три основні напрямки тематичні
як і входять в нас в наш портфоліо це
Digital зліва верху ви бачите
охорона здоров'я внизу зліва і справа
Це важлива тема яка включає в себе
енергетику це зелені угоди
в рамках горизонт Європа У нас є нове
керування нова законодавча база
є
наша рада
яка буде діяти з
кінця січня
буде новий президент
і зараз
ми є
виконуючий інституцію агенцією яка буде
керувати всіма діями і осі
є фонд
який буде підтримувати 37 компаній
нарешті Європейська комісія
наглядає за
зусиллями з назначення ради і
впровадження
планів це наша Рада яка буде діяти з
цього року до 23-го року
це
дуже еталоновиті і Новатори
інвестори
дослідники які мають чудовий досвід
у своїх сферах
Отже я сім повноцінної осі складається
з різних елементів що важливо сказати це
те що ми маємо три різних інструменти
нашому ланцюгу інновації
вже слідопит
- це включає в себе дослідження на
ранніх етапах гранти до 3-4
мільйонів якщо буде успіх ми переходимо
до перехідної фази
Коли
технологи переходять зі стану концепції
до перевірки
готується вихід Ми готуємося до виходу
на ринок і гранти включають в себе до
двох з половиною мільйонів і нарешті
коли проєкт виходить на новий етап
починається фаза axelrator
це фаза розвитку і масштабування
сюди входять змішані фінанси це гранти
до двох з половиною мільйонів а також
інвестиції цінних паперів до 15
мільйонів євро
на даний момент ви бачите
наші
фінансуванням заходи з фінансування 2021
році
Ми вибрали 65 компаній які отримали
фінансування на етапі акселератор і
нещодавно ми вибрали 99 компаній
ви бачите для та послідопит
в бюджет вказаний в колонці справа
компанія які ми підтримуємо
Мають доступ до різних послуг
бізнес
акселераторів не тільки навчання і
менторінг це корадпортивні дні я знаю що
є принаймні одна українська компанія яку
ми вже вибрали на пілотній фазі
[музика]
Микола
Я думаю сьогодні буде говорити про це
детальніше і буде розказувати які в
нього досить співпраці з ЄС і нарешті
про наших програмних менеджерів які
керують нашими портфоліо
в проектів у нас є 4 ми ще будемо 6
нових проектів набирати В наступні
місяці я перепрошую я на жаль нічого не
чую тому я не зможу відповісти на ваші
запитання Я перепрошую відразу дякую
на що ж Дякуємо вам Дякуємо за бісійну
інформацію і рухаємось далі
власне ми починали вже із такого
інструменту давати з тих інструментів
які відкривають європейські перспективи
програми горизонт Ну і Власне цей
потужний інструмент розвитку такий
європейський інноваційна рада Ми про неї
щойно почули і Я впевнений те що від
колег ми почуємо ще багато різноманітних
інсайтів та інформації стосовно того
така як же як же то все зробити втілити
у своє життя Ну і принагідно оці залі
присутні дуже багато тих людей які є
експертами які є досвідченими у напрямку
співпраці з горизонтом Отож
використовуйте можливості партнертесь
обмінюватись контактами Ну я впевнений
те що разом ми зможемо досягнути справді
великих європейських горизонтів ми тим
часом рухаємось далі і власно в мене
таке відчуття те що ми отримали уже
безлічбіційної інформації А скільки ми
ще зможемо отримати
Отож для того аби продовжити я і з
радістю запрошую нашу наступну спікерку
Марк тут томасилє ну і власне наступна
доповідь вона буде присвячена
пріоритетам та місії горизонт Європа на
якій будуть спрямовані відкриті коли та
проекти мотор Запрошуємо до слова пані
Марту Томас Еллі будь ласка сина ваша
дякую дякую за
запрошення всім добрий день я рада тут
бути і говорити про те в чому полягають
що ж змінилося в горизонт Європа
Ну що потрібно зрозуміти це чому нам
потрібні місії Я думаю що багато з вас
знають що
є Марія на мацюка Та яка
працює в університеті Каліфорнії
і було поставлено
ціль
яка є вже має конкретні
часові рамки чому нам потрібні місії нам
потрібно бути ближче до людей люди мають
зрозуміти що конкретно єсть робить
щодо вирішення проблем щодо яких
Громадяни мають занепокоєння також це
включає в себе визначення
пріоритетіїв є
це зелені угоди
боротьба з раком я не буду говорити про
всіх їх
наступний момент - це
способи впливу для цього потрібно мати
підхід на основі портфоліо
і тут
враховується те що
є програма політики не тільки на
Європейському рівні але не національному
рівні
якщо ми детальніше подивимось на історію
європейських місій
в вересні 2020 році є була така
група експертів і було запропоновано 5
напрямків цих місць
в різних напрямках
і також
громадяни які брали участь у онлайн
заходах громадяни ділилася своїм ідеями
далі було прийнято стратегічний план від
2020 році як
зелені угоди і так далі І потім почалася
підготовча фаза де було розроблено план
впровадження і ці плани
це були проекти
різних заходів
які мали включати в себе
цілі і комплекси заходів потрібні для
того щоб досягти цих цілей перше версія
горизонт Європа було
випущені в 2021 році в червні
за літо
вже на політичному рівні це було
прийнято і 29 вересня 2021 році
було запущено 5 європейських місць
європейські місії мають на митці
рішення
основних проблем які стоять перед ЄС
по-перше зміни на клімату
і всі місії основані найноваціях це
означає що ми з цього відштовхуємося
і на основі цього ми вирішуємо проблеми
наших громадян в країнах ЄС ці місії
будуть працювати
між різними експертами між різними
тематиками звичайно Тут будуть залучення
науковці підприємці
державної сектор залучення місцевих
громад
цивільного суспільства як будуть
працювати ці місії ну по-перше результат
буде досягатися завдяки інноваціям і
дослідженням
бо
На цьому етапі потрібні потрібна
підтримка з різних напрямках для
налаштування
масштабування результатів
потрібна підтримка
урядів бо необхідно зміна законодавчої
бази вирішення інфраструктурних питань а
не тільки технічних тобто тут потрібно
зібрати представників різних секторів
для того щоб вони працювали над
вирішенням
однієї проблеми яка міститься в місці
також
потрібно встановити нові зв'язки з
громадянами
встановити систему звітування
і також залучати громадян на етапі
впровадження місії і моніторинговій фазі
є напрямок 2 і тут всі місії тут
перераховані
ці місії можуть
переглядатися на законодавчому рівні
на 2023 році це буде отримувати 10%
бюджету
я 5 місії ЄС які включають в себе
адаптацію до змін клімату боротьба з
раком
відновлення водних ресурсів
ґрунт і
кліматична нейтральність
Ну я б розкажу про всі цілі
на презентації є qr-коди Які ви можете
скористатись і ви можете відкрити
документ Де написано всі цілі кожна
емісії
Якщо говорити про адаптацію до
кліматичних змін то ми хочемо підтримати
як мінімум 150 європейських регіонів від
громад для того щоб вони могли бути
забезпечити кліматичну стійкість до 2030
року і ми маємо продемонструвати
що це можливо і цей досвід можна
масштабувати ми будемо проводити 75
масштабних демонстрацій які покажуть
систематичні трансформації по всій
Європі по всіх європейських громадах
боротьба з раком планується покращити
якість життя 3 млн людей до 2030 року
будуть
консолідовані зусилля щодо знаходження
ліків
сімей і покращення
якості життя хворих на рак
по-перше треба покращити
розуміння проблеми з боку громадян
потрібно сфокусувати свої зусилля на
профілактиці раку
оптимізації діагностики підтримка якості
життя
і також у Європі є спеціальний план щодо
боротьби з раком відновлення водних
ресурсів
на меті ці зусилля мають захист і
відновлення
морських і прісного водних екосистем
різномаїття
профілактика і
мінімізація забруднення водних ресурсів
забезпечення сталості
синьої економіки яка має бути
вуглеценейтральною
кліматично нейтральність і Smart міста
мета полягає в
створені принаймні 100 кліматично
нейтральних
Smart міст в Європі
і всі міста можуть
докладати цю сил до досягнення цілей
зелених угод для того щоб з мінімізувати
викиди на 55%
також це надає багато переваг мешканцям
що приведе до менших
цін на комуналку і так далі
угоди пов'язані з ґрунтом в Європі
мета полягає в створенні 100
інтерактивних лабораторій і
маяків для того щоб
очолити перехід в напрямку
забезпечення
вищої якості ґрунтів до 2030 року
і нарешті
співпраця разом для того щоб майбутнє
покоління мали більше чистий продуктивні
грунти
то щоб
це стояло гарному впливу на населення і
на клімату
29-го березня офіційний сайт була
запущена
запущена і до кінця року буде
опублікований світ а друга поправка буде
весною
впровадження 22-го року вона буде
присвячена найбільше широким інноваціям
і заходам як залучитися до місії
звичайно плани з інтерпретації про які я
говорила створюють основу
місії будь ласка користуйтесь qr-кодом і
зайдіть наш сайт щодо запрошення до
участі
різних уже були
опубліковані з 21-му році оновлені за
цей рік яке буде публіковане до кінця
року ви побачите багато заходів з
досліджень та інновацій а ще більше з
них заплановано оновлені на 22-й рік
також організовуємо інформаційні дні
вони будуть проходити в січні які новини
Якщо ви хочете дізнатись Будь ласка
заходьте на веб-сайти від мене все Я
сподіваюсь вам сподобалась моя
презентація
Саме так дуже дякуємо за таку потужну
презентацію і з безліччю корисних порад
та безцінної інформації дякуємо вам
Ми сьогодні так багато говоримо про
програму горизонт Європа але є якщо не
помиляюсь то окрім власне цієї програми
і окрім того що 12 жовтня Україна стала
асоційованим членом програми Ми також
долучились і до комплементарної програми
горизонт Європа що це таке які
можливості відкриваються програма ну
власне про це поговоримо із нашим
наступним спікером пане Миколо
дзюбінський запрошуємо вас до слова
просимо
сьогодні говорити Ну і безумовна порада
комунікувати спілкуватись долучатись для
того аби справді відчути те що працює це
не просто
Добрий день
я можу продовжувати так
шановні пані і панове для мене є
приємністю презентувати цю програму
єдина проблема яка мене завжди є з
презентацією в Україні я не знаю на якій
мові говорити
я буду пробувати переходити з
української на англійську де це буде
потреба і надіюся що перекладати
матч
[музика]
запропонували Future Action
велика дуже презентація це за розмірами
і я спробую зупинитись на найбільш
важливих пунктах
я презентація Я думаю буде Ну дійсно вам
перше хто ми такі чому євроатом чому
горизонт Європа і
як і разом залучений до цієї програми і
одним із пріоритетів на періоди 25-го
року я сподіваюсь що ви вже знаєте що
один на три більших пріоритетів
комісії це
рухатись напрямку декарбанізації та
більш здорової планети є певні ключові
показники ефективності Один з них до
2030-го року скоротити викиди
парникового газу на 55% в порівнянні до
19-м роком а до 2020 року Європа повинна
стати першим
нейтральним континентом
Я хотів би пояснити чому Герасим'юк і
чому євроатом є різні угоди які
ми керуються європейським Союз основна
така Це
угода договір про
функціонування ЄС
грайзен юрапа і друга другий
договор є договір про євро А там ця
доповнююча програма
доразів
ми маємо справу з розпадом і синтезом і
також проводимо певні дослідження в
нашому спільному центрі звичайно не можу
прийняти це з бюджетом всієї програми
горизонт Європа - це якраз менше але все
ж таки
як це виглядає загальний картині Я хотів
би перейти пояснити деякі
На жаль проблема Із звуком
я буду говорити про основні аспекти
посвідчення євроатами як я зазначав
Оскільки ми комплементарно або додатково
програма прийнята окремим рішенням
єврокомісії комісії у нас програма на 5
років основна програма на 7 років в
основному Ця програма наша програма теж
продовжується на два роки для того щоб
відповідати тому ж самому
періоду
7 років горизонт Європа
основна сіль
договором і регламентом це
навчання досягнення на вищих можливих
стандартів безпеки захищеності ядерних
технологій в новій програмі
21-25 роки
зроблений акцент на переході від
використання ядерних технологій чисто
все енергетик і також використовувати це
в медичній галузі в інших Ми створюємо
партнерські стосунки з іншими наприклад
Ми також
намагаємося вимагати все це
економічні аспекти
є програми дослідження для аспірантів з
20-го року вони також можуть звертатися
до програми Марії Кюрі
підтримкою раніше це було неможливо А
зараз можливо
це наші базові
базові бюджети на наступні роки десь
один і чотири мільярди євро приблизно і
вона Він розподілений на ф'южн єврофішин
266 мільйонів для фішин або розпаду
55 грн на рік і для
самих хтось сидить Жень центром знову ж
таки основні пріоритети досить
стандартні ми маємо справу з безпекою
ядерної безпеки
чому вас видно на екрані лише перший
слайд
Я не знаю чому так Зараз
я на слайді номер 10 чи є можливість для
вас листати мої слайди
перепрошую за проблему
Отож бачимо те що можливостей насправді
багато кожна із них різна але кожна із
них відкриває нові
перепрошую за цю технічну проблему зараз
це працює
які основні
пріоритети основна частина моєї
презентації
ще раз перепрошую за технічну замінку
все ж таки продовжую з презентацією
основні пункти має презентація наразі
ми в вересні дали запрошення на участь
Це дворічне запрошення
не тільки
У нас є дворічні річні які відрізняються
від інших програм горизонт Європа один є
на два роки а для
розпаду мільйонів
в вересні такі були зараз
здається
що дехто з України подали пропозиції які
будуть результати поки що невідомо але
всі
заявники будуть
проінформовані до 15 лютого наступного
року
чи успішними вони були чи ні
наступне запрошення
буде
про на програму на період 23-24 років
запрошень
може програма буде напевно До кінця
наступного на початку 23-го року
прийнята і запрошення вірогідно буде в
травні 23-го року запущено з кінцевим
соком у вересні 23 а оцінка буде
проведена
восени і ми шини очікуємо що наступний
гора з контракти
Професіонал будуть підписані
весною
було запрошення раніше
близько партнерства вже прийшла оцінка і
наскільки я знаю
зараз грантова вода
готується до підписання і
коли маю українські партнери
отримують можливість фінансування з
21-го року Перепрошую ще це технічні
проблеми
питання стосовно нашої програми будь
ласка задавайте бо якщо нема питань то
або все зрозуміло або нічого не
Зрозуміло дякую
дякуємо вам за надзвичайну інформативну
презентацію на жаль обмежень таймінгу
дуже щільні а впевнений те що ви
учасників запитання багато але просто
спринт у нас триває тому усі із питання
збираємо передамо обов'язково і колеги
до усіх спікерів величезне прохання дуже
цікаві теми дуже цікаві доповіді
презентації та дуже обмежені у таймінгу
тому будь ласка величезне прохання до
усіх спікерів слідкувати за таймінгом а
усі питання які будуть виникати Я
сподіваюсь їх буде багато так і є мені
підказують ретектори на даний момент усі
ці питання обов'язково передамо і також
у нас ще буде кавабрик під час кава
брийко під час нетворкінгу буде
можливість поспілкуватись із тими
спікерами які знаходяться у цьому залі
ну і тим паче можливостей відкривається
багато із присутніх наших учасників є
надзвичайно досвідченими Вони уже мають
досвід взаємодії з програмою горизонт
Отож використовуйте можливості партнерти
спілкуйтесь обмінюйтесь досвідом
сьогоднішній захід саме про наступне
день для мене сьогодні дуже
інформативний і я би хотів зараз
звернути увагу на ще один важливий
аспект реалізації програми горизонт
Європа а саме забезпечення відкритості
наукових даних і виконання принципу Open
scence що ж про інструмент який
допомагає в реалізації і де відкрити
науки нам зараз і розкаже наш наступний
спікер Олександр берега Олександри вам
слово будь ласка
Доброго дня шановні колеги
Дякую що запросили мене звати Олександр
березко І я розповім вам про спів
можливості співпраці
згідно платформи відкритих досліджень в
Європі
як там в львівському університеті і є
учасником євродок це європейська рада
кандидатів наук та молоді дослідження
десь віддників вона охоплює
26 різних країн в Євросоюзі також за
межами знаходиться в Брюсселі як
розробляє і доводить політику Україна з
2014 року є повноцінним членом євродок
євро так зосереджується на декільках
темах сьогодні одним з таких фокусів
відкрита наука
поки що получився певні дискусії як це
визначити але загалом відкрита наука це
такі підхід
до наукових процесів які зосереджуються
на розповсюдженні знань Як тільки ви не
стають доступними з використанням
цифрових та
з спільних технологій ми використовуємо
відкриті джерела даних інше інструменти
відкрити наука є в основі програми
горизонту Європа як
використовувати
як
наукова хмарне сховище і
європейська відкрита Наукова платформа
ми обмінюємося практиками і досліджень
ми по всій низці проектів горизонту
Європа євродок
дуже цікавина я у принципі відкритої
науки
є
рекомендації є програма для
і вона стала партнером
відкрите дослідження в Європі Я хотів би
трошки розповісти про
це інноваційна платформа яку запустили в
березні цього року у співпраці з
європейською комісією після процесу
державних закупівель ціль
донести до учасникам проєкту
Європа можливість публікувати свої
роботи з безкоштовно і в інформатики про
політику відкритого доступу
близько висота було написано
статей з цього приводу
і місія хочу бути
лідером таким і
застосовуючим вимоги до платформи Ми
повинні слід слідувати принципами
перегляду
робіт колегами і відкрита політика щодо
оплати
як публікуються вони відкритому доступі
і платформа проводить перегляньте
що дозволяє дуже швидко публікацію і
доступ як
робота пройшла перегляд колегами вона
відсилається до індексів що це означає
на практиці
має шість основних напрямків
відкриті методи наприклад
і
наприклад як взагалі
проводити експерименти
джерела означає що
все має бути опубліковано відкриті дані
і це також дозволяє відтворювати
результати дослідження Відкритий доступ
ви знаєте що навіть зараз
не вся література Наукова доступна для
загалу
платити і це така
складна ситуація для сучасного інтернету
для сучасності і політика відкритого
доступу має
цю проблему вирішити відкрити навчання
або відкриття освіти
це базується на відкритості всіх
навчально-методичних посібників
і все ж таки питання Чому саме відкрите
дослідження є чотири ключових принципи
прозорість
дозволяє всім зрозуміти як все
відбувається і на всіх етапах
дослідження всі етапи відкриті
підзвітність
це означає що
простіше буде перевірити всі результати
які відправляються
і це
дозволяє публікація
і люди будуть бачити загальну картину
якщо
після експертної оцінки в
отримаєте відхилення то Часто люди не
знають чому причина
і важко створити
справедливу
справедливе середовище де всі
зацікавлені сторони будуть відчувати що
всі на рівних умовах беруть участь
якщо буде дотримуватися принцип
відкритості відкритості дослідження то
це буде викликати більше довіру вони
будуть знати Що публікується
процес експертної оцінки сьогодні
такі процеси мабуть
дуже широкий
етап дослідження
якщо б це почалося не 50% тому але в час
інтернету Я впевнений що це не так
працювала як зараз
експертна оцінка сприймається як золотий
стандарт оцінки
наукових робіт Але зараз
все ж таки ситуація трохи інша
багато видавців про це говорять відкрито
в чому проблема все ж таки
ну мабуть
те що
це не чітка додаткова наука це мистецтво
це суб'єктивна думка
і тут щось є певна експерт певна
суб'єктивна компонента
це
ставлення окремої людини до цієї роботи
тому
припускаються помилки
є зловживання тому що на цьому ринку є
велика конкуренція через це
не так просто
заслужити довіру до цього процесу це
процес не відкритий
і забезпечення від коритості експертної
оцінки має привести до збільшення довіри
до всієї системи і привести до
покращення процесу прямої комунікації
між усіма зацікавленими особами
редакторами
і
тут не буде все замішане на сприйнятті
чи не перейнятті роботи Все буде
зав'язано на покращення якості самої
роботи
і
відкриті до оцінки коментарі вони будуть
існувати як додатковий
механізм
покращення якості Ну що таке
відкрита експертна оцінка цьому є багато
визначень але
платформа Open Юра присяж має кілька
аспектів вимог - це від корита
ідентичність це означає що всі учасники
цього процесу знають один одного автори
експерти відкритість звітів всі звіти
публікуються разом з відповідним
матеріалом
і всі
хто читає матеріал можуть бачити всі
звіти і можуть навчатися з цього це
інструмент
відкритого менторства відкрите участь
означає що
широка громадськість може бути долучена
до проценту до процесу оцінки
всі
учасники можуть коментувати і
покращувати якість матеріалу
відкрита експертна оцінка має багато
переваг для всіх зацікавлених осіб для
авторів читачів і
тих хто здійснює оцінку
це все приводить до покращення
результатів
і
публікації можуть слугувати прикладами
для молодих дослідників
Якщо говорити про експертну оцінку це
труд
це важкий труд який часто
не винагороджується належним чином не
тільки в Україні але по всьому світу
і відкриті
звіти можуть сприйматися як
частину матеріалу
дослідження і вони мають також
публікуватися
Таким чином можна
[музика]
ті хто проводить оцінку можуть
заслуговувати довіру
чи можна відразу запустити цей процес
відкритого і оцінки ну мабуть
як нещодавно професор барен Монс сказав
культура дослідження є
вузьким місцем а не технологія
має бути має існувати культура яка буде
забезпечувати відкриту участь інакше
це буде неможливо Я просто хочу сказати
що сьогодні ми говоримо звичайно про
горизонт Європа але давайте не будемо
забувати про інші інструменти
розширення потенціалу
спроможності і я хочу розказати про
проект Optima він забезпечує відкриті
процеси прозорість
і цілісність для сучасних академічних
інституцій
всеукраїнський проект
як і маємо ті впровадження
практик відкритої науки
він буде
забезпечувати інтеграцію
української науки в європейське
середовище це все від мене
Дякую всім за увагу Якщо у вас є питання
щодо
платформи
запитуйте ви можете звернутися до мене
по месенджеру написати мені подзвонити
Дякую що запросили Якщо у вас є
запитання ви можете їх ставити
Ну що ж дуже дякуємо вам за вашу
презентацію за ті можливості які
презентували обов'язково скористаємось
відповідними можливостями Ну і колеги
якщо є запитання то безумовно не
вагайтесь просимо ставити усім спікерам
які сьогодні виступають виходячи із
попередньою панелі могло скластись
враження ти що інструменти європейської
підтримки лише працюють але насправді
держава теж піклується дуже активно
проте аби наука і новації технології
розвивалися в Україні і наступна наша
тематична панель вона буде присвячена
саме отаким інструментом можливостям які
розкажуть нам про те як в Україні все
відбувається і як українські організації
підключаються до того аби таку підтримку
забезпечити і розпочнемо ми нашого
тематичну панель і з презентація
державного фонду основною метою якого є
надання грантів для підтримки
вітчизняних наукових досліджень та
розробок І хоча національний фонд
дослідження і був створений не так давно
у липні 2018 року але на сьогоднішній
момент він показує неймовірно високі
результати у грантовій підприємці наших
вчених тож Дозвольте будь ласка і з
радістю запросити до слова виконавчу
директорку цього фонду Пані Ольго
полоцько Ольга будь ласка вітаємо
блисками
Добрий день шановні колеги в першу чергу
хочу всіх вас привітати з цим днем
на цей день насправді чекало багато
науковців і сам факт запрошення
національного фонду дослідження України
то участі в цьому заході Він говорить
про те що все ж таки ми хоча І абсолютно
вірно ми нова установа але вже маємо
певні досягнення Я сьогодні буду
намагатись вам про них трошечки
розповісти я виконавчий директор
Національного фонду дослідження України
- це організація яка була створена у
2018 році але фактично запрацювала у
2020-му тому що перші наші два конкурси
конкурси на проектів наукових досліджень
і розробок було об'явлено у 2020 році
тобто фактично ми займаємось грантовим
менеджментом десь приблизно півтора року
абсолютно було вірно сказано ми є
державною бюджетною установою і ми є
результатом реформ
і такого стратегічного руху України
українського суспільства наукового
суспільства до
[музика]
західних стандартів західних стандартів
грантової підтримки оцінювання грантових
проектів реалізації орантових проектів і
ми були створені як механізм спеціальний
механізм держави для того щоб
фінансувати найкраще наукові дослідження
виходячи виключно з їхньої якості оце
якості вона оцінюється під час конкурсів
Тобто ми надаємо грантову фінансування
виключно на конкурсних засадах створення
ми були Кабінету Міністрів України є
незалежною установою
це насправді другий да другий рік нашого
існування вже пішов але ми хочемо
сказати що
основні такі акценти розставити в нашій
діяльності вперше в першу чергу це
підтримка найкращих наукових ідей
найкращого інтелектуального потенціалу
серед усіх абсолютно науковців але
особливий акцент все ж таки робиться на
підтримці молодих вчених Я думаю що не
треба пояснювати заради чого це робиться
це робиться і для сталості розвитку
наукової думки в Україні і для того щоб
молоді науковці талановиті науковці вони
в першу чергу не кидали науку і або не
для того щоб вони не кидали науку в
Україні
Окрім цього ще одним з важливих
пріоритетів діяльності фонду є підтримка
технічної спроможності наукових
колективів в Україні
виконувати дослідження високого рівня
тому що не маючи відповідного рівня
обладнання або матеріалів неможливо
провести дослідження світового рівня
2020 рік він вніс серйозні корективи в
життя всієї світо спільноти І Наукова
спільнота вона не може стояти осторонь
від тих викликів з якими людство
зустрілось
наприкінці
2019-2020 році це вже набрала дуже таких
серйозних обертів і Саме через це одним
з пріоритетів наразі фінансування є
дослідження в галузі медицини
дослідження в галузі біотехнології
дуже серйозна увага приділяється
дослідженням які
вирішують проблеми безпеки держави це
може бути різні
види безпеки від екологічної до
інформаційної ну це також один із наших
пріоритетів Окрім цього фонд займається
ще і контролем і моріторінгом тих
досліджень які проводяться в Україні
нашими основними цілями при створенні
національного фонду дослідження України
Так це і залишається це фінансування
найкращих наукових проектів Як
фундаментального так і Прикладного
характеру що є дуже важливим ми не
виокремлюємо і практикуємо якраз
конкурси за принципом ботем Up або
ініціативні конкурси про які вже
сьогодні попередні спікери говорили це
знову ж таки така дуже гарна європейська
традиція коли самі науковці насправді
вирішуються яким за характером своїм
дослідженням їм треба займатися яке
дослідження буде на часі а вже під час
проходження експертизи експерти оцінюють
насправді якість таких досліджень
розбудова дослідницької інфраструктури я
вже сказала це обладнання але це не
тільки обладнання в такому ну
примітивному скажемо вигляді
інфраструктурні проекти Ми плануємо вже
розпочати фінансувати
найбільшими роками тому що наразі ми
фінансуємо виключно наукові дослідження
розробки але це одна з наших один з
наших пріоритетів
я вже сказала що ми підтримуємо молодих
науковців хотіла пару слів сказати У нас
вже було декілька конкурсів в яких
Обов'язковою умовою до колективу
науковців які подають заявки а потім
реалізують проект була певна кількість
молодих вчених в їх складі
по різних конкурсах цей відсоток він
відрізняється Окрім цього ми ще дуже
намагаємось популяризувати науку
популяризувати українських науковців
розповідати про те що в першу чергу
наука в Україні є і що Ця наука має
абсолютно чудові обличчя і за кожною
особистістю науковця стоїть дуже
серйозна історія роботи в першу чергу
над собою
іноді і такою дуже серйозною боротьби
тому ви розумієте що багато досить
багато років Українські науковці
працювали і в принципі зараз
продовжують працювати в умовах такого
серйозного недофінансування тепер
трошечки про структуру фонду вона Ну нам
кажуть що вона досить складна Для нас
вона абсолютно зрозуміла і ще раз я
очолюю
виконавчий орган нашого фонду
виконавчого дирекцію за нами закріплено
певні функції в основному це операційна
робота комунікаційна робота
нашим
наступним органом управління є Наукова
рада яку очолює голова наукової ради І
він є і головою Національного фонду
дослідження України і Окрім цього У нас
ще є один вищий орган - це наглядова
рада І що дуже важливо ці обидва органи
складаються виключно з науковців
практикуючих науковців Окрім цього що і
дуже важливою мінімізує
конфлікт інтересів вони Ніхто з них не
займає високих адміністративних посад
Ані в закладах вищої освіти Ані в
науково-дослідних установах Тобто це
насправді практикуюче науковці які мають
дуже високі наукометричні показники які
мають дуже широкий досвід
певні Науковій галузі Окрім цього вони
мають ще й дуже великий досвід участі в
різних грантових програмах тепер
трошечки про це така спрощена
спрощена така візуалізація це процесів
відбору проектів яка відбувається
насправді кожен конкурс
мінімально займає десь 5,5 місяців від
дня Оголошення До
заключення договорів з переможцями
нашими в першу чергу оголошується певний
конкурс умови конкурсу
вони створюються тобто дизайн цих умов
це превратива виключно наукової Ради
після цього заявки подаються через
електронну систему І взагалі ми
покладаємо досить досить такі і
покладали і покладаємо дуже Великі
сподівання саме на те що через те що
комунікація між наприклад експертами
членами комісії конкурсу між дирекцією
де в через електронну систему там
мінімізується оця
суб'єктивний такий Фактор і можливість
впливати якось суб'єктивно на всіх
учасників цього процесу далі перший етап
оцінювання - це оцінювання за
формальними ознаками знову ж таки тут ми
не дуже оригінальні скажемо так
більшість наших колег за кордоном має
такий етап оцінювання
після цього формується список можливих
експертів потім які підтверджують своє
або не підтверджують бажання провести
оцінку того чи іншого про
після цього відбувається оцінювання вже
кожного конкретного проекту формується
рейтинговий список
учасників конкурсу і відбувається
затвердження результатів конкурсу знову
ж таки на рівні наукової Ради після
цього підписується Договори і
розпочинається вже нова історія історія
реалізації цих проектів те що стосується
відкритості і прозорості це Якраз ті
принципи які є основними і були завжди
основними при створенні коли тільки
зароджувалася ідея створення
національного фонду дослідження України
насправді в будь-яких наших навіть
простих операційних процесах ми
намагаємось максимально бути відкритими
максимально прозорими дуже багато
комунікуємо знову ж таки якщо у вас
виникнуть якісь питання на останньому
слайді буде будуть контактні дані мої і
фонду ми залюбки відповімо на ваші
запитання
я вже сказала про те що для того щоб
бути об'єктивним
А ну насправді от по в промові
попереднього спікера піднялась дуже
серйозні проблеми стосовно культури
експертизи і я вам хочу сказати що ми
все-таки спостерігаємо за тим що ця
культура вона поступово все ж таки
підвищується в Україні і розуміння того
що іноді може існувати прихований
конфлікт інтересів між експертом та
наприклад науковим керівником проекту
який дуже важко навіть якихось відкритих
джерелах віднайти експерти самостійно
його декларують і відмовляються від
оцінки проекту що я в принципі дуже Я
вважаю позитивним моментом
що хотіла ще сказати що кожна заявку у
нас по кожному конкурсу оцінює
щонайменше три експерти і по
умовах певних конкурсів там є
обов'язкове залучення одного іноземного
експерта що насправді дуже важко тому що
іноземні експерти взагалі у нас від нас
ніякої
фінансової подяки не отримують
українські експерти отримують вона
наразі є мізерна в будь-якому разі вона
все ж таки є тому ми дуже вдячні
іноземним колегам які долучаються до
експертизи наших проектів ви знаєте в
своїх супровідних листах Вони дуже часто
пишуть що вони роблять це заради того
щоб ось така незалежна нова інституція в
Україні існувала щоб вона надавала шанси
найкращим науковим ідеям найкращим
науковим проектом як це робиться в
розвинених країнах дуже швидко про
бюджети наших е-е конкурсів нам вже за
них не соромно я мушу сказати Бо держава
насправді виділяє досить досить велике
за об’ємами кошти це виключно для
грантової підтримки ви бачите це два
конкурси які було оголошено Минулого
року їхній бюджет Ви також бачите так
тобто він вже ну
Ми б хотіли однозначно щоб ми могли
оперувати більшими бюджетами але це
однозначно дуже великий крок вперед
ця статистика стосується наданих
експертиз кількості
переможців за конкурсу наприклад
підтримка досліджень провідних та
молодих учених та також розподіл по
галузям наукового знання серед
переможців
цей слайд Мені він дуже завжди
подобається тому що він просто красивий
але окрім того що він красивий він
містить собі оцю дуже важливу інформацію
стосовно тих представників іноземних
держав які
згодились надати експертну оцінку по
проектам які подані на конкурси
національного фонду дослідження України
бачите от по цьому конкретному конкурсу
це Велика Британія це Сполучені Штати
Америки
Німеччина Польща як завжди нас дуже
виручає але є країни які надали по
словами експертів в будь-якому разі наша
вдячність їм точно така ж як і іншим
країнам це конкурс науки для безпеки
людини та суспільства Також ви бачите да
тобто вражаючи цифри цих проведених
експертиз і кількість переможців досить
велика Ну я вам хочу сказати що у нас і
секс Фрейд по різних конкурсах він
різний скажемо так я більш такі
конкурентні конкурси є менш конкурентні
ну в будь-якому разі ви бачите що вже
більше до 100 проектів за 2000 20-й рік
2021 вони продовжують вже профінансована
фондом і Цього року я маю щастя вам
сказати що цього року фонд оголосив вже
три конкурси
Перший з них з бюджетом приблизно 5 млн
євро Він стосується
знову ж таки безпекових питань і ще два
конкурси тут ми розвели
напрями один із них - це природничо-те
науки та математика і інший - це соціум
гуманітарні науки це Скажімо так для в
нашому випадку це певний експеримент
подивимось яким чином він спрацює це мої
контактні дані дуже вам дякую за увагу і
ще раз дуже дякую за запрошення пані
Ольга дуже дякуємо за ваше презентацію І
дуже сподіваємось те що наші учасники
візьмуть на озброєння долучаться
отримати для себе ще більше можливостей
та перспектив Ну що ж ми вже сьогодні
говорили про певні потреби активації
взаємодії між бізнесом та наукою які
безумовно є актуальними адже наука може
принести багато для бізнесу так само
бізнес може профінансувати науку і ця
колаборація може стати дуже успішною
дуже змістовною про подібні інструменти
Ми продовжимо говорити у наші наступні
панельні дискусії Ну і власне наступне
наша презентація буде присвячена тому
така власне яким чином посилити
кооперацію між бізнесом у пошуку
комерційних партнерів адже ця проблема
яку потрібно вирішувати і допомагає нам
у цьому Європейському мережа підприємств
В Україні про роботу цієї мережі нам
детальніше розкаже голова консорбціями
Європи
Enterprise Network Ukraine пані Олена
Фесенко пані Олена будь ласка вам слово
під ваші оплески
Доброго дня шановні колеги Хочу
поділитися з вами інформацією про дуже
дієвий європейський інструмент який
наразі діє вже в Україні понад три роки
у цьому році відбувається трансформація
і мережа
Enterprise yourp Network зараз більш
спрямована на інновації на підтримку
розвитку інновацій і налагодження
контактів вмієш науковою інноваційною та
бізнес-сферами у світі зокрема в Україні
Також я Мене звати Фесенко Олена Я
представляю
Enterprise your Network це консорціум
який діє в Україні в рамках програми
косми зараз програма космою
трансформується в синглмаркет Program і
дуже
передбачається
налагодження дуже скажем тісних
контактів з European innova зараз іде
якраз переформатування усіх програм
інноваційних і крім того що Україна
успішно підписала і я так розумію
Сподіваюся скоро ратифікує програму
горизонт в Україні зараз йде
переговорний процес також по програмі
Single Market Program це дві найбільші
програми які діють в Європі якщо
горизонт Юра це більш така програма яка
націлена на підтримку науки інновацій то
синголмаркет Program - це програма яка
більше
націлена на інновації і на підтримку
розвитку міжнародної співпраці в розрізі
стартапівспінофів малого середнього
підприємництва
що таке
Enterprise yourp Network Enterprise Up
Network - це міжнародна площадка яка діє
більше 55 країнах світу насправді Це
дуже-дуже сильний і потужний
інструмент для комунікації і для
співпраці тобто фактично цей інструмент
можна розглядати як міжнародного
корпорацію яка діє з 65 країнах світу в
тому числі в Україні для імплементації
цієї програми в Україні був створений в
2017 році консорцю Enterprise your
Network який я як координатор очолюю до
нашого консор в цьому входять
організації такі як від Національної
академії наук Інститут фізики нан
україни
українська
торгово-промислова палата Міністерство
закордонних справ Міністерство Економіки
України
університет Шевченка нова корпорація і
офіс з розвитку підприємництва та
експорту
які основні інструменти є в ентерпрайсі
рептету
в нас є величезна База яка оновлюється
на щоденній основі це база даних
створена європейською комісією і
фактично тільки партнери інтерпрей
зірнетвок мають до неї доступ у цій базі
на щоденній основі появляються
пропозиції про співпрацю в різних
куточках світу Тобто всі інтерпресії
діють в 65 країнах світу
подають інформацію своїх національних
регіональних рівнів про
пошуку партнерів інноваторів інвесторів
і коли ви дивитесь цю базу ви можете
почерпнути інформацію про міжнародного
кооперацію Тобто ви можете найти
партнера інвестора технологічного
партнера бізнес-партнера наукового
партнера тобто насправді дуже скажемо
потужна платформа де ви можете
почерпнути інформацію це один напрямок
другий напрямок якщо ви розробник і
маєте розробку і ви хочете знайти
інвестора Чи ви хочете зробимо так
просунути свою інноваційну ідею Яка ще
не є інновацією а є на етапі ну
лабораторного зразка
тобто не ідеї а вже на рівні там
в шостому-сьомому технологічному
розвитку то ви можете також скористатися
нашою платформою і ми заповнюємо такі
відповідні профілі англійською мовою
розміщаємо і Фактично це можна
розглядати як промоція вашої технології
на міжнародному рівні тобто вдумайтеся
про вашу технологію зразу дізнається
більше чим 65 країн світу і таким чином
незворотній зв'язок і якщо хтось
зацікавився ми потім передаємо контакти
вам і ви вже
співпрацюєте напряму тобто Enterprise
your Network це не посередник це
механізм налагодження контактів а дальше
в переговорні процеси ми вже не входимо
наше завдання звести науковців бізнес
технологічні сфери для продовження
співпраці тут на крім бази даних крім
величезного календару календарю івентів
ну щорічно там проходить до 10 тисяч
різних заходів
які спрямовані інформаційні дні
конференції компанії Мішин брокери чи
венти воркшопи вебінари вони є в
вільному доступі переважно
99% вони є безкоштовні ви можете
переглянути обрати і взяти участь в них
тобто в наші інструменти це
налагодження міжнародного партнерства це
консультативна допомога і
підтримка розвитку інновацій які
напрямки
enterprice виробник має 17 тематичних
груп які є дуже широкі це фактично від
космосу
скажімо до нанотехнологій і від Агро до
ІТ тобто ну досить дуже широкі напрямки
співпраці тематичні
нас також є такі інструмент як підтримка
інноваційного маркетингу
він реалізується європейською академією
всі партнери всі хто входить консорціум
Мають доступ мають спеціальні паролі і
ми використовуючи цю систему
така розроблена алгоритм аналізу ми
можемо проводити аналіз стартапу з
пінофів малих середніх підприємств з
точки зору Наскільки в них в системі
створені відділи напрямки залучення
інновацій тому що ви знаєте що ну
проблематично
скажемо
імплементувати інноваційну ідею на ринок
і перетворити її інновації тому що це
досить ризиковий бізнес з однієї сторони
це ризиковий бізнес другий сторони це
дуже
прибутковий бізнес який дає досить
багато Вигоди і для того щоб компанії
стартапи спінофи могли правильно
побудувати свою стратегію виходу на
ринку то використовуючи це інноваційний
під принцип і підхід який розроблений
нами ми можемо через платформу
отримуючи інформацію ваші статистичні
дані ваші фінансові дані тобто або
компанії якщо стартап то там наприклад
технологічні дані ми проводимо такі
аналіз платформи реалізує і ми видаємо
графіки сертифікати і скажімо порівняння
з найкращими з найгіршими
підприємствами в цій сфері тобто ви
можете зразу зорієнтуватися і порівняти
свої дані
сегментом в якому ви працюєте з
найкращими із компаніями Які наприклад
нижче по рівні розвитку це дозволяє
правильно побудувати стратегії
ми на зараз Працюємо як в інноваційному
менеджменту Digital innovation
менеджмент - це два основних напрямки
які ми підтримуємо розвиваємо
Крім того ми намагаємося створили для
того щоб інформаційну дуже швидко
доносити інформацію і охоплювати широку
аудиторію ми випускаємо щотижневу це в
нас дайджест і щомісячно дайджест в
якому ми збираємо інформацію про всі
пріоритетні програми які відкриті коли
переважно ми спрямовані на міжнародні
коли тобто не на національне на
міжнародні
наводимо інформацію по підтримці Які
ресурси ви можете використовувати Також
ми опубліковуємо
запити на міжнародну кооперацію ви
можете скористатися там є відкриті
контакти і найти чи партнера для подачі
проектів чи скажемо бізнес про партнера
чи технологічного партнера насправді
інструмент дуже широкого спрямування
Крім того ми літом наприклад зробили
цілу серію тренінг модулів дуже різного
напрямку Також ми організовували влітку
онлайн
школу і є в школу було відібрано 30
підприємств які систематично протягом
трьох місяців проходили онлайн навчання
в нас за цих три роки вже зібралась
досить така обширна структура як
партнерів на національному так і на
регіональному і на локальному рівні вона
вже дуже багато є історій успіху для
промоції наших історій успіху ми робимо
відео які зараз можна переглянути на
сайті нам приємно що наші відео також є
і розміщення на сайті Європейської
комісії
це основні напрямки діяльності крім того
що в нас є інноваційний бізнес
технологічний напрямок підтримки в нас
також є платформа
ipr тобто для отримання інформації по
підтримці інтелектуальної
власності в різних країнах світу також є
база для сертифікації можна отримати
інформацію як зробити сертифікацію в тій
чи іншій країні світу
тут ви можете побачити деякі наші А чи
моменти тобто наші досягнення
ви бачите що от якщо подивитися
по цьому чи користується попитом наша
платформа так дуже користується попитом
порядку 6000 Експресу Pinterest Тобто це
на ті профілі які вже зроблені на
технологічні або бізнес-профілі які
розміщені в системі прийшли запити про
співпрацю тобто досить активно
українські і Бізнес і Новатори
використовують цю платформу
всі зазначити що наш консорціум є
наймолодший консорціум в Enterprise
сиропнетвок яка діє вже фактично в
Європі 15 років в нас працює ця мережа
тільки три роки але незважаючи на те ну
по кількості профілів які ми розміщаємо
в системі от ви можете побачити що
Україна на п'ятому місці тобто насправді
ну ми досить швидко набрали і активно
активний такий темп і ми розвиваємося
вчимося Кожен рік
це кількість заходів ви бачите Кожен рік
вони також зростають в цьому році в
Німеччині був конкурс І вот Мені приємно
що наш концерт ми подавалися як консорці
це між
65-ма країнами світу кожен консорці міг
подавати свою безпрактіс от мені приємно
що наш концерт
був обраний переможцем Я їздила на
вручення
голосування було онлайн тобто ми
насправді тут вийшли були в фінал а в
самому в Німеччині в нас була така
презентація і онлайн-голосування де
голосувало більше 6000 учасників І от
нас вибрали переможцем
На цьому я в принципі вже підходжу до
завершення але хочу завжди кажуть
запам'ятовується останні слайд що
підсумувати бо я багато надала різної
інформації різнопланової щоб підсумувати
яких все ж таки інструменти є і якими
інструментами можуть скористатися як
інноватори розробники так і представники
стартапівспінафів та і та середнього і
малого бізнесу в Україні це доступ до
бази даних як бізнес так технологічних
пропозицій яка фактично поширюється в 60
країнах світу Ну це фактично реклама
вашої розробки на міжнародному рівні
потім доступ до календарів подій і ви
можете безпосередньо взяти участь в
різних заходах які відбуваються в різних
куточках світу в нас є спеціальна
онлайн-платформа
не обов'язково кудись їхати ви
реєструєтеся і безкоштовно можете
комунікувати
заповнюючи свій профіль
з інноваторами
інвесторами-технологами в різних
куточках світу інноваційний менеджмент я
зупинялася розповідала що ми можемо
зробити такий інноваційний аналіз вашого
підприємства або компанії потім Ви також
можете зайти на підписатися на розсилку
і будете так як база оновлюється щодня
там тричі на день ви будеш будете
отримувати розсилку
навчання модулі також на різну тему є
навчальні модулі так як тут аудиторія
більш наукового спрямування є навчання
модуля як писати гранти як підготовити
пропозицію як знайти партнера як
побудувати консорцію Які наприклад є
також навчальні модулі по пріоритетних
напрямках зараз горизонт юрок і так
дальше
тут корисна інформація лінки ви можете
Зробити скан
Дякую за вашу увагу
Олена Фесенко дуже дякуємо за
презентацію голова концерну Enterprise
your Network Ukraine Хоча і кажете що
запам'ятовується останні слайд але
виходячи з кількості ту інформацію без
ціни Я впевнений Ти що кожне з наших
учасників для себе дуже багато візьме з
вашого презентації Дякую Дуже за безліч
інсайтів і величезну кількість корисної
інформації якою просто треба брати і
користуватись Дякуємо і рухаємось далі
Отож я впевнений Ти що багато із вас
проходило вже через програму горизонт
горизонт 2020 і Якщо говорити про цю
програму і попередні досвід то я
впевнений те що наша наступна
презентація наступна розповідь буде дуже
актуальна для тих учасників які уже
доторкнулися до цієї програми Ну і
власне безумовно для тих учасників які
хочуть долучитися до нових програм Отож
зараз із величезною радістю Запрошуємо
до наступної доповіді державного
експертку іспитані розвитку інновацій
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Оксану крукевича тож пані Оксана будь
ласка вам слово і наші оплески
Дякую Вітаю всіх учасників Horizon your
Launch Day і з радістю хочу вам
повідомити що Міністерство освіти і
науки 11 листопада презентувало
анонс по конкурсному відбору який
фінансується за рахунок
європейської допомоги яка була надана
надана в рамках програми горизонт-220 і
зараз я детальніше розкажу про умови про
порядок проведення про критерії
оцінювання тобто всю корисну інформацію
яка потрібна для того щоб подаватись на
цей конкурс І саме головне що прийом
заявок триває до 20 грудня
Отже конкурс проводиться відповідно до
положення яке затверджене постановою
Кабінету Міністрів номер 971 А також про
положення про конкурсну комісію де ви
можете ознайомитися детально з етапами
проведення експертизи заявок у нас у нас
трирівнева оцінюються радою відповідно
секціями а також експертами
щодо фінансування це саме актуальне
запитання які задають всі учасники тому
що наразі Міністерство проводить активну
консультаційну підтримку для учасників
відповідаємо на всі запитання актуальні
щодо заповнення заявок і найбільше
питань в принципі йде пофінансуванню
зараз на слайді ви можете побачити
розбивку відсотках по всіх напрямках які
фінансуються в межах цього конкурсу І
загальний бюджет цього конкурсного
відбору 319 млн грн це бюджет
запланований для надання фінансування з
22-го року тому він буде актуальний
фінансування розпочинатиметься у 22-му
році
також для зручності ми підготували
прогнозовану верхню межу фінансування за
кожним напрямом конкурсного відбору
відповідно для наукових робіт наукових
проектів така межа є два мільйони 200
тисяч для інфраструктурних проектів це
найбільші за обсягом фінансування
проекти в межах цього конкурсу до 22
мільйонів гривень також для підтримки
інноваційної діяльності закладів вищої
освіти на наукових установ ми виділяємо
мільйон гривень і там можна мільйон
гривень 100 тисяч і також для проектів
які спрямовані на проведення
техніко-економічного обґрунтування 245
тисяч гривень на один проект зараз ще
також повідомлю про терміни відповідно
строк виконання заявок для наукових
робіт науково-технічних проектів до 24
місяців тобто двох до двох років
Звичайно це можуть бути заявки і на рік
і можуть бути на півторах дивлячись того
як ви сформуєте етапи проведення свого
дослідження і лише для науково-технічних
проектів для
техніко-економічного обґрунтування
встановлено 12 місяців а тому що це
проекти які спрямовані лише на
проведення фінансового економічного
розрахунків для вашого проекту
зараз детальніше розкажу про критерії це
також самоважливо що буде оцінюватись І
що впливає на загалом рейтинг який ви
сформований за результатами конкурсного
відбору для наукових робіт головними
критеріями є це якість і значущість
вашої наукової роботи відповідно
спроможність колективу а також наявного
матеріально-технічна база А але можна
писати з обґрунтуванням цього обладнання
яке ви можете купити в межах проекту
також надзвичайно важливим критерієм для
по всіх напрямках є наявність досвіду
участі в програмі горизонт-220 тобто цей
конкурс є підтримка тих активних
учасників від України які брали участь у
програмі горизонт 2020 а також вона
спрямована на стимулювання подальшої
участі українських команд у програмі
горизонт Європа тому тематичні напрями з
якими ви зможете ознайомитись на сайті
Moon вони відповідають напрямом уже
програми горизонт Європа а щодо
критеріїв науково-технічних концертів то
основна відмінність від наукових робіт є
їх практичне спрямування Тобто потрібно
обгрунтувати соціально-економічний вплив
для України цього проекту і що важливо
навколо технічні проекти у нас
передбачають співфінансування тобто якщо
заявку подає університет або наукову
установа співфінансування встановлюється
60% дає Міністерство 40% залучає
самостійно університет і якщо подається
малий або середній бізнес то фіспе
фінансування на рівні 50 на 50 і це
також унікальність цього конкурсу в тому
що учасниками можуть бути представники
середнього та малого бізнесу
наступний напрямок - це проекти
спрямовані на підтримку інноваційної
діяльності закладів вищої освіти
наукових установ тут потрібно показати
вже наявну інноваційну інфраструктуру
обґрунтувати необхідність залучення до
такого фінансування і створення нової
інфраструктури або її до наповнення
розширення і розвитку також передбачає
злучення співфінансування та обов'язкове
залучення представників бізнесу до
виконання цього виду проектів наступний
проект - це техніко-економічне
обґрунтування тут найважливіше що
учасниками за цим проектом можуть бути
лише ті команди які отримали силу
фекселенс Тобто Це найвища оцінка в
рамках програми горизонт 2020 і ці
проекти не отримали лише фінансування в
рамках горизонту 2020 тому ми їх зараз
дофінансовуємо і даємо фінансування на
проведення техніко-економічного
обґрунтування щоб ці проекти могли бути
далі впровадженні в Україні
І абсолютно теж новий напрямок це
інфраструктурні проекти з найбільшим
обсягом фінансування тут важливо що
учасниками можуть бути центри
колективного користування тобто
університети про яких є такі центри і
наукові установи які мають такі центри
можуть бути учасниками за цим напрямом
тут не вимагається
досвід участі в програмі горизонт-220
але тут вимагається обґрунтування А що
за допомогою обладнання яке буде
закуплено в межах цього проекту команди
зможуть брати активну участь у програмі
горизонт Європа а також залучати широке
коло наукових груп до роботи на цьому
обладнанні
також щодо самої подачі заявки у нас є 5
типів відповідно заявок які розміщені і
на сайті мон і відповідно затверджені
постановою Тобто їх можна прямо з
постановою викачати і які відрізняються
тим що за кожним пунктом є детально про
Інформація що саме потрібно подавати От
і це зручно і зручно те що ви можете
одразу скачати експертні висновки в яких
детально прописано який критерій Як
оцінюється як розвивається на під
критерії є ранжування балів від одного
до п'яти і відповідний коефіцієнт тобто
на етапі подачі в принципі ви вже
зможете вирахувати свій бали який набере
ваші заявка
оцінюється трьома експертами експертів
ми набирали у вересні місяці шляхом
звернень від
університетів наукових установа також
шляхом заповнення науковців які бажали
бути експертами відповідали критеріям
заявці яка розміщена була на сайті
щодо таймлайну І взагалі процедури
проведення до 20 грудня ми чекаємо на
заявки далі відбувається відбір заявок
за формальними ознаками тобто формальне
оцінювання воно буде тривати протягом
січня місяця далі розподіл між
експертами експерти у лютому місяці
оцінюватимуть роботи далі збираються
секції Це вже другий рівень оцінки цих
проектів які формують саме пропозиції
для ради і формують пропозицію щодо
надання фінансування тобто якщо
виникатимуть питання щодо заявленого
бюджету можуть викликатися учасники на
засідання і проговорюватись моменти
тобто якщо наприклад в бюджет буде
більше заявлений і учасник його гарно
аргументує то це також може бути
прийнятно і далі засідає Рада яка
затверджує уже остаточне рішення і воно
вводиться в дію наказу мон Після
оголошення результатів проводиться
укладення договорів в якому буде описано
етапи детальні виконання звітування і
процес виконання самого роботи або
проекту
і для того щоб знайти було зручно
експертів
партнерів для подачі заявок
співоконавців Міністерство освіти і
науки уже запустило платформу наука і
Бізнес яка зараз працює у режимі
дослідної експлуатації але функціонал
весь працює Тому ви можете уже шукати
партнерів як серед науковців так само я
так само як і серед підприємців для того
щоб сформувати спільну заявку
Сподіваємось що цей сервіс також буде
дуже корисним для наших науковців та
інноваторів в тому числі Дякую за увагу
Ну що ж дуже дякуємо Оксана крукевич
експерт з питань розвитку інновацій
Міністерство освіти і науки України
Дякуємо за презентацію одної звісно
готуємось долучатись до усіх ініціатив
які були презентовані під час її
доповіді рухаємось далі Отож друзі
багато ініціатив ущільно силу яких є
інновації Ну і власне глобальне завдання
наше постає у тому аби реалізувати
протягом наступних десятиліть дуже
багато крутих інноваційних проектів
багато ініціатив розумних та
наполегливих підприємців науковців і
Новаторів Вони працюють завдяки щоденні
клопідкій праці для того аби втілити ці
всі ініціативи у реальність і в цьому
без сумнівів допомагає Український фонд
стартапів Державний фонд що сприяє
розвитку та появі технологічних
стартапів на різних етапах їх розвитку
саме завдяки такій синергії саме завдяки
такій підтримці народжується круті ідеї
втілюються в життя Ну і власне рухаються
у напрямку того аби проекти були
презентовані світу Україні і аби дійсно
ми побачили крутих і Новаторів які
походять родом із України у кремні від
долині в Україні у світі над теренах
міжнародних для того аби більш
детальніше розказати про перспективи
Українські міжнародні про те як
відбувається акселерація про те як
відбувається підтримка цих проектів і з
радістю про підтримку реального бізнесу
запрошую розказати менеджерку із
compliance пані Марію краснощок Отож
будь ласка пані Марія під наші Оплески
Запрошуємо вас на сину і вам слово
Дякуємо що долучили сьогодні
дякую Я радий усіх вітати від імені
українського фонду стартапів Мене звати
Марія красничук Я займаюсь
complianceусом в українському фонді
стартапі і одразу ж переходячи до теми
хто ми ми є державним фондом ми
фінансуємо ми спеціалізуємось на
підтримці стартапів на ранніх стадіях
розвитку а саме присів та Сіт етапи і
наше фінансування воно є безповоротним
Тобто ми не беремо еквіді ці кошти вони
не відшкодовуються І хто ж наша
аудиторія Отже ми спеціалізуємось на
підтримці проектів які працюють як на
українському ринку так і на міжнародних
Тобто ми підтримуємо і тих Новаторів які
наразі працюють за кордоном але готові
повертатись до України та репрезентувати
свої продукти на українських ринках на
сьогоднішній день ми на порталі вже
маємо заявки від громадян інших країн
головною умовою для подачі має бути саме
зареєстрована в установленому законом
порядку юридична особа або фізична
особа-підприємець ой
секундочку і щодо команди
операційна діяльність фонду забезпечує
внутрішня команда яку очолює директор
фонду Карташов Павло оцінювання заявок
відбувається експертами фонду
незалежними експертами на сьогоднішній
день фонд співпрацює більше ніж з 100
експертами з різних галузей і з числа
експертів 44 особи входять до такого
органу як конкурсна комісія конкурсна
комісія здійснює оцінювання заявок вже
на етапі пітчингу і керівні головним
органом українського фонду стартапів є
наглядова рада наглядова рада приймає
рішення щодо операційної діяльності
фонду так і приймає рішення щодо
фінансування стартапів
ось ви можете побачити що донаглядової
ради входять лідери української
стартапки системи
зі значним досвідом у ведення
міжнародного бізнесу та у Вечірньому
інвестуванні
і
стратегія українського фонду
стартапів розроблена за підтримки
світового банку і тут ви можете побачити
які саме галузі та які саме підтримку
здійснюватиме фонд у найближчі 5 років Я
гадаю що всім цікаво перейти вже від
теорії до практики Отже ви можете
побачити які саме
сфери фінансує фонд Як ви бачите ми
охоплюємо фактично Усі сфери у яких
ведеться інноваційний стартерська
діяльність і якими саме методами
здійснюється підтримка підтримка
здійснюється за надавання надання
грантів у розмірі 25 або 50 тисяч
доларів для присів та осіб етапу
відповідно також здійснюється підтримка
через фінансування акселераційних
програм здійснюється підтримка через
надання інноваційних ваучерів у розмірі
до 10 тисяч доларів і звичайно ж
дуже-дуже багато ще інших можливостей
які ми відкриваємо та провадимо для
стартапів на ранніх стадіях розвитку
зараз давайте більш детально щодо кожної
окремої програми як можливо отримати
фінансування у загальному розмірі до 95
тисяч доларів це загальна кількість яку
загальна кількість коштів які можна
залучити від фонду за різними програмами
Отже
кваліфікаційні критерії для гранту як я
вже повторююсь
Вибачте як я вже повторюся це має бути
зареєстроване в установленому законом
України порядку юридична особа або
фізична особа-підприємці Вона має бути
спрямована на досягнення соціального
ефекту або
шляхом випуску нових продуктів або
вдосконалювання технологій продуктів
організаційних пропозицій технічних
технічних рішень та іншого Вона має мати
масштабовану бізнес-модель
в юридична особа тобто стартап не має
отримувати прибутку за останній рік
більше ніж як на 300 тисяч доларів
сукупно і розмір залучених інвестицій
немає також перевищувати більше 300
тисяч доларів станом на дату подачі
заявки Як же це працює Перший етап - це
знайомство з нашим порталом Ви маєте
зайти на сторінку фонду заповнити свою
заявку після того як ви заповнили заявку
та надіслали її Загалом ми прораховували
якщо сісти від початку і до кінця не
відходять заповнити заявки це займає
приблизно 5 годин однак звичайно ж ви
можете зберегти свою інформацію та
повернутись до заповнювання у будь-який
зручний вам час після заповнення заявки
та надіслання її на вона оцінюється
внутрішньо на критерії формальних
критерії щодо заявки
після того як заявка була оцінювана на
щодо формальних критеріїв вона
надсилається на оцінювання експертів
після того як
стартап було оцінено для проходження на
пресі етапі це має стартап має бути
оцінено більше ніж на 12 балів для
проходження на осі етапі більше ніж як
на 15 балів якщо все успішно тоді
стартапи рекомендується на піч на пічі
так само
презентує свою ідею перед конкурсною
комісією конкурсна комісія здійснює
оцінювання пітчу за окремими категоріями
для стартапу на Сіт етапі та стартапи
просіти етапі - Це окремі категорії І
після того як стартап успішно пройшов
етап піччю приймається рішення про
застосування наглядової радою фонду
Після рішення наглядової ради фонду
стартап збирає необхідні матеріали
проходить комфлайн і звичайно ж отримує
фінансування та має змогу реалізовувати
кошти відповідно до вимог які ставляться
фондом Отже
щодо грантової програми я вас вже
ознайомила а тепер давайте перейдемо до
інших суміжних форматів підтримки які
здійснює фонд а саме акселераційна
програма за акселераційною програмою
стартап має можливість отримати
фінансування у розмірі до 10 тисяч
доларів для проходження акселераційних
програм у акредитованих
фондом
акселераторів Отже Як це працює перше -
це звичайно ж подача заявки через
веб-портал фонду оцінювання експертів у
випадку якщо стартап було рекомендовано
на проходження для проходження
акселераційної програми і експерти
рекомендували такий
наглядова рада так само приймає рішення
щодо фінансування даного стартапу і у
результаті стартап має можливість
реалізувати грант та отримати
навчання у акредитованих фондом
акселераторів яких Ви можете бачити
наразі на екрані
наступний формат підтримки - це
інноваційні ваучери інноваційні ваучери
бувають двох типів а саме промовачери та
призові ваучери промоучери виділяються
для того аби стартап міг поїхати на
міжнародні конференції міжнародні
виставки презентувати свій продукт на
міжнародній арені призові ваучери
видаються за
як результат участі стартапа та Перемоги
відповідно у партнерських заходах як
отримувати фінансування за цією
програмою перше знову ж таки потрібно
подавати заявку через веб-портал фонду
після того як заявку було подано
вона оцінюється на формальні вимоги
знову ж таки етап пітчингу після
оцінювання пітчингу знову ж таки рішення
наглядової ради фонду щодо фінансування
і які саме інноваційні ваучери вже було
видано ось
веб-саміт наразі вже пройшов приблизно
декілька тижнів тому і українські
стартапи мали змогу презентувати свою
продукти на міжнародній арені
конструктор
це у лас-вегасі знову ж таки 4 тисячі
доларів можливо було отримати для
поїздки та презентації своїх продуктів
на
цес у Атласа в Америці і наразі все ще
не проведено пічному Ви маєте можливість
подати свої заявки на експорт 2020
це також всесвітня виставка на якій
стартапи матимуть змогу презентувати
свій продукт перед світовими інвесторами
і розказати про
Україну та про свій продукт і ще одна
програма Фонду розвитку інновацій це
корпоративні анімації в
розрізі цієї програми фонд забезпечує
колаборацію стартапів та Великого
бізнесу корпорацій тобто корпорації
звертаються з якоюсь бізнес-біллю і
стартап знаходить
фонд знаходиться стартапи які можуть
допомогти вирішити цю біль бізнесу та
допомогти у їх діяльності і наразі ми
вже стоїмо на порозі нашого ювілею тобто
фонду виповнюється два роки з моменту
введення операційної діяльності і за два
роки було опрацьовано більше трьох тисяч
заявок більше 200 стартапів отримали
грантове фінансування більше 6 млн
доларів суку за усіма програмами вже
пішли до інноваційної екосистеми України
і за в цьому році фонд став найбільшим
ангельським інвестором в Україні і одним
з найбільших інвесторів у Південній
Європі і звичайно ж ми вже можемо
показати результати нашої діяльності на
слайді ви можете побачити компанії які
вже вийшли на міжнародний ринок вже
мають
певний певну компетенцію і роботи на
міжнародному ринку і роботи з фондом що
об'єднує всі ці стартапи - це те що саме
початкові раунди інвестиції вони
підіймали У фонді
ми інвестуємо в Україну заради того аби
наше майбутнє і майбутнє нашої
інноваційної екосистеми воно було як
неймого більш
привабливим і для іноземних інвесторів і
для України для молодого покоління тому
Ми сподіваємось що ви долучитесь до нас
будете свої заявки і ми будемо бачити і
вас на і вас ваші проекти на слайдах
наших стартапів Дякую за вам за увагу
Марія краснищак Український фонд тапів
дуже дякуємо І допоки презентація
тривала Я уже озброївся своїми мобільним
телефоном почав реєструватись для того
аби долучитись до унікальних можливостей
українського фонду стартапів мрія дуже
дякуємо Ну і принагідно хапаємо
можливості для того аби справді для себе
отримати максимум таких можливостей
відкриваються сьогодні дуже і дуже
багато і як на мене що може бути краще
ніж поспілкуватись про такі швидкості
познайомитись з одним із одним за
партнерити всі власне отримати ще більше
можливостей для нетворкінгу під час
короткого кавабрико ото Шановні колеги
10 хвилин кава Брейк через 10 хвилин ми
повертаємось для того аби поговорити про
можливості які відкрила програма
горизонт 2020 про історію успіху і аби
На конкретних реальних юскейсах
продемонструвати куди рухатись як
працювати як отримати для себе максимум
Отож через 10 хвилин чекаємо вас тут і
зараз у живому ефірі до зустрічі
[музика]
[оплески]
Ну що ж колеги усіх Запрошуємо ми
повертаємося усе найкраще тут і зараз це
програма горизонт Європа і ми готові
продовжувати наш Spring готові
продовжувати наш ефір Отож Доброго
вечора шановні колеги Дякуємо усім хто з
нами протягом усього дня Дякуємо всім
хто щойно до нас долучився будь-яка
опція будь-яка можливість - це величезна
перевага і ці інвестиція у власне
успішне професійне майбутнє у розвиток
власних проектів крутих ініціатив Отож
Друзі будь ласка долучайтесь усіх усіх
усіх і усіх Хто знаходиться зараз
офлайну ці залі і усіх хто до нас
долучився онлайн вітаємо та Запрошуємо
займати місця чи то у реальному залі чи
то віртуальному просторі для того аби
дізнатись дуже багато про нові
можливості які відкриваються перед нами
завдяки програмі горизонт Європа ото
Шановні колеги Запрошуємо Запрошуємо до
глядацької зали Запрошуємо долучатись до
трансляції якщо ваші колеги ще не тут то
У такому випадку
чекаємо 10 секундочок для того аби
власне розпочати наш ефір багато вже
звучало сьогодні протягом нашого ефіру
про багато можливостей уже дізналась але
зараз ми розкажемо про секрети успіху
про успішні юстиції які відбулися в
програмі горизонт 2020 і Я впевнений те
що саме вони можуть стати трігером
зможуть стати отою з подвижною точкою
для того аби податися і для того аби
випробувати на собі те що насправді це
потужна підтримка це потужна інвестиція
власний розвиток Ну що ж повертаємося
тож займаємо місця і горизонт 2020 Отож
український науково-технічний центр у
програмі горизонт 2020 сьогодні
представляє Микола лубів перший
заступник виконавчого директора
українські науково-технологічний центр
Отож давайте розпочинати нашу сесію яка
присвячена історію успіху саме у таких
стартапів які підходять із проекту
горизонт 20 20 стартапів проектів
інновацій ініціатив Отож із величезною
радістю Запрошуємо нашего спікера на
сину будь ласка Микола лубів вперше
заступник виконавчого диктора
український науково-технологічний центр
просимо під ваші оплески
[оплески]
Доброго вечора шановні колеги Мої
вітання усім присутнім щиро дякую за
запрошення та можливість взяти участь в
сьогоднішньому заході Мене звати Микола
лупів Я представляю український
науково-технологічний центр І сьогодні я
б хотів з вами поділитися нашим історією
успіху нашим досвідом в роботі
ранкової програми горизонт 2020 але
перед тим як розпочати Дозвольте коротко
зупинитися на історію
нашого центру оскільки часто
відбувається Так що коли до нас
звертаються науковці або інженери вперше
або перше про нас чують Вони думають що
це я якась виключно українська історія
що це виключно українська організація
насправді не зовсім так
оскільки
28 років тому
ініціативи України була підписана
Міжнародна угода про створення
міжнародної організації з відповідним
статусом України і ця угода була
підписана між
урядами на той час Швеції Сполучених
Штатів Америки Канади та України
пізніше 98-му році Швеція була замінена
Європейським Союзом відповідним
протоколом який був ратифікований нашим
парламентом
протягом
97-го 2004 років до цієї угоди
приєдналися країни гуам і це такі країни
як Грузія
Узбекистан
Азербайджан там Молдова і ці країни
отримали спеціальний статус статус
реципієнтів
Також на даний момент можемо сказати що
наша організація складається із 7
членів країн три сторони яких приймають
активну участь в управлінні центром вони
входять до складу адміністративної ради
Це
рада здійснює абсолютно контроль і
управління діяльності Центру до складу
цього цієї ради входить представники від
Сполучених Штатів Америки Європейської
комісії та власне від України відповідно
до постанови Кабінету Міністрів
Міністерство освіти і науки є тим
видомством який здійснює надає сприяння
та координацію з боку України нашої
нашої організації
[музика]
нещодавно буквально До речі 30 листопада
відбулося засідання 53 засідання нашої
адміністративної ради можу вам сказати
що як результат цього засідання Рада
прийняла до фінансування
проекту на загальну суму більше ніж 24
млн доларів це за 2021 рік і Для нас це
цей рік був дуже успішний оскільки
загалом на середній проектний портфель у
нас складає приблизно 13-14 млн за рік
на жаль 2020 рік було дуже складним для
нас Я думаю як і для багатьох із вас це
був рік трансформацію тому ми
мобілізувалися і показали найкращий
результат вже в 21-му в цьому році якщо
ми говоримо про деякі цифри то ви можете
побачити що протягом 28 років нашої
діяльності ми активно спів більше ніж
тисячу наукових інституцій як і України
гуам більше 18 тисяч вчених отримали
безпосереднє гранти
в тому числі
10 тисяч цих 18 це були науковці
оборонці ми їх називаємо формулу це люди
які в свій час
викладала свої знання на покращення
обороноздатності нашої держави в
радянський час і
за 28 років наш центр успішно реалізував
близько 2000
науково-технологічних проектів
загальною сумою більше ніж 350 мільйонів
доларів США чи багато це чимало можна
по-різному казати Якщо порівняти з
бюджетом програми органайзен Європа це
не так багато але якщо ми
візьмемо цю цифру і представимо що ця
сума пішла безпосередньо на оплату
учасникам проекту науковцям тоді це
набирає певний певного сенсу А у нас
спочатку
підписання угоди про створення центру
центр масової завдання і місії
перша місія яку ми мала на той час
далеких 90-х роках це
забезпечення не розповсюдження
спеціальних технологій та спеціальних
знань які могли бути використані для
виробництва зброї масового враження
ядерної хімічної біологічної основної
основна мета і функція яка залишається
актуальною і на даний момент це все ж
таки підтримка підтримка вітчизняних
науковців в їхніх
їхніх інноваційних проектах їхніх мирних
ідеях ця ідея ця місія залишається
актуальною і до сьогодні але Світ
змінюється і час від часу наше місце є
обновлялося доповнювалися Ми
спостерігали що відкриваються різні
програми сума ранкова програма була
разом 2020 і ми певний час вирішили
долучитися і долучити наш механізм для
підтримки надання підтримки нашим
науковим і фактично з 2017 року офіційно
переговорів з європейською комісією ми
офіційно пройшли успішного статус
спеціального партнера програми 2020
отримали персональний ідентифікаційний
код судалу нам змогу
активно Приймати участь в горизонті 2020
не тільки як третя сторона для
українських
учасників а власне як і координатор
консорціума Це також важливо тому що
якщо ви знаєте
і візьмете будь-який консорці у
Європейський вони як правило не мають
приватну
структурутингова компанія яка здійснює
для них надає послуги фінансової
адміністративні та виконує роль
координатора і як правило Вони беруть За
це 10-15% від суми проекту Ми цю роль
для українських учасників виконуємо
безкоштовно
якщо перейти до цифр то за
[музика]
рамках програми разом 2020 ми брали
участь в 43-х проєктах на загальну суму
більше ніж 14 мільйонів євро
ми пишаємося цією кількістю чи багато це
чимало якщо взяти
загальну статистику по Україні то Нам
дуже приємно що ця Цей номер не є такий
малий як як ми можемо подумати також ви
можете бачити невеликий перелік тих
європейських компаній та університетів
які
певний час зверталися до нас з проханням
долучитися до їхніх до їхніх пропозицій
до їхніх консорців і надати наші
механізми і послуги в рамках в рамках
імплементації їхніх проектів
на даний момент
на даний момент у нас залишилося на
всього три активних проекта де ми
виконуємо роль координатора всі ці три
проекти були виграні і профінансовані в
найбільший європейський програмі частини
або Clean Sky 2
2017 році коли Україна
за ініціативи Міністерства освіти і
науки прийняла офіційну участь в цій
програмі так співпало що Власне цей
самий рік ми отримали валідацію успішну
і завдяки сильній команді на той час
пам'ятаю Харківський авіаційний
університет імені Жуковського ми
приєдналися до
заявки до пропозиції і виграли перший на
той час проект в рамках цієї програми
для України проект який були
розрахований на треніровки і мало
завершитися але у зв'язку з
пандемію Європейської комісії дозволена
нам продовжити його проект загальною
сумою 1.7 мільйонів євро і ця сума іде
повністю для всіх учасників концернції
ми є українськими організаціями такими
як державне підприємство
дівчинка прогрес такими як Харківський
авіаційний університет імені Жуковського
та компанія Мотор Січ
побачивши такий успіх ми приєдналися до
інших пропозицій і як результат
виграли ще додатково два проекти де
Також ми виконуємо роль координатора
загальну суму проєкт 1 млн євро і
проекти є вал який виконується спільно з
приватної компанії з Латвії але
термінали це на 500 тисяч євро тобто на
даний момент у нас ще залишилося три
реактивних проекта загальної суми більше
ніж 3 млн євро і якщо подивитися звіт
про діяльність програми cleansky 2 який
нещодавно був опублікований то загалом
Україна виграла чотири проекти і нам
дуже приємно що Три із них ми маємо
нагоду координувати тому і ми
сподіваємося що наступні програмі
cleansky яка яка є найбільшою
науково-дослідницькою організацією
програмою Європейського союзу в галузі
авіації і мета якої є зменшення викидів
І зменшення шумів і так далі тому
подібне Ми сподіваємося що наступні
програмі у нас буде ще кращий показник і
на останній слайд Я б хотів звернути
увагу чому цікаво нашим
трошки учасникам використовувати
механізм
для
участі в програмі gorizon 2020 і
Сподіваюсь на наступні програмі
в першу чергу Наша історія і наш досвід
28-літній показує що ми можемо надавати
якісні послуги і наші
стандарти ведення проектів абсолютно
відповідають вимогам Європейської
комісії яка здійснює сонячний аудит
нашої діяльності
а також важливий момент відповідно до
угоди про створення нашого центру уряд
України гарантує звільнення від
будь-яких податків в рамках ведення
науково-технологічних управлінь всі
матеріали обладнання які можуть
імпортуватися чи експортувати це в
рамках проекту звільняються будь-яких
зборів та акцизів і знову ж таки скажу
що наші послуги в якості координатора є
абсолютно безкоштовними для українських
наукових організацій що дає в сумі
абсолютно економію абсолютно економії
бюджету всього проекту є вигідно не
тільки для українських учасників але для
загалом всіх учасників концерн цього
тому
я сподіваюся
майбутній програмі наші показники як
мінімум подводяться я вам дякую за увагу
Ну що ж Дякуємо вам Дякуємо і
можливостями користуємося історію успіху
надихаємось Дуже дякуємо і рухаємось
далі величезне прохання до усіх спікерів
дуже потужний спринт 10 хвилиночок будь
ласка слідкуємо за таймігом аби ми були
у тому таймлайні які у нас зазначено в
програмі Ну що ж рухаємось до наступної
презентації наступний проект - це Feed
for nmp можливості так підтримка
українських учасників конкурсів програми
горизонт Європа Запрошуємо до слова
Сергій Лев будь ласка старше науковий
співробітника дедат фізико-математичних
наук Національна академія наук України
будь ласка під наші оплески
Дякую за представлення
Значить так само Головне що я захотів
звернути увагу що Не дивлячись на те що
наш проект
є проектом горизонт 2020 основні цілі і
завдання його направлені саме на участь
наших Ну не тільки наших наша
організація за наші за українські
установи відповідає за їх підтримку для
участі в проектах горизонт Європа
концерт
складається з 10 учасників
основне представництво 9-10 - це країни
Європейського Союзу із асоційованих
країн представлена тільки Україна
представлена національна академію наук
України
завдання нашого проекту це підвищити
участь талановитих новачків з слабо
представлених регіонів в програмах і
проектах
горизонт Європа за наступними напрямами
нанотехнології сучасні матеріали і
виробництво та виробничі процеси що
мається на увазі під талановиті новачки
підлановитими новачками підроздівається
організації які або вже представляли
свої проекти в програмі горизонт 2020
отримали якусь оцінку але не були
успішні не отримували фінансування також
сюди входять
організації які показали зацікавленість
в даному напрямку які проявлять
зацікавленість в даному напрямку за
даними напрямами в процесі виконання
нашого проекту фітфонп
Вони теж будуть включені в базу даних і
залучені до
діяльності нашого проекту
серед як вибиралися слабо представлення
регіони це вибиралося серед
представлених
єврокомісією регіонів вибиралися регіони
в яких є потенціал за даними напрямками
але їхні
показник успішності в проектах горизонт
нижче певного критерію цей критерій
змінювався по мірі виконання проекту але
він в районі 10%
далі як ці наші напрями за якими ми
працюємо координуються з
програмою Horizon євро вони в основному
орієнтовані на
Пила 2 кластер 4 програми горизонт
Європа а саме на
напрями сучасні матеріали
технологічний процеси чисти та замкнена
промисловість
які
послуги які дії надає
наш проект для талановитих новачків
по-перше будуть організовані
семінари і конференції і
з топовими новаторами в даному напрямку
тобто він топінова - це організації з
Європейського Союзу які мають велику
історію успіху в реалізації проектів За
вказаними напрямами також будуть
проводитися тренінги з
передачі технологій трансфер з написання
пропозицій і тренінги з
тренінги по використанню європейських
мереж також буде надаватися фінансова
підтримка для таланової технологічків і
також буде надаватися
допомога в написанні пропозицій на
конкурс горизонт Європа
що таке
семінари з
топіна ватра як я вже казав топінова -
це організації які мають великий досвід
успішний досвід
подачі і отримання заявок грантів в
проекті горизонт 2020 наприклад Sia Віті
- це організація які вже підтвердили
свою участь то що вони будуть надавати
інформацію те що вони будуть допомагати
нашим новачкам і те що вони будуть
надавати їм консультації в тому числі
через наш проект і безпосередньо до
новачків
в рамках проекту планується проведення 6
таких
семінарів кожний семінар буде з іншим
тобто інноватором організатором буде
інший топінатор кожен буде зосереджений
на різних напрямах в межах nmp
і також на ці для участі новачків цих і
в цих семінарах буде надаватися їм
фінансова підтримка в для поїздок і для
участі в різних конкурсах
[музика]
тренінги по передачах
трансфер тренінг
недостача досвіду в області технологи
трансфер це є часто
вражається як основна причин
неуспішності подачі
тими організаціями які були не були
неуспішні в своїх проектах в рамках
нашого проекту буде організовано шість
належить трансфер тренінгів
всі тренінги будуть проводитися одним з
учасників нашого консор в цьому з
Голландії а саме stp
кожен з кожен з цих тренінгів буде
проводитися в одному з слабо
представлених регіонів поки що на жаль
ці регіони не визначені Ми сподіваємося
що одним з таких
семінарів буде проводитися в Україні
перший такий
тренінг планується на початок 2022 року
також для новачків будуть організовані
тренінги по написанню пропозицій
тому що згідно з опитуванням якими
проводились в рамках нашого проекту це є
одним з основних
так би мовити вузьких місць в подачі
заявок і одним з бар'єрів Це правильне
написання
правильне написання пропозицій в рамках
нашого проекту буде проводитися 6
тренінгів на які будуть
запрошені конкретні новачки які будуть
відібрані
одним з тих хто планував який буде
організовувати цей тренінг і для них
буде проводитися консультації з
написання і можливо навіть будуть
проводитися безпосередньо підтримка і
допомога в написанні пропозиції по
конкурсам програми Horizon євро
також будуть проводитися тренінги
стосовно використання
можливостей європейських мереж
для вони будуть проводитися для того для
надачі інформації
організаціям які не мали успішного
досвіду для
залучення освітлення своїх пропозицій Із
залученням максимального
максимально підходящих
учасників консорціум для
пошуку можливих консорців і так далі
будуть організовані тренінги по
використанню вже представленої раніше
європейське
будуть використовувати будуть тренінги
стосовно використання
можливості розділу пошуку партнерів
порталу фінансування і тендерів
Європейської комісії і так далі
також будуть в рамках нашого проекту
будуть проводитись
конференції для популяризації і
підтримки новачків для їхньої
максимального розповсюдження інформації
про них два таких дві таких конференції
вже проводилися одна в Києві в Україні
інша в Румунії
також в рамках нашого проекту для
новачків
будуть надаватися гранти для поїздок і
для участі в європейських брокерах івенс
також для
можливих поїздок
для
реклами своїх для промоушеного своєї
своїх пропозицій і для
проведення можливих зустрічей для
формування
консорці з європейськими з іншими
європейськими учасниками також в рамках
нашого проекту Fit буде формуватися база
даних в які будуть включені профілі
новачків з
обраних регіонів
ці ця база даних не завершена тому якщо
є зацікавленість і ви зацікавлені в тому
щоб ваш організацію
залучити була залучена в діяльність
можна подавати свої заявки або на сайті
я пізніше там далі будуть наведені
координати на які можна звертатися ви
можете бути залучені в діяльності
Світлани і 30 секундочок у нас часом Все
тоді я
Головне якщо ви талановитий новичок і
зацікавлені в отриманні підтримки від
проекту
fit-fmp вам потрібно перевірити на сайті
який переведений нижче чи регіон який ви
представляєте включений в перелік слабо
представлених регіонів і надати свою
форму заповнену за координатами які
наведені на нашому сайті Також я наводжу
координати координатора нашого проекту
і мої координати
електронна адреса і тому подібне Дякую
більше інформації можна знайти на сайті
проекту Ну що ж дуже дякуємо за вашу
презентацію
і колеги пиздимо на таймінг дуже
обмежена лише 10 хвилин на кожного
спікера безумовно Це абсолютно
недостатньо для того аби висвітлити
повністю таку цікаву таку тему широку
Але тим не менше Да От ми сьогодні
знаходимось у спринті тому величезне
прохання до усіх учасників нашої
трансляції якщо Тима зацікавила то будь
ласка обмінюйтесь контактами будь ласка
напишіть спікерам згадайте свої
запитання оскільки цей захід саме для
того аби сформувати Містки аби
сформувати підтримку комунікації дати
вам можливості для подальшого співпраці
для подальшого комунікації тому
безумовно 10 хвилин часу то ні про що
Але тим не менше можна створити загальне
враження можете дізнатись про певні
основні ключові речі далі продовжити
спілкування наша наступна тема і наша
наступна презентація вона буде
стосуватися клінічних знань про людства
і презентація Вона знаходиться на межі
дуже багатьох сфер знань це власне
клінічні Випробування цеї арти з цієї
купа Селена можливостей унікальних
інноваційних які відкривають Це між нами
про такі можливості ми поговоримо і Я
впевнений те що насправді програми
підтримки горизонт Європа Вона відкриває
можливості абсолютно для будь-яких
учасників хоч дата сентист хоч аналітик
хоч хімік білолог хоч представники
абсолютно різних галузей знань науки Але
тим не менше можливості відкриваються
абсолютно для усіх підтримка абсолютно
унікальна Отож долучайтесь підхоплюйте
цю ініціативу і побачити те що перед
вами відкриваються абсолютно Нові
горизонти для того аби-то все втілювати
в життя для того аби і новація бути для
того аби розвиток науки техніки синергія
Наша команда дійсно втілювалась у життя
сьогодні ми будемо знайомитись ще із
кількома презентаціями успіху стартапів
проектів унікальних ініціатив які були
реалізовані завдяки програмі горизонт
2020 Ну і власне програма горизонт 2020
ми спо вона надихне до подальших
звершень до того аби продовжити
втілювати для того аби скористатись
можливостями горизонт Європа Отож
Шановні колеги долучайтесь світ відкрити
можливості відкриті і кожне з вас
долучився до відповідних програм може
Максом для себе отримати з точки зору
розвитку Отож я сподіваюсь те що ми
готові продовжити те що все у нас із
технічної точки зору готове Отож Якщо
так то я із радістю запрошу нашу
наступного спікера будь ласка вітайте
Дмитро Королюк національно-технічного
університету України Київський
політехнічний інститут імені Ігоря
Сікорського знання на кінчиках пальців
клінічні знання про людства вітаємо на
сцені будь ласка Запрошуємо під оплески
перш за все Я хотів би
подякувати
організаторам заходу за
за те що нас запросили я буду
представляти європейські консорці
який називається Каті це скорочення
нолич за тип of your fingers тобто так
сказати знання на кінчиков на кінчиках
ваших пальців значить
європейські консорціум складається з
багатьох країн європейських і
організацій я потім вам покажу
значить і я
представляю зокрема значить цей
консорціум як
українська і українське відділення його
тобто так це об'єднання двох факультетів
національного технічного університету
України ігорськ імені Ігоря Сікорського
значить
цей проект він
присвячений
значить застосуванню
штучного інтелекту для
клінічних значить для ліничних лікувань
ракових захворювань
значить
в чому
полягає значить постановка задачі
постановка задачі полягає в тому що як
відомо є велика кількість от
класифікація велика різних онкологічних
захворювань є для кожного захворювання є
значить деякі Range значить різних
підходів до до лікування цих захворювань
але значить от лікарів бачать що значить
реакція індивідуальна людина вона дуже
індивідуальна комусь може допомогти
певна певний протокол значить лікування
комусь менші а для когось це просто так
сказать навіть шкода
і значить
медичні дослідження привели до того що
треба
співставляти значить генетичну мапу
людини її біохімічні властивості там
аналіз крові і інші там спеціальні
характеристики і значить діагноз і
значить методи як його лікувати значить
в Європі в в
[музика]
клініках значить певної такої наукової
направленості значить
були зібрані за останні 30 років
багаті бази даних про генетичні мапи і
біохімію людей які
були підлягали Значить
медицинським значить процедурам для для
лікування ракових
онкологічних захворювань але ці дані
дуже такі розвазані вони так сказать
неоднорідні значить з госпіталя до
госпіталя і їх треба якось привести до
загального знаменника і це можна зробити
значить для такого великого
великої кількості даних тільки за
допомогою штучного інтелекту значить які
значить де optix які цілі Значить ми
ставимо значить перше - це
використати ці медичні дані генетичні
дані різних центрів центрів значить які
лікують онкологію значить в Європі
значить другий - це значить розробити
ну адекватні схеми
штучного інтелекту
і значить
втілювати втілювати це в
автоматичну систему на кшталт значить
[музика]
консультанта
лікаря лікувальні лікувальника значить
цих значить онкологій тепер значить
зробити цю систему гнучкою такого що
може сама
значить досконалюватися за допомогою
введення нових даних які так сказать от
ну
поточні процеси лікування і четверте -
це значить
на кінці цього проекту а значить він
передбачається
21-24-й рік значить 25-му році
організувати в сиріях
в деякою кількості клінік європейських
організувати пілотний проект для для
того щоб довести перевагу цього методу
над іншими методами значить рішення як
який тип значить терапії треба значить
застосовувати для того чи іншого
пацієнта
значить
тематика - це
штучний інтелект для
гімноміки і персональний медицини Ну і
тепер
значить наші наші
внесок Тепер я буду розказувати про наш
внесок як Київською політехніки в цей
проект Значить ми будемо займатися
розробкою
невральною сітки яка адекватна для
постановки такої задачі далі ми маємо
підготувати дані для глибокого машинного
навчання цього штучного інтелекту
тепер ми
маємо значить зробити
оптимізацію
оптимізаційні і прискорюючі алгоритми
які дозволять нам
скоріше розробляти цю систему
значить обробляти дані значить
статистичні
статистичний вибір значить даних нам теж
прискорює значить вибір правильних
правильних моделей і нарешті нам треба
оцінювати адекватність математичних
моделей які ми будемо застосовувати для
створення такого автоматичного помічника
доктора
значить
тепер які ми будемо робити
дії з Києва це значить у нас в Київську
є система векторних обчислень
паралельних обчислень Яка найбільш
потужна в Україні
одна із найбільш потужних в Україні а
може і в східній Європі І ми
є
достатньо незалежними для того щоб
розробити навіть в наших стінах от цей
значить прототипи ці значить діючі
прототипи таких
автоматичних такого автоматичного
помічника
тепер Значить ми будемо займатися
значить оптимізації
Навчання процеса навчання такого
штучного інтелекту і будемо значить
передбачати наповнення
додатковий наповнення цього штучного
інтелекту новими даними які надходять з
госпіталей
так
і значить цей Каті консорціум Значить
тут є 20 значить 20 учасників тут список
і 20-й - це
Київське Політехнічний інститут із 12
країн Тобто це великий консорціум
на 4 роки
фінансування цього консорціуму 8 з
половиною мільйонів євро
Ну і може буде продовження ще на один
рік як пілотний проект Дуже дякую за
увагу
Ну що ж Дякуємо вам Дякуємо за ваше
презентація
[оплески]
Ну що ж колеги бачимо те що історії
успіху прекрасних дуже і дуже багато
Отож долучайтесь і ви і створювати свою
власну історію успіху як створити свою
власну історію успіху розкаже нам
наступний наш спікер Отож проект
технологія мобільного виробництва
полімерних труб Великого діаметру на
місцях із технологією 3D зварювання
Запрошуємо до виступу Сергія середу
засновника компанії будь ласка під ваші
оплески
[оплески]
Доброго дня
Моє ім'я Середа Сергій я співвласник
компанії
[музика]
що виробляє
мобільне обладнання для полімерних труб
Великого діаметру
великий діаметр мається на увазі від 30
см до двох метрів Ці труби
використовуються для інженерних мереж
інфраструктурних мереж
[музика]
Тобто це каналізація
рівностокі тощо
ринок цих труб глобальна дуже великий
Тобто ми працюємо на ринку більш ніж
57 мільйонів доларів це ринок росте Ми
сподіваємося що ця технологія буде дуже
корисною глобально
чому це важливо для України за
офіційними даними знос інфраструктурних
мереж України складає більш ніж
65%, щодо Києву мерклічко каже що більш
ніж 75%. в аварійному стані більш ніж
20%, тобто Ці труби Ми повинні були
замінити ще вчора Тому рішення щодо
більш ефективного більш швидкого
способу зміни інфраструктурних
трубопроводів це не тільки важливе
завдання для виробництва чи комунальних
служб це також зменшення платіжок для
кожного
споживача тому ця технологія базується
на базі вже існуючого обладнання але ж
стаціонарного що вже 15 років працює в
Україні
виробляється ємкості та труби до
чотирьох метрів але ж мобільна
технологія це унікальна в мирових
світових масштабах немає аналогів цієї
технології наразі в мірі в світі
тому ми вважаємо що ця технологія
game-chen мається на увазі вона ламає
е-е цепочку
поставок
порівняння з існуючим бізнесом дає
велику кількість переваг і також дає
економію бюджету до 30%. А ми отримали
від горизонту 2020 програм Гранд 2017
року 50 тисяч євро по першої фазі ми
використали використали цей грант на
тестування нашого концепцію
мобільного виробництва ми зустрілися з
провідними компаніями США Європи
отримали фідбек від ринку поміняли
тотально поміняли наш концепт
ми мінімально наш концеп чотири рази
Також ми подавалися на другу фазу 5
разів
і наразі на 5 раз ми отримали грант
подругу фазі
Гранд по другому фазі Ми отримали 2020
році це змішане фінансування наразі цей
ран триває
це 1,8 млн євро
цей грант передбачає виробництво
промислового промислового зразка цієї
технології тестування на практиці цієї
технології в Україні та бажано
десь у Європі А також сертифікація
продукції щодо
інвестування
грантова Програма також передбачена
фінансування
безпосередньо в компанію тобто
інвестиція Європейського Союзу тобто
одна із
фінансових компаній Європейського
Союзу стає наши м співвласникам і
зацікавлена в розвитку цієї технології в
глобальних масштабах
Як це працює Мабуть краще на відео
покажемо іншого ф'ючерп powerplanes in
the Story Pines mobile.»
[музика]
так
наша технологія вирішує існуючі проблеми
порівняння з
технологіями що на сьогодні
використовується перш за все за все
треба доставити на місце
аліменти труби
це від 6 до 12 метрів тобто
окремо вантажівка потрібно щоб доставити
кожну трубу Після цього ми робимо не ми
а книжка
обично обично робиться стиковка
елементів труби це дуже тривалий та
коштовний етап
між цим етапами
труби різних діаметрів
заморожене на складах
регіональних складах тому
для того щоб
зробити це більш ефективним ми
використовуємо нашу мобільну установку
яка покриває от базового заводу на якому
виробляється профіль
1000 км тобто якщо ми маємо базовий
завод Який переробляє сировину
гранули в профіль покриття буде вся
Україна якщо ми такі завод ставимо в
Європі це буде декілька стран Європи
тобто маючи флот таких мобільних юнітов
ми можемо дуже швидко закрити великий
обсяг території і
виробляти труби Великого діаметра
в різних країнах
економія на
[музика]
транспортних витратах на
імплементації проектів труб
імплементації
а також економія ідіот матеріали труп
Тобто ми потрапляємо менш матеріалів ніж
завжди
А щодо використання окрім використання
Ми маємо також
новий
Blue Ocean Market
мається на увазі
ведемо перемовини для тестування нашої
технології в Британії
Це дуже
цікава компанія яка
робить підземною інфраструктуру для
доставки товарів та посилок
вони наступного року планують перше 9 км
виробити підземних шляхів і доставляти
грузи від існуючого
складу який розташований за межами міста
і вони хочуть
до 40 тисяч вантажівок в
місяць убрати з дороги тобто
розгрузить місто
Чому
наша співробітниця для них цікава тому
що їх мережа
пот містом і вони не можуть не можуть
виробляти трубу під землею наша рішення
позволяє безпосередньо позивний
производити трубу поставляє енергію та
профіль підземлю
якщо
ліва картинка демонструє
попередньо нашу технологію яка
стаціонарному виробництва до 4 метрів
труби справа ми бачимо вже мобільну
установку яка в рамках програми
горизонту вироблена та тестується наразі
Також ми отримали
подяку та Гранд Європейської комісії як
компанія що економіціоту
ми в рамках зеленого дела також маємо
переваги Дякую за увагу на що ж Дякуємо
вам Дякуємо за вашою історію успіху ну і
звісно подальше втілен і аби проект
розвивався і все маштабувались дякуємо
дуже рухаємось наш нон-стоп триває
наступна презентація вона буде
зосереджена на радоні та норм до
ефективного радіаційного захисту на
основі вдосконалених наукових даних і
соціальних міркувань ми зараз переходимо
переходимо разом із наступним нашим
спікером Володимир берковський будь
ласка вітаємо на сцені
Доброго вечора
Мене звуть головним берковський Я
директор інституту радіаційного захисту
і
ми сьогодні поговоримо про радіаційний
ризики та щоскуються
сфера наша дуже специфічна На жаль
українська мовна термінологія тільки
розвивається До речі ми того тижня
запропонували Міністерство охорони
здоров'я новий нормативний документ в
цій сфері нормою цінної безпеки це
апгрейться того документу коли який ми
зробили багато років тому навіть 20
років тому наші тут розробив цей
документ зараз це новий документ який
основується на базуються на європейській
директиви щодо реакційного захисту і
українська мовна термінологія зараз
запропонована але сьогодні на жаль я
змушений розмовляти англійською тому що
з цією технологією в нашій сфері це
специфічна сфера немає тому я гадаю що
нікого не засмучує англійська давайте
англійською добре
не можуть перекладати добре ну
не знаю як як вони будуть добре Давайте
спробуємо українською що таке радон
утворюється у недрах та
проникаю у нашій житлові будинки і
опромінює нас
основна причина
раку легенів - це радон А якщо ви ще із
палюти паляти то це радон це дійсно
причина грапу до речі сьогодні мене
зателефонували з ровенського АЕС
запросили допомоги тому що їх
співробітник зараз захворів на рак І на
жаль
у Києві наприклад тільки два петкат вони
не можуть отримати часу на цій пкт Та це
великий такий хлопець 120 кг апарати не
можуть прийнятися з пацієнта це приклад
того що це дійсно так це
працівник атомної станції але причина
цього року не з атомна станція а
природний радіоквідтер радон е-е проект
також конструктор торкається природних
інших природних релігії таких так як
уран уран є всюди І е-е наприклад якщо у
вас є дача то у вас десь на ділянці є
уран його не дуже вигідно добувати але
він є Він на вашу опромінює радіо люди
присутні
у цьому залі в цій залі є районів
України повірте мені так Кожний з вас
з великою інтенсивністю 5000 розпадів у
кожній людині зараз кожної секунди
створюються
поїхали сюди мікрофончик трошечки
поближче
проект який який ми приймаємо участь він
сфокусований на цих аспектах
радіологічних ризиках і це вже таке
велике проєкт 18 мільйонів євро на 5
років і в ньому приймають дуже багато
європейських інститутів так сталося що і
ми приймаємо участь не просто так тому
що інститут давно працюють з безпекою і
ми маємо суттєвий вплив на ті міжнародні
процеси на ті міжнародні документи які
зараз створюються Ну якось пропустив
водночас частину хто я такий працюю в
радіаційній безпеці з 86-го року з
Чорнобилем 8 років
працював у мегатем і Фукусіма була також
моєю та був відповідальною за створення
міжнародних стандартів безпеки
на базі яких Зараз ми працюємо
далі
сіль проекту - це зниження цих ризиків
та
розуміння
глибинних механізмів які
пов'язані з опромінням радоном
перш за все це дозиметрія легенів як я
говорю це основний основна суттєва
причина раку легенів
що ми очікуємо від цього проекту
перш за все це
суттєво зниження невизначеності які
пов'язані з опроміненням радоном Це
велика проблема рак легенів це один з
ведучих
одна з основних
причинних випадків від раку та Якщо ми
будемо розуміти чому та як буде легше
боротись з цим
проект включає різні аспекти давайте
подивимось
ми працюємо з ризиками та дозиметрією
але також є багато інститутів які
зосереджувались на технологіях Та так
званому управлінні ризиком що робити
якщо у вас є роду
в Європі Наприклад багато
національних програм у Австрії наприклад
в Австрії кожна людина може витратити
власні власні кошти на боротьбу з
радоном власного будинку та
запропонувати державі компенсацію
запросити компенсацію для цього є
спеціалізована компанія які
здійснюють обстеження до того як
здійснюється така
активність
боротьба з радоном та після того от якщо
цей ефективно якщо ви витратили гроші
ефективно то ви можете отримати суттєву
чашку від ваших витрат до декількох
тисяч євро Австрія витрачає на кожну
оселю для того щоб боротися з радоном
таке такі програми є і у Скандинавії на
жаль в Україні є це суттєва проблема але
на жаль в нас немає на це коштів тому
кожен
бореться як може проект буде
запропонувати ефективні
і посильні технології для того щоб це
робити далі
8 робочих пакетів
і Як бачите це таке дуже
пов'язана робота різних інститутів
взагалі митися кожного місяця маємо такі
телеконференції
Перехресні та розмовляємо Що ми зробили
так куди ми рухаємось
це
в проекті мабуть майже Вся Європа якщо
бачите Майже у всіх странах це суттєво
проблема це
державі та 57 наукових установ
наша роль Як бачите почесне
місце номер 17 і нас Ми навіть не
просили до цього до цієї проєкт до цього
проекту нас покликали тому що багато
років в нас є технології є знання в
цьому
напрямку і наприклад
Ну ми засновані в 95-му році ми саме
були засновані групи вчених які
працювали спочатку
говорить цій небезпеці потім з
Чорнобилем та з іншими проблемами з
проблемами ядерної енергетики інститут
працює з усіма атомними станціями
України
Так
здійснює підтримку як вітчизняних так і
закордонних установ в тому числі
міжнародних установ
один із засновників інституту старіші
засновник і ми дуже вдячні цій людині
професор ліхтарьов заснував в Україні
школу науково після Чорнобиля він
повернувся з санкт-петербургу до України
він народився у Чернігові працював
багато років Росії та повернувся Ну тоді
Російська Федерація повернувся Та якась
дуже багато зробив і в Чорнобилі І
взагалі в організаційній безпеці це
стаття у радіобая фізіс Як бачите
провідні вчені
приймали участь у написанні цього
меморіала а-а дуже такий подробний
життєпис
цього науковця подивіться
Що ми робимо взагалі Це ми працюємо з
науковими комітетом ООН дія атомної
радіації це єдиний науковий комітет ООН
і наприклад з цього року вийшла
публікація цього комітету щодо до
опромінення населення фокусів населення
Японії та навколо і фукусіми наша
інститут
надав для цього для цієї доповіді великі
наукові матеріали науковий матеріал ще
не не опублікований в інших
виданнях ми співпрацюємо з міжнародною
комісією з радіологічного захисту
І наприклад я очолюю один з комітетів
цієї комісії з
надзвичайних ситуацій
Ми наприклад випустили нову публікацію
міжнародної комісії за радіологічних
одиниць вимірів це також буде
використовуватися у проекті та працюємо
також міжнародною агенцією з Атомної
енергії
та іншім організаціями Європейська
комісія одна з них
протягом 15 років ми підтримували
програму безпеки на майданчику
Чорнобильської станції
дуже багато зроблено 17 тисяч осіб
пройшло через контроль дозиметричний
біофізичний
та
у цьому проєкті наприклад ця співпраця з
іншими міжнародними організаціями дуже
важливо наприклад Наш внесок до проекту
це
публікація номер
141 в якому ми це дуже таке суттєвий
вклад
суттєвий об'єм дозі медичної інформації
дуже коефіцієнти це така база даних
цифрових цифрових цифрових матеріалів
для того щоб розраховувати дози та
моделювання цих процесів включено в
публікацію мкрза а й серпнішого протекшн
і У проекті наша роль це дозиметрія це
кількісний опис це процесів
дозоутворення
процеси дуже складні Я мабуть не буду
поглублятися у деталі А взагалі це якщо
уявляти що таке Легені це така
ієрархічна структура де є багато шарів
тканин і
видалення енергії іонізуючого
випромінювання оцих шарах це дуже
складний процес Ну і до того ж ці шари
це не естетичні такі як від структури а
наші легені якось постійно оновлюються
тому біокінетика чи легенів дуже складна
і важка для моделювання
ми цим будемо займаємося будемо
займатися у проєкті
є такі перлини аспекти як епіміологія
осіб які зазнали опромінення від радону
що вони отримали чому які наслідки та
час обмежені в часі добре добре пішли
далі Ну і це приклад
спеціалізованого програмного
забезпечення яке таке ж буде
використовуватися в проекті Дякую за
увагу якщо є питання Я до ваших
розпорядженні Дуже дякуємо вам на цікава
презентація Дякуємо і вітаємо плескання
Ну що ж колеги рухаємось далі ще кілька
презентацій Нас чекають сьогодні Отож
наступна презентація вона буде
стосуватися розвитку інноваційного
потенціалу в українських мсп та
посилення співпраці з європейськими мсп
і з радістю запрошених це сину до слова
Олександра бєдюха керівника програми
інен Ukraine в Київському національному
університеті імені Тараса Шевченка
Олександре сцена ваша Вітаємо вас
Дуже дякую за можливість тут виступити
Ну проєм тут уже було декілька
презентацій перш за все нашого
координатора Олена фесенка Я хотів би
зупинитися на успіхах яка як яких
досягла по-перше ця мережа в Україні і
як вона наразі допомагає реально
допомагає українським
резидентом досягти цього успіху
ми маємо статистику
по фактично наш статистика вона основна
на статистика - це укладення угоди це
наша основна звітність перед
європейською комісією за те що що ми
відповідаємо Як ви бачите на цьому
слайді ми
загалом наш консольством який
складається з 7-7 організацій
зареєстрував 193
успішний Так ми назвемоса який
включаються партнершими і реєстина
конституційний послуги це реальні
результати допомоги конкретним
українським президентом Зверніть увагу
що перше таке послуги були ще в 13-му
році
а фінансування цього проекту з Європи
почалося 17-му році тобто сам наш проект
він теж досяг успіху на протязі кілька
років Коли ми працювали для іміджу
нашого нашого консульства ми змінювався
змінювався склад трошки але основний
виконавці концерт залишилися ті самі і
зараз цей консорціум досяг вже
професійного такого я б сказав би
рівня який відповідає в європейським
концом не не не дармами наш концерт
виграв нагороду про яку говорила
Олена Фесенко
далі тут є дані саме про університет
Шевченка і приклади ну от що таке
наприклад
конституційний послуги Ну от 18-19 роках
ми до кавіду завдяки роботу через син ми
змогли кілька
стартапів кілька
груп розробників за рахунок приймаючої
сторони дозволили їм поїхати по Європі в
Китай і це продовжилось би навіть
нарощували Ну на жаль цьому
припинив це ну не думаю що десь через
деякий час ми це відновимо Які ще
послуги Ну наприклад ми допомагаємо трим
сертифікат на європейській кадр на
продукцію українських підприємств або
скажімо допомогти вийти на відповідні
ринки в даному випадку азіатські Ну а і
приклади партнерських угод Ну от тут от
ви бачите в 17-му році у нас було 34
партнерські угоди коли ми допомогли
створити консорці якраз роботи з
горизонтом 2020
А як цього досягти ну от як фактично за
допомогою інтеграції виробництва досягти
успіху а фактично успіху ми називаємо
можливість
створити контакти перш за все з
іноземними закордонними
зацікавленими партнерами а потім з ними
якраз підписати подібні угоди
Що Що треба зробити перш за все треба
зареєструватися мережі як на мене дуже
демократична система для реєстрації
достатньо електронну адресу прізвище
ім'я
контактної особи і назва підприємств Ну
і контактний телефон цього достатньо
тобто реєстрація в мережі дуже
демократична після цього
зареєстрований клієнт отримає пропозицію
вибрати пароль і може працювати з
мережею тобто реєстрація займає
буквально декілька хвилин
після того якраз
клієнт мережі отримує досить широкий
широкий широкий можливості користуватися
інструменти в мережі такі інструменти
вже були були
про них уже було сказано але нею Фесенко
я трошки Я трошки більше про них скажу
Ну основний елемент який можна
використати для ну отримання зв’язків
тобто для тренування контактів це база
даних запитів і пропозицій
в даному випадку ви бачите пошукову
систему теж дуже демократична Тобто
можна вибрати країну можна вибрати тип
профілю Запитів там бізнес технологічні
тому подібне А можна просто ввести там
ключове слово що в даному випадку і
зроблено там інформаційні технології і
побачити скільки запитів і
пропозиції є по цьому ключовим словом в
даному випадку якщо не помиляюсь там
таких
біля 700 оце зробив вчора біля 700
пропозицій для
співпраці ви можете до кожного з цих
пропозицій от приблизно так вона
виглядає отам в кінці є можливість
створити весь інтересу після створення
горизонтурес фактично вас є контакти
авторів цього профілю ви можете
кантувати з ним фактично На цьому наша
функція зупиняється Якщо хочете ми
можемо продовжити вам допомагати але
фактично після цього ви можете працювати
безпосередньо з авторами того профілю
відповідно це можливість утворити той
контакт і надалі
після розвитку контакту Зрозуміло Як для
нас
найважливіше це результат утворити ну
створити Так ми з вами партнерську угоду
тобто домовитись про співпрацю це один з
інструментів інший інструмент - Це
участь подіях про яке теж трошки
говорила Олена трошки
більше про це скажу от це
календар подій який
З понеділка от кожен день якісь події 6
грудня і так далі Ну в даному випадку до
кінця грудня 40 таких подій
в різних абсолютно різних галузях От
наприклад вибрала одну от
приблизно от там щось
індустві 4:0 при подія яка відбувається
в Турції 8 грудня До речі реєстрація ще
можливо це це вівторок якщо не помиляюсь
от в цій події вже зараз приймають
участь
зараз подивлюсь 150 учасників ви можете
призначити зареєструватися в події
можете призначити Прекрасну зустріч з
будь-яким учасниками відповідно от ще
одна можливість організувати контакт
дуже просто дуже ефективна і Абсолютно
безкоштовно
Ну і останнє це викласти свою власну
пропозицію в цій мережі якщо звернули
увагу пропозиції займає півтори сторінки
ну зрозуміло англійською мовою оце
основний основні інструменти часу про
них просто сказав які дозволяють реально
отримати партнера відповідно далі від
вас залежить домовитися з партнером про
співпрацю
Дякую за увагу Ну що ж Дякуємо вам пане
Олександре за презентацію за можливості
Ну і впевнений теж разом із Європі
нетерпрес Network спільно Ми зробимо
дуже багато крутих речей і наші учасники
неодмінно долучаться Я теж на це
сподіваюсь Ну що ж ще раз Дякуємо і
продовжуємо наш спринт ото Шановні
колеги наступна презентація це
презентація проектів біосенс
ультрасучасний портативний пристрій для
точного та швидкого аналізу посівів
запрошуємо на сцену Андрія Карпюка
генерального директора та засновника
біосенс представляються національний
університет біоресурсів та
природокористування України будь ласка
все на ваша Запрошуємо і вітаю
Всім доброго вечора Мене звати Андрій
Карп'юк я засновник стартап компанії
біосенс в якій ми розробляємо прилад для
експрес-діагностики продуктів харчування
перш за все хочу подякувати всім хто
залишився до цієї години От і постараюся
в даній презентації поділитися досвідом
розказати той Шлях який Ми пройшли за
останні 5 років і надіюсь комусь з вас
щось та й буде корисним
і так в
близько 15 років тому назад Я приїхав в
Київ закінчив магістратуру по
електрифікації автоматизації а під час
магістратури я почав цікавитися
біосенсорами відповідно вступив до
аспірантури якраз на тему розробка
біосенсорів для експрес-діагностики
продуктів харчування безпосередньо
мікротоксинів
паралельно навчаючись в аспірантурі був
досвід підприємництва і запускав два
бізнеса один із них До речі працює по
сьогоднішній день от Але після цих
класичних бізнесів була ідея створити
щось масштабне
те що можна розвивати по всьому світу от
і так як досвід за плечима був тільки в
біосенсарах відповідно це якраз і стало
за основу стартап проекту чисто
випадково я побачив в Фейсбуці рекламу
про агрохакетон я Він не знав що таке
хакатон і з чим його їдять
то есть і я взяв там участь там
познайомився зі своїм партнером
Олександром за яким ми по сьогоднішній
день працюємо бо як ви знаєте Коли
створюється якась стартап компанія дуже
часто буває що
партнери приходять уходять тому що
досить така Це нелегка
справа інколи і в кінцевому результаті
Тобто ми прийшли до до такого прототипу
ми міряємо мікротоксини це продукти
життєдіяльності грибів зараз про них
більш детальніше розкажу близько 25%
всієї насіннєвої продукції щорічно
уражується мікротоксимами внаслідок чого
в світі ми втрачаємо близько одного
мільярда тонн харчової продукції Уявіть
собі це достатньо щоб нагодувати цілий
Континент протягом цілого року і
найбільшою проблемою
мікротоксинів є те що близько 150 тисяч
людей щорічно хворіють на рак через те
що споживають продукцію кон
мікотоксинами і на сьогоднішній день щоб
провести діагностику є два варіанти
Тобто Це або відправляти в лабораторію
це дорого і довго або купляти Експрес
методи але вони є складні в використанні
і вони
не є достатньо точними от ми розробили
Прилад за допомогою якого без Скажімо
так ступеня phd за плечами можна
провести аналіз і основним об'єктом
нашого патенту є це безпосередньо
автоматизація правопідготовки
Ми отримали патент в Україні і пройшли
50 процедуру в Європейському патентному
офісі
так ну це все про нас це наша крута
команда яку я збирав п'ять років не буду
зупинятися на ній розкажу більше про наш
досвід Тобто Це був 2016 рік це тут був
агрохакатон на агрохокатоні з 30
проектів Ми зайняли тільки шосте місце
але нас запросили тоді в it Hub
Роман Кравченко засновник цього хабу де
зібралися молоді активні команди в яких
в яких було дуже багато енергії багато
бажання але в тих чи інших моментах не
хватало досвіду в когось маркетингу в
когось проти типуванні і в таких
інкубаторах
якраз можна цю цю експертизу отримати і
зробити перший прототип
перші Прототип це були це ще якраз на
основі моїх наукових досліджень там був
датчик взятий за основу це
нано-структурований кремній але потім в
2017 році ми поїхали в Швейцарію на три
місяці на кікстар такселератор де Ми
зрозуміли що точний сенсор це важливо
але для клієнтів наших потенційних ще є
дуже важливим є той момент це простота в
використанні а простота використання це
на сьогоднішній день це є проба
підготовка Тобто це ціла куща реагентів
ціла куча піпеток з якими треба
лаборанти людині безпосередньо яка
проводить аналіз працювати І ми всі
розуміємо що є людський фактор так тобто
щось неправильно зробив отримав хибний
хибний результат і після цієї
екселерації ми коли приїхали ми почали
працювати там давали 15 тисяч франків на
цих три місяці в Швейцарія дуже дороге
місто там 15 доларів коштує бокал пива
але Нам вдалося зекономити пару тисяч і
ми коли вже вернулися в Україну то і ми
за ці кошти почали працювати над
автоматизацією про підготовки
як потім
і оцей перший період я більше Я його
називаю цих перших два роки це такий як
Learning Це був період навчання Тобто ми
тоді всі працювали десь на якихось
роботах хтось хтось в університеті хтось
в приватних компаніях і проект біосенс
для нас був чисто як хобі Скажем так у
вільний від роботи час
вже в наступні два роки ми вже почали
більш серйозно займатися цим питанням Ми
отримали фінансування це кліматичні
інноваційні ваучери 50 тисяч євро
також ще ми отримали
50 тисяч від програми горизонт 2020 і
самі інструмент перша фаза на жаль на
другу фазу так як попередній проект про
труби ми подавалися чотири рази на 5 і
ми другу фазу не отримали можливо нам
треба податися ще п'ятий раз
Так а ну і також також ми ще отримали
фінансування на розвиток цього проекту
від
Експо 2020
Думаю багато хто з вас знає що
проводиться зараз в Дубаях виставка
Експо 2020 це виставка триває півроку От
і організатори цієї виставки вони з усіх
точок світу збирали інноваційні проекти
не виділили бюджет чи там була якась
історія
вони коли в 2014 році там в фіналі по
тендеру проведення цієї виставки був
санкт-петербург і Дубаї Дубаї виграли
цей тендер і після цього вони зібралися
І шейхи так от і сіли і подумали
великі компанії великі країни вони і так
приїдуть на цю виставку і зможуть себе
представити От і але що робити з
невеличкими компаніями з малими
проектами які не приїдуть до нас якщо
вони зробили вони виділили бюджет 100
млн доларів і почали ось цих 6 років до
2020 року шукати проекти
підтримувати їх фінансово за цих 5 років
було профінансовано 120 проектів це в
розмірі 100 тисяч доларів і ми єдиний
проект з України
Так це були там наші наші локальні
програми
через там включив включили в якийсь
рейтинг по незрозумілі нам причині за
які заслуги
підрезимуючи що я хочу сказати Хочу
сказати що
в мене немає Великого досвіду залучення
приватних інвестицій в основному це є
тобто з нашого шляху в біосенці Та ми
пішли по грантовій історії якщо ми
говоримо про розвиток стартапу треба
розуміти де ви хочете бути через півроку
через рік через два роки і відносно
цього приймати рішення тому що залучення
гарантів це є довгий процес і Ну от я
сьогодні розказав там про наш кейс де ми
отримали три гранти воно все виглядає
круто Класно але ніхто але ніхто ж не
знає тобто Ніхто ж не говорить про те що
ми подавалися на 30 проектів Да і з них
тільки три було профінансовано і
насправді це займає дуже багато часу і
якщо є хороша технологія яку потрібно
швидко вивести на ринок то це не
грантова історія це приватні інвестиції
це швидкий вихід на ринок
тому що грантова історія - це я думаю
більшість з вас тут краще за мене знаєте
що коли ти на проект подаєшся особливо
там консорціум Так це проект може
початися через рік півтора
10 хвилин
Всім дякую за увагу якщо будуть
запитання Буду радий відповісти Ну що ж
Андрій Дуже дякуємо
Ну і власне я для себе занотував те що
потрібно пробувати потрібно для того аби
досягнути успіху дуже багато усього
пройти і тоді успіх точно посміхнеться
Іноді може бути
27-29 із 30-ти заявок які будуть файлом
але потім да от буде виграш і він
принесе власне розвиток проекту отаку
історію успіху яка зараз є у вас дуже
дякуємо за презентацію Ну і рухаємось до
крайньої на сьогодні презентації Як то
кажуть це лазбатнотлист а то Шановні
колеги презентація яка присвячена
проекту I Solution labs запрошуємо на
сину Ігоря катюба засновника проекту
isolution Label - це Національної
академії наук України Отож бачимо вас
Будь ласка увага на екран Дякуємо за те
що долучились Ну і власне наша
віртуальна сцена ваша будь ласка
запрошуємо
Добрий вечір дякую це складно вступати
крайньому сказали бо я розумію що я
перешкодом між е-е власне виступитами
І хочу розповісти про наш шлях і
підтримую
попереднього спікера стосовно важкості
цього і хоче додати для чого ми це
робили також під час мого виступу
давайте наступний слайд
тобто власне
почали працювати з горизон 2020 і
намагатися знайти себе там чи з самого
початку самого першого дня благодійності
коли Україна стала асоційованою і
ми
сфокусувалися на сайті а і безпекових
питаннях і стосовно енергетики і
стосовно критичні інфраструктури
власними виправлення сьогодні три
проекти знову ж таки підтримав проект
53 от власне І чому ми вважаємо от
кібербезпеці горизонт 2020 Це є дуже
потужна синергетична штука тому що
власне для нас I Solutions в Україні ну
дуже було б складно скажімо там рішення
звернентувати
смарт Сіті модель А через Smart City тут
у Фінляндії а власне горизонту
який дозволяє нам співпрацювати з тобто
компаніями от зараз на слайді ви бачите
наш останній проект який ми можемо
тільки два місяці тільки почався
Електрон де ми власне знову ж таки в нас
перемог - це те що ми змогли долучити
українську і кейси потім попередніх
проект Так тут власна нас
Прикарпаттяобленерго Як ви знаєте це 5
років тому це цей Обленерго який було
такого вони і весь регіон був без
електрики і ми розробляємо новітні
рішення А стосовно кібербезпеки
енергетичних мереж і будемо їх
застосовувати в тому числі
Прикарпаттяобленерго європе
власне разом 2020 і Ну я б сказав
основні секрети і основні речі які
хотіли би
відзначити Це звісно
я дуже рекомендую всім публікуватись
топових виданнях
англійською мовою Я
рекомендую не звертати увагу на індекс
гірше як це там національних програмах
чи там дуже дуже суттєвий Фактор тут все
ж таки це те й нетворкінг Це ті рішення
які ви робите І ми проводимо веб-шоу
пойти колись розслідуванням злочинів США
вже п'ятий рік я сказав би що це цей
майданчик де більше всього в нас
партнерства тому що там ми співпрацюємо
із правоохоронними органами що в науці
а-а беріть відповідальність
відповідальність і
саме
делівером тобто
давайте і
Скажімо так
результатом має бути те що ви обіцяли і
це є
секрет автоматичного участі в наступних
колах тому що
Звісно що консортію ми
хотіли б мати людей які є консистенції є
розуміння що ми можемо разом зробити
щось інтеграційне і відповісти на всі ті
виклики які описує комісія нам колах які
є тепер і майбутніх А які ще побачать
тому дякую Я хотів би бути максимально
стислим тому що ну власне власне
часом небагато і
тому напевно завершує виступ тут
доєднуйтесь там соціальних мережах Я
готовий відповідати на питання І власне
давайте горизонт Європа якому
Ну що ж дуже дякуємо Дуже дякуємо вам за
презентацію Ну і власне зараз підбиваємо
підсумки нашого сьогоднішнього заходу
долучаємося до того аби ну власне
підбити трошечки да от ті фокуси які
сьогодні озвучувались і перспективки до
яких можна було долучитись ото Шановні
колеги Міністерство освіти та науки
України
директор директора та будь ласочка
запрошуємо вас Будь ласка вітаємо на
сцені будь ласка ваші Оплески і трошки
якщо можна підсумки сьогоднішнього
нашого заходу І власне розказати про те
як воно все спрацювало які ви
перспективи стосовно роботи вашого
директорату представляєте і в як ви то
все Бачите які подальші шляхи Ми
сьогодні намітили
дякую
ну по-перше хотів би сказати
Величезне дякую сьогодні всім спікерам
Я думаю що сьогодні ми побачили таку
такий зріз
класних інноваційних проектів які вже
були виконані або зараз виконується
українськими вченими в Україні Я думаю
що ті люди які сьогодні нас слухають в
Ютубі або на Фейсбуці або ще послухають
побачили що можливості таки є
побачили що можливості є саме в Україні
уряд України
забезпечує ці можливості
Я думаю що ви побачили коло тих людей
які є вже не те щоб
першопрохідниками в горизонті а вже
мають достатньо досвіду для того щоб
повести не тільки свої наукові школи
слід за собою в цих проектах а повести і
інших вчених ви не побачили сьогодні
можливо
мережу представників національних
контактних пунктів які яка почне
працювати з 22-го року вже в програмі
горизонт Європа ми її ще думаємо можливо
будемо поповнювати
ви не побачили ще представників
майбутнього офісу
програми горизонт Європа Але я думаю що
вони з'являться
і
команда комунікаційна команда професійна
допоможе українцям зробити я так скажу
шутку трошки
проблеми нашому міністерству фінансів
України з точки зору того щоб сплачувати
внесок програму горизонт Європа там
через два плюс роки після відповідного
року в плані кількості тих проектів
фінансування тих проектів які будуть
виконуватись українськими організаціями
українськими вченими в рамках горизонту
Та Юра тому
все що треба буде зробити Міністерство
ту свою домашню роботу Міністерство буде
виконувати
все що необхідно в плані комунікацій
наступні роки ми будемо покладати цю
візійну роль на всіх вас на команду
університетів наукових установ державних
підприємств на бізнес
тобто тільки такий з енергетичний ефект
такий зв'язок дасть можливість
Україні зробити прорив в технологіях
одне Міністерство освіти і науки
окремо там дії Національної академії
наук України окремі дії бізнесу чи
окремих міністерств до успіху не
приведуть і це одна з візійних програм
Європейського Союзу яка якраз і є
євроінтеграційною
тому
сподіваюсь що у нас у нас у всіх вас і у
нас все вийде Всім дякую і до наступних
зустрічей на наступних наших заходах Ну
що ж дуже дякуємо Григорій мазалевич
засняк виконуючи обов'язки генерального
директора директорату науки та інновації
Міністерства освіти та науки України
Дуже дякуємо дуже дякуємо за ці слова
дуже дякуємо за все те що Міністерство
освіти науки робить для того аби власне
посту був аби розвиток був і аби
перспектива для науковців для
інноваторів завжди була перед нами
завжди втілювалась у життя Дякуємо дуже
дякуємо за ці напутні слова Дякуємо
Григорія Миколайовича за цю ту роботу
яку робите для того аби інновація в
Україні бути ну що ж це був Григорій
мозолевич виконуючий обов'язки
генерального директора директора та
науки та інновацій Міністерства освіти
та науки України Дякуємо дуже Ну що ж
колеги нар-захід добігає завершення Ну і
власне на завершення і ти кредит творити
мріяти досягати рухатись у напрямку до
нових горизонтів і нехай європейська
перспектива нехай європейських горизонти
завжди відкриваються перед усіма нами
усім також можемо успіху вдосконалення
подальших звершень Ну і бути попереду
планети усієї для того аби ваші проекти
ваші ідеї ваші здобутки втілились у
життя усіх Також ми вітаємо усім також
можемо Дякуємо за участь у
сьогоднішньому заході Ну і власне Так
тримати і ти вперед Дякуємо друзі і до
зустрічі на наступних ініціативах від
проекту горизонт Європа Дякуємо за те що
сьогодні були з нами і до нових
зустрічей у прямому ефірі у живому ефірі
і уживому спілкуванні із презентаціями
неймовірних проектів Дякуємо успіхів до
зустрічі
[музика]